[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
well hello early in the morning
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome to a special
edition
a live edition of as we react to
the marjorie puff foot green
marjory taylor green
earrings
they have just they have just commenced
they're standing up right now
as you see them um let's let's turn up
the the volume here and see if we can
hear
we are going to react live
to this hearing um if you guys
don't know marjory taylor green is being
questioned rather she can run for her
seat
it's really hard to hear they don't have
this mic worth a damn
no no no you need to turn up your
microphone
we can't hear you over here
no talking to the microphone
talking to the microphone there's
marjorie taylor green setting up they
all cheered
as she entered the room
um you know in pure fascist style
yay
yay the
okay let's see here
some obvious things but they bear
repeating this is important hearing uh
these are important things
we need to have respect
proceeding
it's
this is our big courtroom but it's quite
good morning karen
hi how are you
i'm good they're just getting started
uh it seems like you're careful they're
they're the volume is is getting better
they're the ball you're getting a bit
they're they're just uh they're just
going through the core proceedings here
you're you're very familiar with some of
this stuff um as as as a an attorney and
a prosecutor it spent time in a
courtroom um when she came in they all
cheered yeah yeah yeah the fascist is
here and then um she sat down and
they're going through you know some of
the rules and stuff i'm sure like hey
this is a very important proceeding that
sort of thing can you tell us as we
listen in
what why this is so important
absolutely i mean this is a
i would say an unprecedented
uh court proceeding or hearing i mean i
think the whole world is going to watch
this because this is a very
unique
um kind of hearing you know these types
of disqualification hearings are usually
things about is the person
old enough or you know it's it's
disputes about things you know things
like that here this is
this is this is the kind of
disqualification hearing that i don't
think anyone's ever seen or or
watched before and i think a lot of
people are tuning in to see what exactly
are they going to ask her what's the
proceeding going to be like is she going
to testify is she going to be put under
oath
she testifies
yeah so this is like like most court
proceedings um that you don't see on law
and order
uh
there's this whole there there are some
rules and procedural things that all
judges do
at the beginning of any whether it's a
hearing or a trial you know they sort of
it's almost ministerial you know things
that just have to be done and and that's
what this judge appears to be doing
right now um so we'll see you know we'll
we'll see this this doesn't
to my knowledge this hasn't really
happened in our lifetimes right like not
to my knowledge i mean it's it's not
something that we know about i mean so a
lot of people have questions what what's
the burden of proof what's this what are
the what type of evidence are they going
to put on is she going to testify right
is she going to
um be put under oath you know and swear
to tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth so help you god
and the reason you swear people under
oath is so that if they don't tell the
truth you later potentially could
prosecute them for perjury
so i mean it's you know this is serious
this is a very serious proceeding
because
you know it's it's at the very core of
our democracy whether someone gets to be
put on a ballot and run for office or
not i mean this is a really important
a really important thing that's
happening here you know i have questions
about about how
how
what do they have to prove or to show to
um call her an insurrectionist or you
know to
or or to say she engaged in insurrection
and then therefore be in violation of
the 14th amendment of the constitution
you know is it is it do you have to be
convicted of it or is it enough to just
show that you participated in it or what
kind of finding does the judge have to
make here so so all of these things are
are sort of interesting and and maybe
the judge is talking about it right now
and explaining these things so perhaps
we should listen let me turn it up and
we'll listen 36
dave is joining us here gabe good
morning we're listening in p44
p45
p48
p49
p51 p52 and 53 p54
p55
p57 it sounds like he's auctioning
cattle i don't know this is what uh when
i was younger this is you know you'd
have the uh all the cattle would be
tagged as numbers and letters so that
you could keep track of the inventory so
i don't know what he's doing here but i
thought we walked into a bingo game so
yeah
bingo
barely looks like a courtroom i mean it
clearly is itself
363 p64 p65
again when when marjorie taylor green
did enter the room everyone started
cheering um because she's obviously
stacked in the room with uh
a piece of before with her fans i'm sure
courtrooms are public right now
like my mug
thank you the legal af mug yeah but you
know the problem branding yeah but you
know what i don't like about it i'm
about to criticize it
if i'm if you're right-handed like most
people are oh you don't get it it's on
the wrong side it's on the wrong side so
i can't even shamelessly promote it by
just drinking you know we'll call them
all the suits we'll call the suits we'll
call this
just write it in right i mean don't you
agree i should be able to you know
pretend you know
like you know
i didn't realize what i'm doing
those are all in
uh
i will if council want to perfect
objections at this point or raise
[Music]
yeah i mean i believe i mean i believe
this is what i went through yesterday
there were a couple of items that i
didn't have a chance to review until
today
yeah
one second sure
all right your honorary good passion
okay i'm stephen arjun
know him
not well not well okay
okay i'll try to speak to it more
directly thank you thank you
go ahead uh sorry your honor i i thought
yesterday you admitted p15
these these p15s p20s these must be
pieces of evidence that they're
submitting yeah so p
probably here's uh stands for plaintiff
um so
that's how you that's how you would
distinguish
um
like so for example in a criminal case a
criminal federal case you would the
prosecutor's exhibits would be
gx-1
so government exhibit one
or dx
20 you know defense exhibit 20. so in
here the plaintiff is the person suing
marjorie taylor green so that she can't
re-run for her seat exactly
exactly so this is this is a um
this is a group of people who have come
together who are the plaintiff and and
suing her saying she's not qualified
it's five people right
i'm not sure actually yesterday i'm not
sure how many times he is
women
oh yes let me look at these because it
seems like they're having trouble
sorting out how many yes those are those
are what it was 80 81 and 80
81 and 83. what they're doing now is
they're
trying so in order to admit an exhibit
in real life
you have to ask a bunch of foundation
questions you know do you recognize this
what do you recognize this to be is this
a fair and accurate depiction of what
you know and it and i think what they're
trying to do is
as many documents and exhibits into
evidence as you can
that both sides agree on and so that
you're saying the plaintiffs are trying
to admit these interviews i think both
sides typically what they do is let's
let's all agree with what are all the
exhibits let's make the arguments now so
that when we ask questions of the
witnesses i don't have to sit here and
do all these foundational questions that
can take forever and they're very
tedious so they're probably right now
they're doing some streamlining to try
to make things more efficient
so kind of like jury selection you both
have to agree that
this is the actual juror that you're
okay with yeah if if you want to agree
in advance of the things that you're
going to admit and then you ask the
judge you know and the judge is right
now ruling on what he is going to
say yes or no
can this come in can this not has the
has the judge reviewed this evidence
beforehand or is he just kind of like
offhand based on the description he's
being given right now
just being so okay
he mentioned that
uh he did this yesterday so
um
i would assume that he's reviewed it all
and that he get arguments from both
sides as to
what things are and why but here we go i
think we're about to we're about to
begin as we discussed as we've discussed
we're going to proceed
i'm going to i'd like to begin with
these statements uh well before we begin
anything uh
miss bob anything that you want to
discuss before we start building stuff
[Music]
all right good so what we're going to do
is we'll start with opening statements i
like to have both of them at the same
time the burden in this case is on the
petition right preponderance of the
evidence so they will get to go first
we will
and then we'll proceed i think you just
noticed that he said the burden of proof
is on the plaintiff so they're bringing
the case they have to prove that she is
an insurrectionist and not so many words
i guess thank
you and please court sir ron fine on
behalf of the
voters in georgia's 14th congressional
district to file this challenge
and with me of course are andrew sam
shakiro diamond wells
brian sells and of course our council
watching
your honor this is a solemn occasion
this is not politics this is not theater
this is a serious case
that the voters
we represent have brought
in order to offer proof that their
united states representative seeking
re-election
marjorie taylor greene having taken the
oath to support the constitution then
broke that oath and engaged in
insurrection
and in order to
understand that case it's important to
set the stage with some history
there have been past insurrections in
this country we're going to hear about
some of them the most important of which
was civil war or as it was called at the
time
the insurrection
and professor gerard magliaca who is one
of the nation's foremost constitutional
historians
of that era specializing in
reconstruction in the 14th amendment
we'll talk about some of that history
what was interesting about some of the
differences between these past
insurrections is that the civil war
involved states raising armies they
equipped them with uniforms insignia
state-of-the-art military equipment they
marched in columns they occupied huge
tracts of land
that is not the only type of
insurrection that this country has seen
professor maglia will also talk about
some of the previous insurrections that
were on the minds of 19th century
americans those include shae's rebellion
also known as shay's insurrection the
whiskey rebellion
these insurrections were of a different
character they were not quite as
organized as the civil war the
foot soldiers of those insurrections
didn't march in armies they didn't
conquer vast swaths of territory and
they certainly didn't wear uniforms
that is the kind of insurrection that
occurred on january 6th
the evidence will show a violent assault
on the united states capital
that the law enforcement and ordinary
authorities were unable to control
that this violent assault had multiple
purposes those included
capturing and executing the speaker of
the house of the united states
representatives
the vice president of the united states
other members of congress
those purposes also included and for a
time achieved
preventing
the certification of the electoral votes
for the president incoming joseph r
biden
and
the disruption of the peaceful transfer
of power
this attack on the sacred temple of our
democracy the united states capital was
unprecedented
and to be sure it was less organized
than some of those past insurrections
this was not a case where the leaders
were on horseback leading the charge
this was not the type of insurrection
where the leaders were
standing in richmond virginia giving
long-winded speeches to justify the man
rather the leaders of this insurrection
of whom there were a number
were among us
on facebook on twitter on corners of
social media that would make your
stomach hurt
the evidence will show
that marjorie taylor green
was one of them
in order to understand that january 6th
has to be set in context it didn't arise
out of nowhere
even before january 6
as december 2020 turned into
january of 2021
there were multiple
shifting tactics used by
different groups some violent extremist
groups some
non-violent groups all
loosely coordinating
all with a shared central aim of
preventing the certification
of joseph biden as president
the tactics shifted
the different leaders jockeyed for
position
some were in violent extremist groups
some more elected officials some are
influencers of various types you'll hear
about them you'll hear about
these different uh figures some of whom
isolated themselves from
uh
from some of the action with layers of
deniability some more plausible than
others
there'll be direct evidence they'll also
be inferential evidence
and that inferential evidence includes
coded language let me explain what i
mean by that the evidence today does not
include
surveillance tapes purporting to show
that marjorie taylor green was directing
the plotting of the attack that's not
going to happen today the witness list
today does not include a turncoat
witness who's going to come and risk
their own exposure by testifying
that he or she was ordered by marjorie
tyler green to take certain actions in
secret that's not the type of evidence
that we are going to present today
rather
the way that insurrections are organized
nowadays
is less in uniforms with military
hierarchies and chains of command less
with detailed military plans of battle
and more
through social media and the mass media
that's the era that we're living in in
many cases the communications have
multiple layers
and anyone who knows a teenager is a
teenager or knows anyone in their 20s
knows that hashtags and memes and ways
of communicating among internet
subcultures can mean
that words that could have one meaning a
benign or even a baffling meaning to
large portions of the american public
can carry a very
different significance
to the people swimming in that
particular subculture
so the most important witness today
after professor maguloyaka testifies the
most powerful witness against marjorie
taylor green's candidacy
the most powerful witness in
establishing
that she crossed the line into
engagement of insurrection
is marjorie taylor green herself
you'll hear her words of course on the
stand
what she says and what she doesn't say
you'll also hear what she said in the
past again some of that will be
in somewhat coded or veiled language but
you'll also hear
in some cases
the mask falls and she shows us exactly
what she intended
now she was not on the capitol steps
urging the uh attackers to to breach
police lines and smash through the doors
on january 6th that was not the role
that she played different figures within
this larger effort had different roles
but what became clear as december turned
into january as
lawful means of preventing the
certification of joe biden were
exhausted as
non-violent even if unlawful means were
exhausted is that marjorie taylor green
nonetheless played an important role
and her role even after she took the
oath on january 3rd
to
uphold the constitution and defend it
against all enemies foreign and domestic
it was several fold
to
bring people to dc again not by
providing trains and buses that would
transport them directly
but rather through other means to
contribute in the planet
and to signal that january 6th would be
as she said herself on january 5th
our
1776 moment
coded phrase with great significance
in fact it turned out to be
an 1861 moment
instead of violence against the foreign
empire as we saw in
1776 she urged and encouraged and helped
facilitate violent resistance to our own
government
our democracy and our constitution
and in doing so she engaged in exactly
the type of conduct
that triggers
disqualification under section 3 of the
14th amendment which is to say she
engaged in insurrection
thank you
thank you
you should have spent more time
talking about what she did i i'm
concerned about the evidence because he
didn't really talk about what she did
and he should have i mean it's clear
there was an insurrection it's clear
that
uh you know all of the elements are
there except what about her and i'm
concerned that the most he said was she
used coded language right yeah i mean
yeah mentioned that a few times yeah so
i i'm
like see what the evidence is but this
i'm already a little concerned
in your honor this is a court of law
this is not a political candidate today
this is not a place for
political hyperbole
it is not a place for political smear
it's a court of law
and what we just heard
it was not a word
about the law
what does the 13th uh section 3 of the
third of the 14th amendment mean
what does the word insurrection mean
what does the word engage mean
not a word
it was not a word about the first
amendment
that prevents normal political speech
and hyperbole from being used against
someone
not a word
they think they're in the wrong place
well i plan to talk about the law
what does this
mean
this
very serious charge
that has
very broad ramifications to the rights
of representative greene the voters in
his district and our democracy
first
the right to vote is at stake
right here right now
because they want to deny the right to
vote
to the thousands of people in the 14th
district of georgia by having
grain removed from the ballot
those voters have a right to vote for
the candidate of their choosing
and they have a right to have their vote
counted
now the primary is may 24th
absentee ballots have already been
printed
they will be mailed on may the 2nd
and early voting starts on may 7th
and what is their hope is that there
will be a decision by the secretary of
state
right before the primary
where she is immediately struck from the
ballot
and those people that go into the
polling place
cannot vote for their candidate of their
choice
because by utilizing this procedure
the substantial constitutional and
federal law
violations
that this candidacy challenge
presents
cannot be decided by this court
unlike civil court or criminal corps
which will
always prioritize
deciding issues of that magnitude
before being subject to a trial
before
being penalized
by disqualification
and before the irreparable harm that
will occur if that occurs
but that's the nature of the procedure
when can representative green raise her
constitutional
defenses like
the evidence you're presenting violates
the first amendment to the constitution
when are we going to be able to litigate
that question
in state court
after she's disqualified after she's
stripped from the ballot maybe after
the primary occurs and she loses well
nobody can vote for and obviously loses
it
well what do they
okay
how do we recover from that how do we go
back from that
these are these are irrevocable this is
harm to the voters and to the candidate
now second
our democracy is at stake
it should not be it should be the voters
not government employees public
officials judges and lawyers to decide
our elections
voters have a right to vote for the
candidate of their choice
unless there is very compelling legal
not rhetorical
justification for that
third and which is not present here
third fundamentally first amendment
rights are at stake
not only the right to vote as i've
mentioned or the right to run for office
but also the challenges we'll try to use
the first amendment protected political
speech of representative green as
evidence of quote
engaging in an insurrection or rebellion
that's unconstitutional and should not
be allowed
and finally
the charge not only triggers
disqualification
but is a serious federal criminal
offence
that she is being charged with
now this is a very serious matter and
the decision should be based on
admissible evidence under the rules
we are
we recognize that you have greater
latitude than that
uh but
the the charges the seriousness of the
charges we think warrant that adherence
and faithful application of the law
and we expect you
that you will do that
now procedure
georgio up and here i am talking about
the law
georgia for law
2192-5 permits a candidate challenge
under two circumstances one
a candidate a candidate is not qualified
to be a candidate
all right
and number two
is a candidate is not qualified to take
office
of course either different
different conceptually and different in
their application
so
a claim under
section 3 of the 14th amendment has to
do with
what your your ability to take office
because it not
it doesn't address candidacy in any way
it's the ability of a representative in
this case to take office
because
she has
sworn the oath of often
engaged in insurrection or rebuilding
congress has not
given her amnesty
and finally she when she presents
herself
to take the ozo oath of office she could
be challenged
which we think is the exclusive
constitutional right of convert
not
state officials to decide
whether or not she is eligible at that
time to take office
so
we're not dealing with a candidacy
disqualification we're dealing with a
alleged take office qualification
now
unfortunately as i mentioned
many of these issues cannot be decided
by this court
even though you might make
recommendations of the secretary of
state on the net
and we have fully briefed this already
in our motion to dismiss and to stay in
proceedings
the
constitutional claim the federal law
claims the protections of the first
amendment speech and debate
and what these
words in section 3
mean
so let's look at that
all right
we have our we uh defended the evidence
is r2 which is the 14th amendment and it
includes course section 3.
and section 3 provides
that no person shall be a senator or
representative in congress
etc etc
who
having previously taken an oath as a
member of congress for an officer of the
united states
to support the constitution shall
have engaged in insurrection or
rebellion against the same
or given aid and comfort to the enemies
there
so there's a sequence
you have to have originally taken you
you have to then engage
and then you can't you are disqualified
and congress can determine that you're
disqualified for having done that from
taking a subsequent vote
and therefore cannot assume your your
position as a member of congress
and then furthermore but congress may by
a vote of two thirds of each house
remove such disability
and of course that's the
various amnesty acts that have been
adopted or could be adopted by congress
now this
provision
as i mentioned makes it clear this is
about eligibility on january 3rd
2023
not today
not tomorrow
but eligibility when she presents
herself as a re-elected member of
congress
she could be
excluded under the exclusive power of
congress to judge the qualifications of
this members
that's
where these people should be
in congress
explaining why she
uh once she is reelected is disqualified
from taking her seat
now
makes clear
is that
in her case she took the office first
for the first time and these are in our
stipulated facts right
on january the 3rd that's that's the
first time
and so she would have had to engage in
insurrection or rebellion after january
3rd
in other words under the
the constitution
prior to january 3rd
she could have done
done it
under the law
now it's preposterous that she would
even consider her
she
she
she
reveres the united states constitution
but uh the way the statute or the
constitutional provision is set up
she would have to have engaged after
so
evidence of anything she did prior to
january
is just
completely irrelevant
to the section three
unless it is direct
a direct admission
of her intention to engage in
uh insurrection or rebellion after
january 3rd
anything else she did is not only it
should be excluded because it doesn't
fit
the charge right
but as i will soon demonstrate it is
protected by the first amendment
now here
words matter
and at every turn the challengers
mistake what the law is in their
complaint
obviously they didn't discuss it here
but in their complaint
and calling something something
doesn't make it something calling a
orange an apple does not make the orange
an apple
an orange has characteristics
that
are pre-established
and are applied to determine whether the
word apple
applies
here
the key phrases in
section 3 are themselves
defined
by the law
now
they start off
in miss stating the law
by saying
that
representative green should be
disqualified under section three this is
also called by the way the
disqualification claw
because she is someone who quote aided
and engaged
in an insurrection and a quote
complaint page one
aided and engaged
where is that in section three
it says
engage in insurrectional rebellion
or gave aid or comfort to the enemies
thereof
there's no aided
and engaged in this
in this
uh in this statute
now
each of those phrases
engaged in insurrection or rebellion
that phrase and the and it's or
accompanying uh
phrase gives aid or comfort to the enemy
zero
each of those have special meaning
engage is
an act
it is
a direct and over act at
uh uh of rock's
insurrection
it is about as one commentator said
domestic war
that's what engaged in insurrection
rebellion is
about
the or
giving aid or comfort to the enemies
as the same commentator said is about
foreign wars
each of these phrases have been used
several times in federal law
and have come to
gain
particular meaning their words of art
so you can't take
aid
out of the second part about foreign
wars and add it to the first part that
is about domestically
that defies the rules of construction it
flaunts the the uh technical and
uh uh and uh
meaning of those phrases of those words
so what is engaged and what does it mean
well engage connotes conduct
a direct over act of
insurrection to overthrow the united
states government
it is about things like
which the people who drafted this well
understood many of them were
part of the victorious thank the lord uh
union army
and they
they knew what an insurrection of
rebellion was
so it was taking up arms voluntarily
joining the confederate army it was
about
working in the war department
for the confederate government
it was about
providing supplies and equipment and
material for the people who
were conducting the war
so these were
direct overt acts of insurrection
now
instead of
looking to that
what we have already heard
described as their evidence and of
course is well revealed in their
complaint
they want us they want to hold against
her first amendment protected speech
and here's a few examples
uh on uh page 19
quote the people will remember the
patriots who stood for election
integrity
that is supposed to be
about an insurrection or engaging women
insurrection
or they said she said she's alleged to
have said
uh quote congress is the last line of
defense
from a stolen election end of quote on
page 21.
isn't that quintessential political
speech
isn't that recognizing the role of
congress and certifying the electors
how could that be interpreted as
inc
as an over act to engage in insurrection
or rebound
well
it can't be
uh
and
now
the question of voter fraud in the 2020
election it was a quintessential example
of political speech
legitimate political disagreements
about what happened
yeah you know a supreme court in
republican party in minnesota versus
white
actually the first one i argued
in the court uh said that announcing
views on disputed legal or political
issues is at the core of the personality
at the core
now this is
disputed
no question
but
but to say that is an act of
insurrection it is a
old direct overt act of insurrection
against the united states
when gentlemen representative greene was
an elected member of congress who on
january 6 had a constitutional duty and
responsibility to be on the floor where
she was
to
determine whether or not
certain votes uh electoral votes from
from the states would be certified
now the first amendment demands a very
narrow test
i've already said
and argued that
engage
is canoes condo
but we can look to
a
much broader term that actually allows
speech to be considered
and that is the brandenburg case in the
naacp case which we thought
and that is the word in
incitement
now incitement and
engage are different words with
different meanings
and in fact you know that for sure
the reason he is
talking about incitement or engage
is because
incitement is the type of speech you're
actually not the first amendment does
not protect you
so that's why he's going down this this
hole
that the supreme court has said
so in other words insurrection is not
protected by the first amendment is
supreme court because the first one
correct well he's saying well
insurrection is not protected but he's
saying it requires conduct or requires
you to do something right and the
plaintiff or the petitioner's theory is
that the words here was was the action
it was the doing something
and he's saying no the words were free
speech but the thing is your the the
right to free speech is not unlimited so
for example i can't run in you know the
example that's been given
historically is i can't run into a
crowded movie theater and scream that
there's a fire and then people run out
and get trampled you know and i say oh
free speech i can say whatever i want
you're not allowed to do certain
speech is not unlimited protected and
one of the things that is not allowed is
something called incitement like to
incite violence to encourage violence to
incite a riot you know so that's one of
the exceptions that you're not allowed
to do so what he's trying to do is
thread this little needle
saying that
that to incite is not the same as to
engage because this because it says
engage in an insurrection it doesn't say
in
an insurrection
it's very interesting you know and right
continue to listen but you know the
first thing that comes to mind in this
is is a general concept that i would say
you know if when you're on the defense
if you've got the facts on your side you
argue the facts if you but if you don't
have the facts on your side then you go
to the law
so far all he's talked about is the law
right yeah
that signals to me that he's worried
about the facts yeah he's done he's done
a lot of
he's he's debating semantics right now
he's like it's not they said and it says
or
no he's arguing about an and versus nor
you're absolutely right so that signals
like i said that he's worried about the
facts well because the facts are is that
marjorie taylor green did use her speech
to incite right yeah i mean i mean so
could you look at the video that was the
night before when she comes out she's
like hey everyone just had a meeting
really excited about you know like uh
not certifying the election like would
you consider that like obviously it
wasn't on january 6 but would you
consider that absolutely absolutely yeah
that's really important you know the
other thing that i thought was
interesting was he was saying
anything before january 3rd she hadn't
taken the oath yet so you know so so
because she wasn't a sitting person of
correct and they're right that still
doesn't mean she wasn't inciting an
insurrection yeah but she's allowed to
that's what he's saying that maybe not
maybe she could be maybe so you're
allowed you're allowed to incite an
insurrection if you're
i'd say a federal court might have
something to say about that so you're so
there's two separate issues right she
could be prosecuted for it right but
he's specifically saying it doesn't
disqualify her from holding office
because this is all about
disqualification for holding office
right this is a civil this is a civil
case another thing it's not even civil
it's administrative
one of the other arguments he made was
we're not even in civil court he's like
this is an administrative proceeding so
you know there's a lot to unpack and i'm
taking notes so i don't forget to say
any of these things when you know when
we have a downtime and i don't mean to
be not no go ahead listen guys
but but he's he's like i said he's
focusing on the law and on these legal
because he wants to hang his hat on the
fact that you know that basically
it says and not or says or not and i
mean he's really threading a needle here
to try to get the judge to to get her on
this ballot he's saying because the
judge makes the decision right like
there's no jury no jury here right
correct because the other thing here
that he's saying is he's he had the
whole arm before he went into semantics
he was like well it's their right to
have someone on the ballot but i could
also argue that the guy in north dakota
who died of copen in 2020 was still on
the ballot and he won
so i'm pretty sure there's precedent for
people who have not run through various
means in terms of being able to hold
office yeah so he's talking about
yes and he's making a few arguments he's
saying
judge you're the wrong this is the wrong
place to have this argument this
argument belongs either in civil court
where we can discuss the constitution
and her constitutional rights
or to congress you know once she's
elected you go to congress and then you
try to disqualify her so he's trying to
just get her on the ballot and get her
elected and then get the can down to
congress to make the argument there
he's also saying that he's when he says
um that the law requires you to be sworn
and then
um
and then you you know you swore to hold
the constitution and then you can't
engage in an insurrection that he's
saying she wasn't sworn until january
3rd therefore everything before that's
irrelevant to whether she can be on the
ballot and he's saying that because he
wants that and he's so he or criminal
but not right but not
anything regarding the election so he's
saying that in order to prevent and
preclude any evidence because i there
must be things before january third i'm
sure you can find something on her but
isn't there isn't there a case to be
made even though she hadn't taken the
oath she had already her vote had
already been certified right right so i
mean even though she hadn't stood there
and took the oath she still was no she
has to take the oath but i would still
make the argument that it's relevant
towards her intent on january 6. whether
that conduct was
technically you know i would say it's
still admissible and relevant you know
but that's why he's i'm just telling you
why he's saying that
transfer to someone else right anyway so
those are sort of
the thoughts i have so far but why don't
we do that
yeah i don't know what that is
when a heckler i think it's i think it's
on the uh the broadcasting
let me meet my mic and see the congress
you know the house and they have to
suspend
it's gone now
must be me
my dog is snoring underneath my like
right here underneath my desk too so um
i don't know what that maybe maybe it's
the dog snoring yeah
but i would say the other thing he moved
now so we might have to the other thing
about this too is like
you could you know you could argue all
you want to say she wasn't a city man or
a member of congress so you know she
should still be on the ballot but the
same time it's like well i can also
demonstrate intent right like she ran
for office she knew she won
yep and just like just like lauren
bobert and her you know uh
capital tours and what have you like
there's there's intent there there was
planning and intent before
taking office all right there's a
transition period here where you were
elected and you took office and you knew
exactly what you were going to do
what you were going to say and how you
were going to act like here's the thing
two days after she's elected she's
already having meetings about january
6th with the president of the united
states
seems like something's going on here
that yeah
i mean look and the other thing too is
you know and and the the judge said this
in the beginning he said the burden of
proof so what the petitioner has to
prove
is um is that you know she is not
qualified by a preponderance of the
evidence and that's what that means is
so there's different burdens of proof so
in a criminal case you have to prove
beyond a reasonable doubt so that's the
highest burden of proof
to prove something by the preponderance
of the evidence that's literally just
greater than 50
so
it's like you know you can put a feather
on a scale and it tips it to 50 points
01
and that's it you've met your burden
so it'll be interesting it's not a high
burden that that the petitioner has to
prove here and finally
let's let's listen and see what he says
he's saying
an insurrection
juxtaposed what the insurrection is and
what an insurrection isn't
it says an insurrection is an organized
and armed uprising against authority or
operation
of government sorry there is zero doubt
that this was an
insurrection right the only question
in the insurrection
there was an insurrection well because
she doesn't have that
right she doesn't have to actually carry
the guns right like like it wasn't in
direction
right she doesn't have to like swing the
gun on her back and go into the
to be
to me there's zero doubt that this was
an insurrection the only question is was
she engaged well and retta this judge
will agree with that too i guess
the other question
let's listen
now
we have stipulated
that
a group of people this judge's side
unlawfully entered the united states
capital on january
and they did
i mean
more about i say more than that about
what happened
as i just have before your report that
your honor on behalf of representative
green excuse me
yeah i apologize mr bob um
mr hamilton
sorry
that's our my guy who needs to help us
with the sound
oh okay there we go it is the courtroom
the judge just did the judge just said i
need help they're hearing the sound in
the corner as well okay so just for
everyone listening and watching it is
not us
it is the court
by the way this is like central casting
old white guys you know
all three like the the petitioner's
lawyer the defense lawyer it's just well
the the the defense lawyer put my dog to
sleep um
he's he's moved now but he was snoring
right underneath my feet and i didn't
realize it because i had my headphones
on but gabe pointed it out to me
privately and um so
he even put my dog to sleep
i don't know as a woman lawyer it just i
wish sometimes it wasn't it wasn't this
all the time right the judge too
yeah if there is conduct
that meets the term engagement it
probably does smell really like moth
balls
real close to the front there
i would imagine breaking into the
capital that would be an engagement
sorry
did your grandparents smell like balls
my grandparents smelled like they would
keep a bag of mothballs in the i don't
know they had mothballs in the drawers
yeah clothes smell like that so yeah
there was happen to all the moths that
used to exist
like it's like they went away well they
they mothballed them out of existence i
guess i suppose
now
what you will see
is pertinent evidence
about what you did
from us
from january third
until
uh the end of the day on january 6th
he he won't let him yeah he's sticking
to that january third that on january
3rd and we stipulated she was sworn in
she met with president trump about
making
objections
to certain states electoral votes very
very odd that
a very green
junior
congress person would be meeting he
wasn't sworn in
right
seems convenient doesn't it yeah
you will see
that on january 6th
and of all the tweets
and all the videos
do you think this guy knows what a tweet
is we are presenting this
i'm just asking like a handwritten
letter right during the moment when the
attack on the capital was occurring
and she is in the capital
in a dark hallway
and she said i don't know the first in
the tweet accompanying the video
which they do quote in their complaint
be safe
it sounds like he's referring to
evidence that they've submitted is that
right karen is that what you're this is
not a time for violence
this is a times for president trump and
support election integrity which they
believe they were doing on the floor of
the united states
and then the
video
i so i urge you to remain calm i urge
you to have a peaceful protest make sure
that everyone is safe and protected
and let's do this in a peaceful manner
this is this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump's poor election integrity and
support this important process
that we're going through in congress
where we're allowed to object
so this this is very important so i urge
you to speak yeah but what's it i want
to know what did your time stand for
that twelve
you know you can't like
say something and not really mean it and
just be like but i said it you know it's
ridiculous i said i was sorry yeah
exactly right
i mean after i murdered them
and then
fbi director ray testified before
a committee of congress this is r5
i was appalled
like you as addressing members of
congress
at the violence and destruction that we
saw that day
i was appalled
that you
members of congress
our
country's elected leaders were
victimized right here in the very halls
of congress
representative greene was a victim
[Laughter]
okay
i got trapped in the house fire
i was almost burned alive
because i didn't know the way out
oh my god
[ __ ] ridiculous oh
oh man
that's the
ultimate victim oh my god well it's
really crumpy it's really
nice
but to look
talking oh he's finally done oh
he's finally done start with uh
that was very long
joining us here
so so uh snow fest there
seems to be a little over we're gonna
see what they're gonna do finally
finished what seemed like watching 17
hours
but it sounds like he's going to give
his rebuttal here
here we go proceedings through their
undersigned council speculate that the
following facts are true
that the respondent is over the age of
25
and the respondent has been a united
states citizen for more than seven years
responded is inhabited in georgia
petitioners are all registered voters in
georgia's 14th congressional district
on january 3
2021 the respondent took the oath of
office to be a member of the us house of
representatives for the first time
a joint session of congress is called to
order at or around 1 pm on january 6
2021 for the purposes of opening
counting and resolving any objections to
the electoral college vote
of the 2020 u.s presidential election
and certifying the results of the
electoral college vote
a group of people that did not include
the respondent unlawfully entered the
united states capital on january 6 2021.
on january 26 2021
joint session of congress was suspended
while people were unlawfully inside the
u.s capitol
congress certified the results of the
electoral college vote after about 3 40
a.m on january 7 2021 and responded
filed her candidacy for the upcoming
midterm elections for georgia's 14th
congressional district on march 7th 2022
and filed an amended members of
candidacy on march 10 2022. we'd like to
call professor magliato okay
here we go we're just straight into this
now cool
it looks like they're going to be
calling witnesses um it looks like maybe
um even the plaintives themselves
good morning
could you just repeat your full name for
the record gerard magliapa and what's
your profession
i am the samuel r rosen professor at the
indiana university robert h mckinney
school of law what's your educational
background
i received my college degree at stanford
and my law degree from yale and can you
summarize your professional experience
since then yes i was a law clerk for one
year
and then i was an associate at the law
firm for two years and i've been a
teacher for the past 21 years
and your honor i would say that p61 his
resume has already been
admitted so we don't need to retread it
uh professor mcbecker what are your
areas of research
my main area of research is american
constitutional history and you don't
have a phd in history though i do not so
what is your experience working with
historical materials
well i do work at archives around the
united states on books that i write so
for example i've worked at the library
of congress mount vernon
chicago history museum
the national archives and as well as
other facilities that hold documents and
how much of your work has been original
historical research using original
historical materials well more than half
i mean obviously i use secondary sources
and other books and articles to do my
research thank you just a second i think
they haven't difficulty
oh
okay
yes you actually unfortunately have to
talk
uh did you need to finish that question
uh would you like me to repeat my
pleasure yes i'd say i do more than half
of my work on primary sources
and then the remainder consists of
reading the other books or articles
written about the subjects that i'm
studying
what methods do you use when you're
conducting this original historical
research well i use the same methods
that a historian would use so for
example i try to identify documents and
make sure they are authentic
i try to understand the doc so what's
happening right now is
they just read stipulations into the
record which means these are the facts
we all agree on so you don't have to
prove them this is the date she was
declared her candidacy this is the date
she was you know all these are all
technical elements of the crime
you know that that
otherwise they would have to prove
and so they're all agreeing that people
went into the capital
that it was paused for a certain period
of time so otherwise we'd be having
almost a full blown trial where they're
showing all of this over and over and
over again the stipulations mean
both sides agree and so you don't have
to prove those things
now what's happening is there's a
professor that they're putting on that
they're clearly trying to certify as an
expert and so they're calling him as an
expert
to talk about whatever he's going to
the second was the period at the end of
the 19th century one million so this
isn't a plaintiff this is an expert
witness
basically
correct i think he's setting the setting
the context or setting the stage that
this is an insurrection because in his
opening statement he tried to say you
know certain insurrections which was
like the civil war but then he said
there are other types of insurrections
that don't necessarily constitute
technical wars like the whiskey
rebellion and you know he was he was
giving other examples so i think that's
what he's trying to show here that this
wasn't a military
organized military coup
type insurrection but this was a another
sort of type of insurrection and this
counts and so that's what they're trying
to show here that this was
an
insurrection i always i always call it
the cheeto dust kangaroo
well there you go
so right now they're trying exactly so
they're trying to prove that a this is
an insurrection and then the next thing
is that she
engaged
um and i've been doing some other things
related so that's why they're going
through his resume just so that they can
certify him as and if you're fellowships
or professional recognition for this
work yes i was a fellow at non-verbal so
this is just this is just um the court
where i work giving him credibility
exactly on the record exactly and so so
there's something um there's a term of
art
in a courtroom called an expert witness
and it's it's it'll once you certify
someone an expert and you go through
these questions about their resume to
make them an expert once they're
certified as an expert
then they are allowed to give their
opinion
about something so they're gonna i i
guarantee they're gonna ask him what you
know in your opinion was what happened
on january six in
insurrection and if he were not an
expert or he's not certified as an
expert his opinions would not be allowed
uh the only thing that's allowed for a
regular witness is
is facts you're allowed to give i saw
this i did this i um witnessed that
so
but they're trying to allow get him to
be able to give opinion and that's why
they're going through this wall you know
what are your awards and publications
and schooling
newspapers have to say about
uh the pending proposal what was said in
the states the extent that we can find
out about the ratification of the 14th
amendment
so it's primarily looking to the
discussion or conversation that
americans had about the 14th amendment
when it was proposed and under
discussions
and how are these approaches similar or
different from the types of ordinary
legal analysis that lawyers and judges
well i mean there's some overlap of
course but the i focus much more in my
work on the
surrounding politics or social aspects
of what's going on at these particular
times with these particular
constitutional issues
rather than focusing more on the text or
the cases
uh so obviously you have to do some with
both but i'm more of a uh you know more
of a historian than uh than a lawyer in
that respect
your honor this time i moved to tender
professor maguiaka as an expert witness
in 19th century american constitutional
history there you go
i inject your owner uh number one uh
so this is the battle rather he's an
expert or not yep exactly
again like i said if he is bound to be
an expert he can give his opinion
uh so that we can prepare for his
testimony number three
uh he has not produced the to us
the documents that he relied upon in
order to reach whatever conclusions the
expert originally before honey this is
why
as much as i love
law shows and you know they're sorry the
stories they pick are so interesting i i
literally can't watch them because
nothing ever happens the way they show
on these shows it's really this boring
you know technical kind of long
drawn-out
stuff you know and it's not the
romanticized
i mean i wish it was but well government
government is is very boring
and that's really kind of trump's stick
is that it's not boring it's salacious
it's you know that that was always his
draw and it's it's reality tv in other
words yeah and it's really not that it
really isn't
it's true
uh oh he's indicated his art is he going
to justify essentially the contents of
his article that he wrote
you know iran the subject matter of the
questioning would address matters that
were not entirely embraced within the
context of his law in the article
and i was going back and forth whether
or not this was proper when he starts
answering asking questions and now but i
want to answer
is uh his expertise
expertise
and what he has
said he will testify about are
quintessential
legal question
if a statute is vague
you look to the legislative history
that's what he wants to testify about
that's the legal
uh question what the legislative history
is you know interestingly
it seems ridiculous uh that they're
fighting over this because it's not like
a jury's here it's one thing to call an
expert in front of a jury and it means
something
i mean
you know the judge is gonna make his
decision he's hearing what you know he's
going to hear the facts he's going to
make his decision
it really is just theater i mean at this
point yeah i mean maybe they're maybe
he's trying to preserve an appellate
record i have no idea you know to say
the judge was wrong in certifying this
guy as a witness but as an expert i
should say
i'm struggling because
i'm i'm trying to it you know we don't i
don't know what the testimony is going
to be i mean it's a circle of question
but
i
the issue of the history of the 14th
amendment if the teachers want to spend
their time
with a history of the enactment of 14th
amendment i will listen
but i concur with you that i will not
permit and will not entertain testimony
regarding
the meaning of statutes or anything that
would be properly the subject briefly so
what i am
i will let you start but
and i would also suggest i mean to me
this all sounds like the sort of stuff
that would be coming in appropriately in
the briefing
uh and if you have articles and
authorities and original documents that
you wish to cite i'm happy to read
but the judge is saying you should have
put all this in your papers and argued
it
right and it's not appropriate to just
put it on as a witness without a full
legal analysis in papers
i will judge
yeah he's going to let him start and see
where he goes
but the judge basically saying i don't
want to be told what the law is by
someone else
is this a federally appointed judge or
is this a state judge state this is a
state administration
i just want to make sure that everyone
out there listening knows that this is a
georgia state judge
after the civil war elections were held
across the south for congress and for
the senate and some of the people who
won had been leaders in the confederacy
they arrived in washington seeking to
take their seats
northern public opinion was outraged at
this because these were some of the same
people who had led secession
so
those members were excluded from
congress and then
consideration was given to some formal
proposal that would exclude them for
some period of time afterwards
and who are the primary framers of this
so section 3 of the 14th amendment was
drafted by senator jacob howard of
michigan
and it was
narrower than the original proposal that
had been put forward in the house of
representatives so the house proposal
for section 3 would have prohibited
all former confederates from voting in
federal elections until 1870.
so the senators considered that too
broad and unfair
so the substitute drafted by senator
howard focused instead on office holding
rather than voting and did not apply to
anyone who had been engaged in
insurrection instead it applied only to
officials either current or former and
civil or military
um on the thought that it was the
leaders of the insurrection who should
be
held accountable rather than
ordinary followers
and in developing section 3 the 14th
amendment did the framers look to any
historical examples of insurrections
other than the civil war
there were other examples but there was
nothing cited
specifically in the debates in congress
about
that provision
what uh if any uh historical
instructions were well known for
reasonably educated mid 19th century
americans well there were two one was
shea's rebellion which was also referred
to as shae's insurrection and the other
was the whiskey rebellion which was also
referred to as whiskey the whiskey
insurrection
uh so let's let's start with shay's
insurrection or shea's rebellion um when
anywhere did that occur
so shades rebellion occurred in
massachusetts at the end of 1786 and
early 1787 it was a tax protest by
farmers who were upset about
high land taxes
and that had led to many foreclosures of
farms so what started happening was that
groups of farmers would arm themselves
and go to local courts
to basically stop the courts from
operating so that foreclosure sales
would not happen
uh this built up to a point where the
state militia was called in to sort of
deal with this suspension of the normal
operation of the courts by the armed
people
and that led to a clash at an armory
when some of the uh
insurrectionists decided to try to take
some weapons um four people were killed
and after that the rebellion the
resurrection and
you said that their goal was to uh stop
the courts from operating
is that that's correct to prevent
foreclosure sales on farms
and
from a historical perspective what were
the key features of shae's rebellion
that would be remembered in the mid 19th
century by reasonably educated americans
well that it was an effort by armed
people to suspend the civil authority of
government for a period of time and it
was considered a significant event
because it seemed to have an influence
on the framers when they gathered in
philadelphia for the constitutional
convention because they saw it as an
example of why we needed to replace the
articles of confederation with a new
constitution and was it considered an
insurrection or rebellion or both
well so in federalist number 10 james
madison
the subtitle of federalist number 10 was
the union as a safeguard against
domestic faction and insurrection
so and he was referring to shea's
insurrection as well as some other
upheavals that had happened in the
states uh prior to that uh and then in
the 19th century a well-known book by
justice joseph story referred to the
insurrection
in massachusetts story was from
massachusetts so it probably explains
why he emphasized that point in his book
thank you uh let's talk about the other
one you mentioned the whiskey rebellion
or whiskey insurrection what was that so
the whiskey insurrection was another tax
protest uh by farmers this time on a
federal tax on whiskey and other spirits
um so farmers in pennsylvania were upset
about this and they decided to start
getting armed and trying to prevent tax
collection um they did this in various
ways sometimes they would
well in one case they tart and feather
the tax collector
uh also they would basically attack uh
places where the tax collector what
happened to tarring and feathering he
also shut down courts because again are
you saying we should turn feather to
it was a thing and now it's no longer a
thing like how does that happen
i i don't know feathers became real
expensive
there were four or five people
and basically for the most part the
insurrection has ended because of the
site of this large force led by george
washington but four or five people were
killed how well organized was the
whiskey for that
well it was a loosely organized thing
um
we're going to see local groups doing
different things there wasn't really a
single year what he's saying about the
whiskey rebellion here seems pretty
significant
and like
that it's loosely it was loosely
organized it wasn't like this grand
scheme
to
ordinary exactly that's what they're
trying to say
that this counts
and this is where they're objecting
because it it's it's starting to dig
into the facts here
well he's already conceived
that in the debate
they were talking about the civil war
not what these were colloquially called
insurrection
not the legal definition that would
sustain
the next question
if i recall your earlier testimony
correctly uh you said that uh four
people died in
shape of diamond and four or five in the
whiskey redundant
all right
they seem really nervous i don't know
are they able to use like you look at
all the other people who have been
indicted or you know convicted of
their role in the inspiration you may
not use that as president to say like
we've established this in the court
already correct
that's an interesting point you're
making
800 i can't remember how many people
were charged by the department of
justice not one has been charged with
the crime of instructions there is a
crime if they established this as
precedent could then other cases say
well this
court already established it's an
insurrection
again this is not criminal right right
preponderance of the evidence not beyond
a reasonable doubt it's sort of
different
but but you're making good points and
that's one of the curious questions is
why didn't the department of justice
charge all these other individuals with
an insurrection
so
it was such a clear insurrection so
um
we'll see
i'd like to display an exhibit that's
already been admitted into evidence
which is 81
81.
i believe this is our first piece of
evidence right that's been presented
this is going to be the first one
sort of i mean yes stipulations are
evident i mean you know yes this is
going to be probably the first thing we
see right
look at the uh why they're preparing one
more i want to let the viewers know that
we're going to stay with this and our
show starts at noon eastern yes and
we'll stick with it at noon eastern
we'll just flip over to a different
uh broadcast and we'll give you that
lincoln how was that dictionary used in
1830 and afterwards well it was the
leading dictionary in the united states
during this period
and excuse me what what period we talked
about
1830 okay 1830 okay
uh was the dictionary updated on a
semi-regular or regular basis after that
yeah it's much like modern dictionaries
they would do a new edition every so
many years
uh but this is the 1830 edition yes
and
you're familiar with this dictionary
you've seen it before yes i am
to what extent does it inform if at all
your understanding of how words were
used in the
mid-19th century
let's turn to page
the next page
and if we could zoom in on the uh left
column
and uh
the top can you can read that's our mind
a little spicy wood okay can you zoom in
even more now
okay
can you yes i think i can can you read a
couple entries down and i'm not going to
ask you to read it aloud um
but do you uh see their uh
definitions there yes
are you familiar with if this dictionary
has a definition for insurrection yes it
does
and
what what can you without reading from
that uh that definition
is that i mean we didn't need an expert
to be called to read the dictionary
is that what's happening here
essentially yeah
i mean look it courts often look to the
dictionary to find the quote-unquote
plain meaning of words
but
well they're helpful in putting terms
into context for example if i'm reading
a letter and i'm trying to understand
what somebody meant you know sometimes
the definition that people used back
then they're defining a definition and
defining a dictionary it's fine you know
it's again this is the the wheels of
justice
again government is boring it's very
boring like as boring as it would be to
read a dictionary even
yeah government can be boring
i i don't i'm not trying to offend
anyone i try to make government
interesting but you know and uh what are
we looking at here
this is a statute a georgia statute
enacted in 1866
and why did that i think what we're not
seeing here is they're projecting these
definitions
i believe it was because of there's no
way to turn the camera basically i guess
not
we don't have control over that
i don't i i
don't have control over the i just have
control over the uh the volume uh
i don't i actually don't know whose
speed this is
i'm sorry this is very serious stuff but
what what concerns me mr bryant
is
this is what i would expect to be
reading in briefs this is not what i
expected your testimony on this is
historical data
that can be reviewed and commented on
and crawford and so forth i'm indulging
you because of the importance of this
hearing but uh
you may ask the question now if i hear
an objection
thank you your honor um
he's flustered
when
which happens happens to all of us
when the judge sure you know when the
judge sort of say he
that's because marjorie taylor green uh
probably brought those people on the
court
to do that
to do that
right yeah but the judge just said this
is not a show do not clap this is a
scenario
actually i think that was uh i think
that was margaret taylor green's defense
attorney who stood up and said that
oh really yeah i'm going to mute this so
so we'll play it here um while we're
talking um
i i i misspoke we're not going to
actually go to a different link we're
going to stay here
when we get ready here in about um an
hour and nine minutes we're just gonna
replay the intro go into the podcast if
we're still um
going into
if the hearing is still going on then
we'll actually go ahead and just keep
broadcasting it and commenting um karen
you're welcome to stay or if you have to
go and i know you have some hard outs
here today um so so anytime you need to
you know cut out just just let us know
and and but we do appreciate your your
analysis here so so far what do you what
do you think about
how this is turning out do you think
this is um what what marjorie taylor
green is looking for or do you think
that more of this is what the plaintiff
is looking for in this
so
i i think that the the petitioner here
is um a little flustered and it happens
you know when you have a plan and it's
happened to me when you have a plan
about what you're going to
uh present to court and
you
you know you're completely prepared and
the judge basically cuts the legs out
from under you and says you know i'm not
interested in hearing about this this
should have been in your papers so
don't don't do this do something else
and and one of the things about being a
lawyer and a and a trial lawyer is you
have to be able to be nimble and
you know be on your feet and uh you know
think on your feet and and be able to
change course pretty quickly and so i
you saw that kind of happen there and
the judge was very nice he said okay i
see that you're a little bit flustered
there right let's take a break let's
take a break and and judges do that you
know and it's a nice it's it's a nice
thing to do there are some times judges
aren't so nice and and and make you sort
of do it anyway but so you know you're
seeing real life not actors not scripted
kind of what it's like to be a lawyer a
courtroom lawyer and a litigator so
really what the petitioner's lawyer is
going to do is they're going to um
regroup and and try to reframe this
witness to talk about the things that
the judge says
i will allow and not the other things
that uh that they won't allow but
what would concern me a little bit so
far about what i've seen is the
petitioner both the petitioner
and the um and marjorie taylor-green's
lawyer
neither one of them have really talked
about the facts so i i don't know who's
more worried about them you know so i i
was hoping to hear you know because
there's so much news about the
insurrection and about you know the
the who did what and
and um you know i don't know how many
people could actually say this is
exactly the things that marjorie taylor
green did and i would have wanted to
hear more from the petitioner about
on this date she did this and then on
this day she tweeted that and then she
met with the president and then you know
she so basically the step by step that
just that happens that's what an opening
statement is supposed to be is is you
know kind of a a preview of what the
evidence is your story and you know
frankly he should know that this is
being uh televised on national
television practically you know all over
the world people are watching this tell
the story what are you going to show we
all know there was a violent attempt at
stopping the election and for a period
of time they did stop the peaceful
transfer of power so so we know that
that happened we know that there was you
know there's there's an insurrection
tell us what she did what was her
involvement talk about the facts you
know and and and the and again so i was
thinking that because the petitioner
stayed away from the facts i thought for
sure that the entire defense
opening was going to be you know you
didn't hear one single thing in their
opening about her being involved because
she wasn't involved and these are the
facts you know on from my side you know
she supports the constitution she loves
america she would never do these things
whatever whatever their defense is going
to be talk about the facts and then i
would go to and by the way
uh
the law also doesn't support it but to
only talk about the law i they're both
clearly worried about the facts is the
bottom line because neither one of them
talked about it so do you think they're
playing a little bit close
to the chest because they feel like
anything bigger would be
a risk to make such like accusations if
if they feel like the evidence really
isn't there no i think what they i think
what's happening is because this is a
judge hearing and judges decide the law
they're focusing on the law and that's
that's really it but that's why the the
defense attorney is focusing on the
semantics of the and verses
all of them trying to go with the apples
oranges comparisons
correct but the petitioner really
both both for the court of public
opinion and for this court should have
focused more on on the facts of what did
marjorie taylor green do and also the
fact again that they're starting with
this historical
um you know
with with uh the historical precedent
this is an insurrection again i wouldn't
have called this as as my first witness
i would have called like set the stage
you know you you are the plaintiff you
are the petitioner you're the prosecutor
so to speak you're telling the story you
want to capture
the um the the court of public opinion
you want the judge and everyone to be on
your side and to be not looking at the
and versus the or and the comma and
whatever you want them to to be like oh
wow this is bad look what she did is bad
and for you to find want me to find that
she wasn't involved and to focus on the
comma and the end versus or you got a
long you know a long road to you know
a lot a big hill to climb and and so far
the petitioner in my opinion has not
captured kind of the heart and soul of
the case or or the public opinion of the
case you know and they and they really
needed to you know if you're a democrat
if you're a democrat you're against
marjorie taylor green but guess what 50
of the country
is is on her side so you need to focus
on you know and everybody's watching
this they really need to focus on on
what did she do and they didn't
do you think madison cawthorne is kind
of watching this case closely i think
everybody's watching this case closely
don't you think well yeah i mean
specifically him because aren't the
constituents of his district also uh
coming at him with the 14th amendment to
to remove him from the ballot i know
that he was
complaining about that so yeah so he
there was a kid he brought it um the the
same people who brought this case
against marjory taylor green also um
also
are doing did the same thing with
madison cawthorne but uh you know but he
drew a different judge he drew a judge
that
is a trump supporter and um that judge
ruled the opposite of what the judge uh
in marjorie taylor-green's case um ruled
which was
uh
it's sort of a legal technicality that
that the judge in that case said that
you know that that um basically it that
it only there's a there's a statute that
um that that gave amnesty to
uh people in the civil war um you know
just to basically say you know what we
had a war but there's an amnesty that
says you you guys can run for office
you're not disqualified and so there was
this this amnesty act
and um this judge ruled that the
and that the amnesty act applies didn't
apply
to the past that it applied to the
future
and so therefore it doesn't apply to
madison cawthorne what the judge
in the marjorie taylor green case um
judge totenberg said that's preposterous
of course you know that that amnesty act
applied
retrospectively not prospectively and
and by the way the law doesn't work that
way you know there's a hierarchy in the
law and so the 14th amendment is an
amendment to the constitution that
that's a constitutional right that
trumps everything that's the bedrock the
foundation of everything that we have
if congress passes a law
that comes net that that's sort of a
lower on the totem pole right the the
constitution it's like as as michael
popock my co-host on legal af said it's
like rock paper scissors right and one
trumps the other well the constitution
and the amendments to the constitution
trump the law if
or i should say um
congressionally passed laws and statutes
so if if congress wanted to do something
uh that that was going to influence the
14th amendment to the constitution they
would have had to pass a constitutional
amendment hard to do hasn't been done in
a long long long time certainly not in
my lifetime and uh
you know so it's it's it doesn't make
any sense that that um
that cow thorn you know that that cow
um
you know
that the judge in that case ruled the
way they did but that's that's where
they are
yeah that's right so i think i think
it's all good points um
you know madison cawthorne um you know
obviously
obviously an insurrection himself as
well you know if you if you're if this
court's gonna find that marjorie taylor
green and this judge is gonna find that
she is an insurrectionist and she's
not qualified to be on the ballot um
then our assumption is that a lot of
these members of congress are not
qualified to be on ballots and i think i
think that's kind of the point here is
the uh
the political point not the legal point
because i want to go back to that
because
we talked a couple times about what kind
of court this is because is this
actually a court or is this just a
hearing to figure out if she can be on a
ballot i mean what what is this
so this is an administrative hearing
and
um it's it's a nuance i mean yes this is
a court but it's an administrative court
and this is this is um it's not a
criminal court where somebody where
liberty is determined
and where you know somebody's convicted
of crime or anything like that is
determined and it's not a civil court
where um where monetary damages are
are um
are
decided you know that's typically what
happens in in civil courts this is an
administrative court where they're
trying to decide whether under georgia
state law
administratively
she can be put on a ballot and whether
the secretary of state who has rule
making authority over the elections of
the state of georgia
whether they
uh their rule making about what
qualifies someone to be on a ballot or
not whether she's qualified you know
that there are different you know that's
why one of the things the defense
attorney was saying was um
you know is this um is she qual a
qualified candidate you know hold on i
actually took notes let me find my my
notes about what exactly they were
saying um you know but he he was saying
is this a um
you know was this was this was she
qualified to be a candidate or qualif or
qualified was she not qualified to be a
candidate or not qualified to take
office i guess those are the two things
that in georgia the secretary of state
has authority over and he's saying this
is not whether she qualified to be a
candidate you know like i guess
you have to be a certain age or you know
all that kind of you have to be a united
states citizen perhaps or not have a
criminal record i don't know whatever
the georgia qualifications to be a
candidate or he's saying that's not
what's what what the issue is here she's
qualified to be a candidate she's been
qualified before to be a candidate what
she's saying is she qualified to take
office and that that's what this is
about and the petitioner didn't agree
that this is an administrative hearing
to determine that
so so um
so you know that's where
where we are um so really quick you um
you gave me permission to uh jump
whenever i had to i don't have to leave
but i do have to press pause and uh take
care of something for five minutes
that's fine
i'll be back yeah let's let's do that
and uh because we're gonna me and gable
talk and then um we'll be right back uh
because we got the uh thing going so
we'll see here in just a minute karen
okay
so gabe um
it really it
it really is something to watch um the
theatrics here again karen alluded to it
that that government sometimes is is
really [ __ ] boring um especially when
you have moving right
especially when you have grandpa
mothballs um trying to make arguments
right for
uh marjorie taylor green in a way that
would put my dog to sleep um
into the microphone yeah
you pointed out you pointed out hey are
you snoring or is your dog
if anyone doesn't know who who are new
uh listeners here to the tony michael's
podcast um
sometimes sometimes my dog falls asleep
either on the chair in front of me or
beside me and if i'm not talking or if
there's not noise you can hear him
snoring so uh that's that's that's what
happens it looks like people are going
to be uh working their way back into the
hearing room um so we'll we'll go back
to it as soon as they start up
what what's your take on it so far as
far as your confidence
in that marjorie taylor green will not
appear on the ballot because they made a
case about the primary ballot which is
coming up right so that's that's what
everyone's trying to do is keep her off
the primary ballot and the reason why he
brought the primary about because if she
can't win the primary
she can't be in the general election
right yeah yeah
so yeah you know i i look at this and i
think you know karen made some good
points um
and you know to reiterate those is like
we definitely saw you know the defense
was just arguing semantics right like
again obviously because this is like
what is the word of the law you know
uh he's gonna he's going to
argue
uh
you know the and or because it's like oh
well it's not or which means it could be
either or they're saying that it was and
which means that technically um
marger taylor green didn't
and he's not saying that she didn't do
both of them he's saying or rather one
or the other he's like she didn't do
both of them because that's the clause
that they're using right they're using
this and
instead of an ore
um
and
yeah i look at this and i'm like i
didn't see a lot of uh you know i didn't
see evidence from the defense which or
from the from the prosecution which i
was hoping for to get something right
like here's video or like there was
video of her there were phone records
right right right
geo tagged in his areas
but i also didn't see much from the
defense either oh the judge the judge is
chastising the uh the marjorie taylor
green fans now uh basically saying quit
your [ __ ] clapping um this is this is
a hearing room this is not a goddamn
concert
looks like we're going to get back to
uh a few more minutes
um
how were the southern states governed
after we surrendered
well there were temporary civil
governments put in place uh by president
johnson but then in 1867 congress passed
the military reconstruction act to
impose essentially martial law on
almost the entire former confederacy
so for example who was governing
virginia during that period union army
general
and when was 14th amendment section 3
first implemented
so it was first implemented in the
military reconstruction acts
because those acts said that there had
to be new elections throughout the south
to elect conventions that could ratify
the 14th amendment and write new state
constitutions
and so the act provided that people who
were covered by what it described as
section three of the pending amendment
were not going to be able to vote in the
elections for those conventions and then
there had to be some means of uh
determining whether people could or
could not vote under that standard
um can we please put up exhibit p48
which has been admitted into evidence
ready
see what that is
yes this is an opinion of attorney
general stan mary
interpreting the first second military
reconstruction
when was that
this opinion is may 1867. when was the
14th amendment ratified uh in 1868 and
where was this printed this was in the
new york times it would have been widely
reprinted in new spaces across the
country
okay great uh we can put that down um
how widely was section 3 applied in the
years after the ratification of the 14
well between 1868 and 1872 it was
implemented many times mostly to remove
state and local officials who had been
part of the confederacy but also in a
couple instances to exclude people from
from office
and
what led to
it not being implemented as much so in
1872 congress exercised its power under
section three to grant an amnesty to
many of the former confederates
um
basically in part that was because there
had been private bills that had been
giving amnesty to individuals but
largely that was simply did you know a
member of congress
and then if you did they would pass a
bill for you you know i moved to strike
his first statement it was a legal
thinking and that is whether the amnesty
act of 1872
uh
removed uh gave amnesty to former
only
former officer it's a legal question
i understand i understand raise the
issue i'm going to let it stand
i mean i understand the point believe me
i understand
uh what did the debates around amnesty
in public and
streets or in congress center
there's a lack of foundation
we've got to have a little foundation
how familiar are you with the debates
that led to the 1872 i'm quite familiar
with am i read old
and what did they focus on
well they focused on whether people
deserved amnesty first of all and second
if so who should be excluded from that
um and basically would it be good for
sectional reconciliation or not
and how much of those debates centered
around ex-confederates as compared to
anyone else who might become subject to
section 3. well it was basically about
ex-confederates because those were the
people who were petitioning congress for
amnesty
just a few more questions
during the civil war itself how did
washington dc fare
well it was a fortified city
and a good reason because there was a
confederate attack by
drupal early
on the capitol in 1864 that was repulsed
at fort monroe
and were there or how many if any
presidential elections occurred during
the civil war
one in 1864 how orderly was that you
know it was very orderly
uh and how did the counting of the
electoral votes proceed
there was no problem with it at all when
if ever did the confederate
insurrectionist seize control of the
united states capital
they did not
and uh in your opinion if in 1864 or
1868 a violent mass of people could
cease to control the us capital during
certification of presidential electoral
votes he disrupted the peaceful transfer
of power wouldn't they be saying
americans have understanding you stop
that question thank you
see he asked his opinion
no further questions that's it
so in other words when he when he
started to ask the expert's opinion the
the judge stopped it because it's only
his opinion not fact is that right yeah
it seems like yeah
and i was a history major
so maybe i agree with myself
thank you very much thank you the judge
see the judge said sustained without
independence
oh here we go
game time
so this is where this is where
marjorie taylor green as i call her
marjorie hoof foot green is going to
take the stage
here
please
these are the gonna be the words under
scrutiny the most
thank you um good morning representative
i'm andy i represent the plaintiffs in
this matter
um
you were elected to congress in november
of 2020 right
yes and you became a member of congress
on january 3rd 2025 is that correct yes
and when you became a member of congress
you became a member of congress by
virtue of having taken the impose of
office right
i became a member of congress by being
elected by the people of the 14th
district okay but you actually were
permitted to take your seat in the house
of representatives
because you took an oath of office isn't
that correct i swore
and that oath requires difficult witness
she won't even support and defend the
constitution of the united states right
and
it required you to
square note that you would support and
defend the constitution of the united
states against all enemies right
yes
and part of the oath that you took
says that you were going to undertake
that obligation
to defend the constitution against all
enemies
freely without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion you recall that
part
i think so okay well let's have a look
at this will be uh plaintiff's exhibit
63 i just want to make sure
looks like we have an interruption in
the feed we're waiting for the video
signal to continue of course during the
um testimony of martyr j the green we
have a a problem with the feed it's not
on our end it's not on youtube's end um
looks like it's just a technical
difficulty there in the room there we go
maybe maybe i wish we could see what the
evidence was that they're presenting
yeah well
in perfect world you would um
i need multiple angles in this courtroom
tony
we need law and order angles right karen
is that what we need is we need a long
order angle exactly i need to close that
up over the shoulder i need to see
people in the in the dramatic pauses of
the judge the look of the of
of
of course uh we're getting no video feed
now it might be because they're trying
to maybe they are trying to move the
camera is the reason why we lost maybe
maybe the maybe the russian hackers or
oh well there you go we're really
getting deep into conspiracy now
um
no no i do it this is no it actually can
be i mean you know it could be it could
be all the the the the trump support i
mean her supporters could have hacked in
and
um it is a little weird that she took
the stand and she got one or two
questions answered and then
right we're now waiting for life i don't
know if you picked up on it that was
supposed to be an easy question you know
you you you were basically sworn in and
that's why you were a congressman like
that was supposed to be like a kind of
softball right softball like let's get
to the meat of this and she couldn't
even answer that
so it's going to be very interesting
she's going to be a tricky i really hope
this comes back because i this is going
to be she's going to be a tough witness
and this is where you need someone who
is a real seasoned litigator who can
control the courtroom control the
witness and ask the questions
uh if it doesn't come back i'm going to
go to
uh c spanish okay we have an alternative
well uh c-span has a feed so we'll go to
c-span's feed if we can't uh get this
other speed feed back yeah i would say
move over here
yeah let me let me switch it here real
quick
i'm looking forward to the law and order
episode where there's a technical
difficulty
here we go now we have a we have a
better baby
much better
wouldn't you agree
does it define that way does it define
that well i'm asking for your
understanding if somebody broke the law
in a way designed to interfere with the
process of counting the electoral
college votes
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution
you mean interrupting congress is that
what you're referring to
doing anything unlawfully to interfere
with the process of counting the
electoral votes
interrupting congress like when the
democrats she's not smart
on the house floor
excuse me
could you refresh
i'm entitled to ask my questions and the
way i'd like to ask them your honor i
ask that you listen to my question and
simply respond
may i proceed
yes
so if someone broke the law
in an effort to interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes
that person would be an enemy of the
constitution am i right about that
yes
breaking the law is unlawful there's
been over 700 people charged
for what happened on january 6th right
and those people were trying to
interfere
with the lawful process of counting the
votes for the electoral college right
i i
i would assume yes they they did they
stopped the electoral count right and so
those people would be enemies of the
constitution you would agree with that
right
say it i don't know if i don't know i
don't know if it defines it that way
well
having taken the oath that we saw on the
screen
if you were aware that someone was going
to law
do you think unlawfully they would be an
animal with the constitutional process
of counting the electoral votes
you'd be obliged by your oath to try to
stop them right
i i object uh the the client the claim
is not she violated or wrote the claim
is under section 3 of the 14th amendment
uh and so her opinion she's not a little
comfortable there
are words of art often in
the law
is just irrelevant
to uh to the matter whether or not she
engaged
did a direct and uh
overt act uh of interrupt your honor we
we we had a one hour presentation on the
law from mr bob we did not object to
that
i will let you answer the question i
forgot
can we ask for it to be right back
okay
question if you were
aware that somebody was going to
unlawfully
interfere with the constitutional
process of counting electoral votes you
would be obliged
to have them arrested or stopped right
you may answer
you may answer the question to the best
of your bill
i had no knowledge
of any attempt and so that's a question
that i can't answer well
i can't answer that question i i i take
your representation that you had no
knowledge for the for the time being i'm
asking it as a hypothetical question
just to understand
your answer
well i'm permitted to ask you one so i'm
going to ask you again if you had
knowledge in advance that someone was
going to unlawfully interfere with the
counting of the electoral votes in a
presidential election
under your oath you'd be obliged to do
something to stop that right object
she's not being charged for violating
her vote there's no
foundation laid that she had any
knowledge about anything like that we'll
come to that and so these
things
the objections show that that they're
nervous about this
different way on the
it's back and forth the judge and the
judge agreed from a few minutes ago
right the worst possible thing here
would be to get a free-flowing
you know
kind of thing the lawyer's going to
object objective objectives
knock him off his game you knew that
before you took the oath
and you took the oath anyway
and decided not to do anything
about those plans
that would be a mental reservation don't
you agree object she's not she is not
being charged with violating the elders
the question is does she engage in
insurrection or rebellion
her state of mind is relevant your honor
we think it's very important to have her
understanding what
it's relevant to whether she engaged in
insurrection during the time period from
january 3rd to january 6th and we're
going to be talking about her state of
mind all day you may come back to that
question after you have laid a
foundation for why it ties into her
activities from and after the fair
enough
fair enough drama
um ms green you're familiar with social
media right
and that's a form of communication right
yes you know what facebook is and
twitter right yeah you use those as an
important form of communication in your
work
yes you post messages on facebook right
when she's not banned yeah yeah
and you also
respond and react to other people's
comments when they're posted on facebook
or twitter right
yes
and you do that as a way to get your
political views out into the world
it's my freedom of speech to do so i
agree
um and you've been very successful at
using social media to get your
your views out of the world right
i would say that's an opinion well i'm
asking your opinion you've got
hundreds of thousands of people
who follow you
on twitter and facebook right no not
really because my twitter my personal
twitter account
doesn't exist anymore before it was
suspended by twitter
you had hundreds of thousands of people
following you on facebook and twitter
right yes and by the way
the way facebook and twitter work is my
understanding is they don't have to
necessarily follow you
to read what you have to say right
i guess so so
it could be millions of people who have
read the things that you have said on
facebook and twitter over the years
i don't know that
but it click
he would agree with that right no i
don't know that okay i don't know how
many people read or see
what i post on social media
but what you post on social media is
what you want people to know about your
political that's factually incorrect you
can actually see the impressions of your
tweets you can actually see it
sure okay you're not putting stuff up
there as a joke are you
sometimes yes
um well we'll go we'll come back to that
um
and you use facebook and twitter
to communicate with your constituents in
the 14th congressional district here in
georgia right yes
so
immediately after the 2020 election
and through january 6th even beyond that
you issued a number of
tweets and made statements on twitter
and facebook
about the election right
yes you tweeted a whole lot of material
about your views of what happened in the
2020 election yes and
the thrust of those tweets
were that you felt that the election was
stolen from the sitting president i
object
that is
you can ask the question what is your
opinion what is it well well i also want
to ask whether she communicated that
opinion through
well let's do it that way your honor i i
take your point
where are you going with this counselor
i'm going to show the witness a number
of her tweets and i wanted to make sure
that i understand the context of them
that's all
well she said she posts on twitter right
and my question is whether she posts
material that reflect the opinion that
you have strike that ms green you you
had
you had the opinion between november
2020 when the election happened and
january 6th
2021 that the election was stolen from
president trump
am i right about that
if you've got questions about specific
documents or specific things go ahead
let's not
let's let's go to px2m as well please
i'm sorry which one is this
a 2a your honor
listen at least now we can kind of see
what's going on
no i'm not really see that
and um what we have here in 2a is a
document
well i'll ask you um can you tell us
is this a statement that you posted
on twitter
uh
on december 3rd 2020
go ahead go again
sure yes ma'am
yes yeah and
this is a
statement where you talked about
um
that you were looking for a senator to
join yourself and representative mo
brooks to reject the fraudulent votes
for joe biden and to keep the real
donald trump in the white house right i
have jack uh your honor to
the
you can hear my objection i'm waiting
i'm waiting with baited breath jim all
right
free speech uh there's nothing in this
statement
that uh meets the brandenburg test even
if speech could be
what
considered
it can't when we're dealing with
uh he get engages which is conduct not
speak if it is free speech then why the
objection
like if that's truly what it is then why
the objection if it is free speech
why are you objecting fighting or
producing imminent flawless action your
honor we heard an hour of argument this
morning
thank you honor that is likely to
insider all right i wasn't really
listening i was googling this judge
to try to see because the judge seems
frankly
to be
i would say more on the marjorie taylor
green side than on the petitioner's side
i was just curious to see if i could
figure out who all i've all i've seen so
far is he was a tax lawyer for a hundred
years when you sent out this
strike that did you send out this tweet
it was green
as well did you put it back on
yes okay
and when you sent out this tweet you
wanted the people who had the judge who
was biased to know that it was your view
that
the votes for mr biden for president
were fraudulent or some of them were
right
that really wasn't the purpose of that
tweet
i'm just asking whether when you sent
this you were communicating some are
saying in the chat karen that
this judge was appointed by governor
kemp i'm not sure if that's true but
there's any votes for mr biden
and that your goal was to keep president
trump in the white house i was
communicating that we were looking for a
senator to join our objection which is
very much
part of the
responsibilities and duties
that i can do as a member of congress i
agree with that
but the purpose of that
was because you believed
that the votes for mr biden were
fraudulent right or at least some of
them
we had we had been
spending a vast amount of time reading
she won't say yes
and have seen uh tremendous evidence of
voter fraud i don't know if you're aware
because i know so know then i guess
currently have our secretary of state
your honor i would hope to strike this
i'm entitled to get answers to my
questions your honor
thank you all right let's let's back up
by the way
your honor i'm sorry to interrupt we we
missed something very important can the
representative be sworn oh thank you no
i swore oh you did okay i didn't see
that i'm sorry
um
and can i ask the court to acknowledge
that this is a an adverse wisdom witness
a hostile witness
witness
exactly right even though it's only your
case and she has psychology and can i
treat the insurrectionist as hostile
right in this posture she has to answer
my questions she can't give speeches
is that fair she's entitled your time to
an answer to the question that is asked
she's not entitled to my answer you're
not entitled to answers that are
uh that uh to require her to answer when
the question is objectionable violates
the first amendment right is irrelevant
to the charges that are
being made
just to
what fishing expedition political
theater what is that this is this is
cross-examination she has a fifth
amendment right not a first amendment
right when she's under oath i don't
understand what's going on here
you have a standing objection mr bop
to everything in the world i want to
question your witness let her know
she's doing this
let me stand back up and object
just properly sit down next question
this is not theater
this is not an argument from the supreme
court this is an evidentiary hearing so
let's get going go ahead mr cho
um ms wells can you pull up plaintiff's
exhibit
2c please
what was which number 2c
we have a comment here that this is a
[ __ ] show and anything involving marjory
taylor green is definitely a [ __ ] show
in your account
on
december 19
2020
yes
and in this tweet um
let's let me go back a second your honor
i would just ask that
the previous exhibit which i think was
2db um admitted into evidence
d
i'm sorry 2a all right so 2a is b
um i'd ask that 2c be admitted into
evidence
2c
all right
say that again
sure i asked the witness if this was her
tweet she said it was this is your tweet
okay
and i ask it be admitted into evidence i
object if it's not probative and it
violates the first amendment right well
it's not to do with engage it doesn't it
it's in for what it's worth
i think everyone can see she really
hasn't answered a question yet
we've this is all about the lawyers the
judge and this is what this
why would she take the stand then does
she have to here
one of the things you're communicating
to the people who
would read this tweet was that you want
them to come to washington
on january 6th
for a demonstration
is that right
for a march for trump right march for
fight for trump
the phrase that you use there
is hashtag fight for trump right that's
what the words say that's what it says
on my tweet okay
um
oh she could tweet that day i posted
that because you in fact wanted people
to show up
on january 6th
2021 in dc
in order to help you
stop
the theft of the 2020 election from your
point of view
now
okay
well i'm not sure we got a clear answer
on this you you did believe at this time
that the 2020 election had been stolen
by the democrats from mr trump right
i i was asking people to come for a
peaceful march which is
what everyone is entitled to do
under their first amendment but i was
not asking them to actively engage in
violence or any type of action
that wasn't the question though it's
really simple it's about your opinion
when this tweet came out in this period
it was your opinion that the election
had been stolen from mr trump or was
about to be stolen right
under my opinion there was a tremendous
amount of
fraudulent uh things that happened in
the election
and under my opinion i want to do
anything i can to protect election
integrity and to protect
the
people of my district in georgia
people's votes they should count
from election night of 2020
until january 6 2021
your personal opinion and your wish
was that congress not certify joe biden
as the winner of the 2020 election
uh no that's not accurate
what uh you believed that joe biden had
lost the election she's under oath by
the way i don't know if that matters
well yes we saw a tremendous amount of
voter fraud we have uh investigations
going on right now remember she's under
oath when she's saying these things in
multiple states
my own husband showed up to vote on the
general election and when he went in to
vote in person he was told that he had
already
voted by absentee ballot when in fact he
had never even requested an absentee
ballot these are facts that could be dug
up
oh
you're on our
let me do this now i understand there's
an i.t issue that requires a pause okay
well should we take how long do we need
two minutes all right well i'm not just
everybody
be patient
all right so she's she just claimed i
don't know if i've ever heard that
before that her husband
was uh
a victim
of this whole ballot
issue um which is interesting what do
you think about her being under oath
garen and making these claims
you know
so far she hasn't really answered
questions right so
i i right now i i don't i think it's way
too soon to make any predictions about
being under oath and telling the truth
etc because
she hasn't really answered a question
other than you know she's talked about
her husband's experience you know one
anecdote
doesn't make a trend and you know how
many court challenges have there been
where they've actually looked for
these these defects that they've been
talking about and every single one of
them has been thrown out i mean this
claim of you know dead people voting or
my husband showing up or all these all
these store you know these stories of
of you know the
the election was stolen not not one of
them has
has come about with any kind of you know
none of them are true i mean every
they've every single one of them has
failed in court so yeah they've all
resulted in rudy giuliani leaking
leaking from his hair i mean that's kind
of the result of all these claims that
they made even in federal court rudy
giuliani had to say to the judge in in
not so many words we are not claiming
fraud like literally he had to say that
to the judge because from my
understanding he can't lie
in court
okay yeah i mean
everybody seated please
looks like they're going to take a break
it looks like um
i don't know that this is a good idea
for the uh for the plaintiffs because
now it gives marjory taylor green an
opportunity to really
conference with her attorneys as opposed
to stay on the stand but yeah i mean
look they've had plenty of time to
prepare i don't think a few minutes is
going to make a difference i i just
think the tactic here is disruption
right the tactic here is
you know blow up
what you don't want is a smooth case
coming in on the petitioner's side
because they have the burden of proof
and so if they can just present evidence
and present stuff and it all comes in
smoothly their burden becomes easier and
what they're doing here is disrupt
disrupt disrupt try to blow up the
proceeding any way you can and try to
disrupt any kind of evidence that comes
in
any you know like i said we've barely
heard her speak so far
why i mean
i mean that those are that is good
points because when she has spoke she
hasn't answered a question she's
um
really been
it
it you know it practiced
to deflect in other words well you know
look i
i'm from new york so you know forgive me
for the following statement but is this
like what is this faux demure kind of
you know
like
southern thing that she's trying to pull
off here you know like
well they are in georgia so you know
bless her heart bless her heart
he's a good christian woman did you see
that cross on her neck right yeah but is
that does that really does that
is
it might it might be effective with this
judge um yeah i mean we know that it
seems that this judge through this
hearing has some sort of
bias it looks like they're going to take
a longer break than just an id break
um so we're going to keep an eye on the
the hearing room here as we as we do
commentary but
karen did you did you find out is this
judge
um
a kemp appointed judge you know i i
i was trying to actually listen to the
proceeding
i'm clearly not very good at
multitasking maybe we could get our
executive producer over there to uh what
yeah what is the name of uh what is the
name of the judge what is the name of
the judge his name is uh
b e a u d r o t beaudro i'm not sure how
you pronounce that
dro probably something like that
he's a junior which makes it even more
sus no i'm just kidding i i mean i don't
i don't i don't know i um you know this
judge seems to um have a bias here but
really
you say it's an administrative court and
he is a judge but it and he's gonna hand
down a ruling but it seems very awkward
it's almost like
it's almost like a city council type
meeting right like not really
you know what i mean it's not really
like a courtroom as in the civil or
criminal trial like you were saying
earlier it's more
like a city council or school board
meeting where they're going to vote to
have a certain policy in the school or
certain or they're going to put a stop
sign at this certain intersection i mean
i know that seems a little more
insignificant than what we're talking
about but really that's kind of the
proceeding here right am i am i wrong in
saying that no it's it's an
administrative hearing um yeah it's it's
exactly right it's exactly what you're
what you're saying and at the end he's
gonna make a ruling i think it's gonna i
think
my prediction is he's going to say
that
she stays on the ballot
she he's not going to disqualify her
why do you why do you say that is it is
it based on the evidence that we've seen
or are just because of what we haven't
seen yet
neither i think it's such a significant
to to basically deprive you know
elections democracy voting i mean these
are
fundamental bedrocks of our society and
this little administrative judge i i
don't think he's going to make that
god forbid he gets it wrong right you
know he's not going to
he i think he'd rather sort of let it go
forward see if she wins see you know
because look let's say he lets it go
forward and she loses then
you know then you don't have to even get
to these questions right or but so see
if she wins if she wins if she gets
elected and and maybe and i think he's
going to say this isn't a thing for
congress you know because
again
even if you show
that um there was an insurrection that
day and even if you showed that that she
said what she said what what is the
standard of finding that she
was a part of the insurrection you know
it's i just think it's legally it's a
little um i think it's a little
complicated and a little uh dramatic
frankly i just don't see him
and he also seems slightly biased you
know i i hate to say it or maybe more
than slightly i don't know but it so far
he seems a little um
a little more more biased so i i think
he's going to
uh
frankly kick it over to congress and let
congress
make this make this decision or or a
federal court um once she's elected i
don't see in it because i think at the
end of the day he is going to say this
is a little administrative hearing and
you know yet we're we're making a
decision about a constitutional issue
and i think he's not gonna i just don't
think he's gonna do it i don't know i
don't know exactly
how he's gonna shoehorn his decision
into that you know it could look like a
a bunch of different things but i think
that's gonna be the ultimate result
um unfortunately which i i know is is
going to be disappointing to a lot of
people uh when it happens but i i don't
just even the way it's going so far
nothing has come in
at all
remotely
for the petitioners to hang their hat on
nothing and for him to even make a
decision for him to even make a decision
because we are talking about the primary
ballot at this point yeah that's that's
the decision that this judge is making i
want everyone to make that clear that
this isn't for the general election
ballot that's going to happen in
november for the 2022 midterm they are
specifically talking about and you've
seen in the beginning um they're talking
about the the the uh primary that is
about to happen in may so just just
within a few weeks from now yeah i mean
the ballot's already printed as somebody
pointed out you know there's so there's
no way he's going to
disrupt that i think he's just going to
allow
democracy and the constitution to
proceed and and let congress decide
whether to swear her in or not uh at the
end of the day that that's that's where
i see this is happening
did you find it yeah
so i i haven't seen anything that
definitively says that kemp was an
appointed i did i was able to look up
the kent appointed judges
uh i don't know if these are like brand
new judges that are put to different
different seats but everything that i've
seen in the local level and other state
courts court of appeals and the supreme
court
neither of which mention the name i do
know that from what i've seen
the honorable charles r boudreau jr
was appointed to the georgia tax
tribunal by governor
nathan
diehl which is the former
um
georgia governor and he was appointed in
november of 2012 to the georgia tax
tribunal so i don't know at what point
he shifted over but from what i see i
mean unless someone can find something
differently but i'm not finding anything
on ballotpedia or anywhere else that
says that kemp was the one who actually
moved him over
um it also could have been done but i'm
not seeing any official documentation
that says kemp was the one who did it
so so this guy was an administrative
judge in a tax court is that kind of
so i don't uh
i don't know i mean i can tell you where
he went to school i can tell you his uh
previous uh law firm that he was at
what's here let's hear the uh the school
that he went to why not we might as well
yeah well he went to um
oh now i gotta log in oh i believe
he's he's pretty good at researching uh
on the fly but usually he has a link or
something for me that i can throw you
know i know i just right right right
yeah hold on okay so
let me go
let me get back to this
uh our boy charles r boudreau he's a
composer and musician
oh he was an administrative law judge
and a retired lawyer from morris manning
and martin llp
um
yeah he is from 2013 so i'm assuming
that this is still part of the deal kind
of appointment but it says he served as
a judge at the office of this uh state
administrative hearings osa at the state
of georgia
um
and he's been that way i've been an
administrative judge for a long time
he's been this way since january 2013.
so what i think happened is he he was
tax tribunal judge and then that was in
november of 2012 and then shortly
thereafter within a few months he
shifted over to this uh administrative
hearings
judge
but he previously um
went to harvard got his jd
went to duke he got his uh ba in history
um
yeah well that's why that's why he
wasn't having it when when the plaintiff
or the petitioner tried to put on a
history
like uh you know i know about history i
don't know i don't know
he don't you don't need to be taught in
other words yeah yeah i mean 1969 to
1973. those were the well and then 1973
to 1976 but those are the times that he
was in school
i mean look taking off sort of the hat
of what do we want to have happen and
who do we like better and and what we
think
uh we want here i i have to say i i do
think that um to ask an administrative
judge in an administrative hearing
um to take the extraordinary step of
saying somebody is not qualified to be
uh on the primary ballot in a couple of
weeks
um when she hasn't been charged
convicted convicted or in any way held
accountable being an insurrectionist i
think is is a really extraordinary step
that that he's being asked to do and i
just don't see him
uh thinking that it's the appropriate
forum to do it and
and you know it's there will be other
opportunities to to challenge this in in
probably uh federal court or in congress
which is i i think it's a
slightly more appropriate potentially
more appropriate and legitimate place to
make a constitutional
challenge the way um the way that he's
being asked to do here that that's
that's what i think um this feels like
and seems like just just from from
watching this
well so so in other words you're you're
saying that it may be easy for him to
kick the can down the road so that may
be the avenue he takes because it does
make sense for him to say hey this is a
constitutional issue this isn't an
administrative issue is that kind of the
can that you're saying he might kick
because it's easy to kick yes
okay
well and and having think about it what
if he gets it wrong
what if he
says uh what what if he says you know
you're not qualified and then that's
obviously going to and then she's not on
the ballot
and she doesn't get elected and then
it's it's going to be challenged in
court and what if he got it wrong what
what do you do then you can't then
kind of
you know it's much easier to get someone
elected and then
take them off you know basically
disqualify them and hold a special
election than it is to not let someone
go forward and be elected and then oops
we made a mistake here you can't then
hold you know you're not going to hold
the special election that way so
i just you know
i don't know i i just think that that
from uh
again it's it's there are constitutional
rights and there are constitutional
rights right
and the the the bedrock of our democracy
is about the right to vote and um
i just don't see a a administrative
hearing where people are are are
clapping and and the plaintiff didn't
talk about any facts
and
you know or the petitioner i keep
calling them the plaintiff but um you
know i don't know i just don't see th
this is not the major leagues that's
happening here in any way not on either
side you know but we're not watching a
well-oiled machine um we're watching a a
very local
which is very real right this
this is what most courtrooms are like
it's a very local sort of you know
technical difficulties we have people
shouting in the audience we have
you know lawyers who are are
very good but they're not you know these
these celebrity show
show men and women
um and you got an administrative judge i
just don't think he's going to to make a
decision that that um
i i just don't think he's gonna make a
decision that that goes to the
fundamental heart of who we are as a
society in this particular you know
we're basically in traffic court you
know like right right
so it's just i just don't see it
happening and i think um i could be
wrong i hope i'm wrong but i just i
don't see it happening i think this goes
to
so outside the legal ramifications
because there are political
ramifications of this as well i mean
marjorie taylor green actually happening
to take the stand and actually having to
answer some of these questions could
have political ramifications right it
could it could hurt her in her politics
um to to run in an election so i'm not
saying that that is the intention here
that's what i'm saying um but i i i am i
am trying to point out that just because
that the decision that is made by this
administrative judge rather it is the
decision you want or not i'm talking to
the listeners if it is a decision that
you
desire in this uh in this situation or
not
i i believe that there are going to be
political consequences for marjorie
taylor green taking the stand which it
sounds like she has to do
and answering but more importantly not
answering some of these questions
because
almost at the fundamental core of
marjory taylor green's personality
because that's truly what she is she's
not she's not a real congress person to
a degree that she sits on committees um
she doesn't have the ability to
interject in committees so she is only
only a personality that can go to the
floor during debate
and create social media moments on video
that she can retweet and i want to be
clear
she said during her and this is one of
the political ramifications i think is
very bad for her she continues to talk
about how she's banned from twitter and
she is not that is a lie and the other
thing that's a lie that she said is that
you can't you can't figure out how many
people see your tweets that's also a lie
she might not i mean i'm not trying to
defend her she might not know i mean
like i'm on twitter and i have no idea
well all right right
fair enough fair enough fair enough tell
me what what do you mean by the fact
that she's not banned from twitter why
would she say that she's clearly talking
about something what what
so she has two accounts on twitter her
personal account uh was banned a
permaban she'd been suspended several
times and twitter had cut off her
permanent account but because she's a
member of congress she has afforded an
official congressional account um that
is that is verified it is going to be
archived as as a public official and she
still tweets from that account so the
idea that she absolutely is not on
twitter is a bold-faced lie so that so
that's a point that her that the
petitioner's lawyer
if you if
you know again not to monday morning
quarterback because it's hard to be no
please do please do please i i want to
go with the caveat that being a trial
room being a courtroom lawyer is one of
the hardest things you can do right um
and
but one of the things that they should
have said when she said that would have
been exactly what you just said when she
because because she i was left with the
impression that she was banned from
twitter right and right and so what the
lawyer what the petitioner should have
done at that moment is said
isn't it true
so so miss
miss green you're saying that you're
banned from twitter right so you're
saying you have no ability to tweet at
all is that what you're saying
yes so but isn't it true that as a
member of congress you are afforded at
whatever you know her actual twitter
handle is and you know and and so so and
you have control over that and you can
tweet from that and blah blah you know
on and on and just show right there
through those questions you are a liar
you don't have to call her a liar you
don't have to say i mean i can't i can
but yeah well the other thing the
ineffective litigator that's what you do
show that she's that's an easy thing
right like that's you're not gonna get
her to agree with your opinion this was
an insurrection or this was not an
insurrection but show her to be a liar
again you you want and and does it and
and what significance does that mean
that she's a liar the more times you can
do that all of a sudden the judge might
start might kind of say you know what
i'm not going to believe this if she
lies about these simple things i don't
know that i'm going to believe her with
these other things and same thing in the
court of public opinion again
i think i pay pretty good attention to
things i had no idea that she has the
congressional twitter account again i
was left with the impression
that she's banned from twitter the way
so many people who should be banned are
banned but i again this was an easy this
was an easy ground ball missed
opportunity
from the petitioner's side and and i
hate that i'm monday morning
quarterbacking or commenting on an
attorney because i would hate for
someone to do it to me
um it's a hard thing to do i've made a
million mistakes and will continue to
make mistakes it's hard to do it in
court but that's just you know that's
just a point that i want to
make right yeah the other the other
thing too is uh you know
the
the plaintiff was uh making the argument
to say like okay you you send these
tweets out and they are visible to
hundreds of thousands of people right
and her claim is
well
you know not anymore because i don't
have my personal account right and
that's where you would go back and say
okay well which one was banned you still
have one account
but the other thing too is
easily verifiable is you just go to
you know rep mtg and you look on twitter
and you see that she's got over 500 000
followers right so you look at these
things and you're like there is the num
like no one can [ __ ] this number no
one can [ __ ] the fact that you have
two accounts one was permabanned that
you have hundreds of thousands of
followers you have potentially over a
million if you were to combine both
of those
those channels
um
and then you know i think pushing that
forward for the argument which was
you know anyone on the platform can see
your tweets who are not even logged in
you know they could be embedded they can
be shared they can be screenshotted they
could be all these things and saying to
the point of
your words
have consequences and when your words
say we should
you know
block the certification or we should
fight it or whatever it's not just a
means of like
oh um i want to rally the troops but
there's more intent and more kind of
uh
uh malicious intent i'll say behind
those things and i think if you know to
your point it's like well she says this
then refute it with well you have
another account if she says this then
repeated with you've got over 500 000
people that follow follow you
specifically that doesn't include the
millions of people who are able to view
the tweets on a public
um kind of scale so
yeah i'm i
when this was brought up you know for
the same reason of like
she's
not answering a yes or no question and
saying like well i don't know or this or
that i think there are easy ways to get
around that and then rephrase the
question like you ever saying like
what's your opinion do you think right
like let's work outside this world of
hypotheticals
or you know
are you as an insurrectionist doing this
but like do you think that this is legal
right well what you just said though
so so there's a line of questioning that
you could ask
that you don't care what the answer is
because you're getting your story out
she could say no to all of those things
and again the petitioner could have said
isn't it true that on twitter there are
people who can watch you or not watch
you or whatever you know yes and she'll
say no or i don't know and isn't it true
that that you know they'll see all the
things that you just said i don't know
and isn't it true then that it's
possible that millions and millions of
people saw when you said
that you know the election was a fraud i
have no idea who cares what her answer
is you know you're trying to get you're
painting a picture for that for the
meaning that's going to make any
questions right for the judge who's
going to make this decision because
ultimately not only are you painting a
picture for him but you're painting a
picture politically because the other
the other thing that that i find
ridiculous is that she doesn't know how
many impressions she gets and that's
that's absolutely crazy to me she's on
she and
let's skip past twitter because she's on
facebook she's on
telegram she's on parlor she's on
several other social media platforms
that has hundreds and hundreds of
thousands
of of uh
followers and those accounts are public
too anyone can go create an account and
go see those quote unquote tweets or
what her word is or what she's trying to
say in public um the fact the fact that
she's blatantly lying on the stand and
and it's not really lying she's stuck in
this political mind right like she's
trying to get out into the microphone
that i was banned from twitter like she
wears it as a badge she intentionally
did that she intentionally got banned
but that's why again the petitioner
could have said right isn't it true
you're on facebook isn't it true you're
on your way isn't it you know all those
again who cares what the answer is right
so you're saying that at
you know mtg blah blah blah i mean you
know again you can just set the stage of
a that she's a liar and b get your story
out through your questions and so that's
one of the things her her lawyers being
i have to say effective at is he's
he is trying to prevent the petitioner
from telling their story through their
questions right and so he's interrupting
and disrupting and you know look the the
petitioner's lawyer is is human and you
get flustered i mean i get flustered you
know in court sometimes you know not as
much anymore because i'm i'm older but
you know when i was when i was coming up
you know you you get people to object
object object object and you get the
judge and all of a sudden you don't
remember what's going on and then you
start to feel
you know a little bit insecure and you
know you're just throwing off your game
a little bit you know and and it's hard
it's a hard job to do and
and um and this defense attorney you
know or or whatever he is again i have
no idea if it's petitioner and
respondent or plaintiff and defense like
i have no idea what the parties are
called but you know i'm calling them
the defense
so
well it's definitely you know
yeah they're it looks like they're
coming back in but i was going to say
yeah like just like in sports you know
you're what you're talking about just
icing your opponent you're like yeah oh
we're going to take a out right before
the field go kick you know like stuff
like that that's how it's clearly
happening and i have to say it's
effective
yeah appreciate everybody here we go
again
they're claiming technology uh uh the
difficulties but i think this is the
other thing too
marjorie taylor green is the first
sitting uh
representative senator congress person
that has to testify to january 6.
wow okay well
ms green this is a tweet that we talked
about a little bit earlier just a quick
question on it um
you issued this on
um
december 19 2020 correct
i can't see real well but i think that's
the date maybe maybe we can make it a
little larger
that's what it says
and
what you were doing in this
tweet was you were
tweeting out a story
uh from the epic times
uh about president trump saying that the
protests that were planned for january 6
were going to be quote wild right for
those who don't know this this epic
times is
a very evil right there under the
picture under the ashes lying rag
it says trump trump calling supporters
should join wild protest in dc on jan 6.
okay i would throw
you can answer the question
representative green what was your
question my question is what you were
doing in this tweet is you were tweeting
out a story from the epic times
about president trump making a statement
that the protest on january 6th
would be wild
right
i tweeted an article that had the
details of the dates and times right and
also included president trump's
statements that he expected the
demonstrations on january 6 to be wild
right
i don't think that's what my tweet was
about okay well but you see that the
article says trump colon supporters
should join quote wild protests in dc
on jan 6.
i don't remember tweeting that
specifically for what you're saying
those are your words
no i'm ready i'm actually reading from
what's on
you're speculating on why i tweeted that
but i don't remember tweeting it for
that specific reason is green i'm just
asking questions i'm just answering
no you're not and
in your tweet you mentioned earlier that
um
your words join
march for trump and dc on january 6 to
fight for trump that you were urging
people to come to washington for a
peaceful demonstration right
peaceful demonstration right absolutely
yeah that word peaceful is nowhere in
this tweet right
have a look that word peaceful is not in
the street there's only half of it there
let's let's get give the representative
a paper copy of that one
i just want to make sure i'm not going
to see it now
um
well you know like is the word peaceful
in there miss green it does not say
peaceful right my question you're asking
me and i said for peaceful
demonstrations this is a little more of
the lines of the questioning we were
talking about earlier i i'm asking
you didn't there's not a secret code in
there that's supposed to be peaceful
right well i never mean anything for
violence i don't support violence of any
kind and i've said it over and over
again
so i i'm telling you i can find
we'll examine that question go to uh
planets exhibit two f please
two
f
in yes
and
i'm looking at
yes this top half of the exhibit
ms green this is a tweet that you sent
out
on january 2nd 2021 correct
i'm not sure
okay you don't recall this
i don't recall tweeting that now okay
um you can set that to one side
well let me ask this question
does anybody
tweet things on your twitter account
like that did anybody in january of 2021
tweet things on your twitter account
without your permission
on what day
anytime from
november of 2020 to january 6th
i don't remember that's difficult
you'd be surprised if somebody got into
your twitter account and tweeted
something without your permission
wouldn't you
well no one tweeted anything without my
permission i just don't remember
who tweeted what
fair enough follow up follow up follow
up
would you agree miss green that
this tweet
from january 2nd 2021
is something that we can fairly
attribute to you being that it was
tweeted on your twitter account
i
i'm sorry i
i don't know
okay
you take that down
um mrs green you've had your
disagreements with speaker pelosi isn't
that right
i'm not sure what you mean you've got
political disagreements with her you
don't agree with some of the things
she's done in her career right
politically speaking that would be
correct right you don't agree with a lot
of things she's done right
politically speaking that would be
correct in fact you think that speaker
pelosi is a traitor to the country right
looks over to the lawyer you're i'm not
answering that question of speculation
you've said that have you had the screen
yep there it is there it is i haven't
said that okay
it's exhibit five please okay i was like
oh no bro
oh wait oh now i remember
by not upholding the uh securing the
border
that that violates
her oath of office
fair enough i'm i'm not interested in
the oath of office i'm interested in
that you said
that she's a traitor to our country
right
actually uh this is i don't see the
relevance of that mr chilly
your honor can we give mr bap a standing
objection on the first amendment grounds
because this is this is a this is an
effort to interrupt my examination of
the witness
i am attempting to establish the
the
the witnesses the judge's desire
to engage in insurrection
during the period january 3rd to january
6th now it's true that some of the
things that she said are relevant if
they were even though they occurred
before january 3rd but there's no first
amendment objection to evidence your
honor she's she said what she said
there is first amendment
we don't agree well
but i get to make my objection you can
make the objection you can have a
standing objection
because he wants to interrupt my flow
right that's that's not appropriate i
don't object to everything okay okay i
have specific things that i think i
object to and i i
should be extended the courtesy to do
that you may you may object
uh plan signified
um
so i'm placing before you um what we've
pre-marked the claims exhibit five
which is an article that appeared in cnn
on
january 26
2021.
a hard copy of this
should be in the book i mean does she
have a hard copy i mean she can't read
it off the screen um
we have one for her
let's start using hard copies you can't
read stuff like this on the screen may i
approach the witness yes
you have standing permission appropriate
witness to deliver copies of documents
as to which you can ask your question
thank you
as well if you could scroll down a bit
one second
ms green i want to
direct your attention to the bottom of
the fourth page of the
exhibit this is this is a paragraph that
starts out
she's a traitor to our country do you
see that
i'm actually honored what possible
relevance could it be
that they she had political
disagreements that resulted in hyperbole
that is commonly used your honor this is
an argument
thank you
um i just want to ask a narrow question
representative greene
um
did you say
referring to speaker pelosi she's a
traitor to our country
she's guilty of treason she took an oath
to protect the american citizens
she gives aid and comfort to our enemies
who illegally invade our land that's
what treason is
and our law representatives and senators
can be kicked out and no longer serve in
our government
and it's uh a crime punishable by death
is what treason is nancy pelosi is
guilty of treason did you say those
words
i said this is what i was telling you is
i
she doesn't uphold our laws uh it's a
simple yes or no question ma'am did you
say those words
without being instructed by him to say
yes or no i don't agree your honor this
is cross-examination she's entitled to
an answer to my question not a speech
did you say these words that are quoted
on the bible did you say that
according to the cnn article i did i
don't remember
i don't recall saying all of this but i
do i do recall having
said this about the i totally disagree
with the border issues
next question
um
and representative greene you you have
advocated
the use of physical violence
against people you disagree with
politically right i object without
contacts without
anything
for anyone watching the screen here um
you can see a facebook post again
you've advocated the use of physical
violence i put up a facebook post where
she was inciting violence that was that
and it was actually taken down by
facebook
i don't think so i don't know how to
answer that next question
well um have a look at what we've marked
as planets exhibit
five
e5 q5
that's the same same one
you've got a copy of this representative
oh is it the same
okay
and
well let me ask a foundational question
um
you understand that
on social media posts like facebook and
twitter
uh one of the things well i guess on
facebook one of the things you can do is
you can like someone's post right
you can like people's
posts right
and when you like someone's post here's
one of the facebook posts
that she got pulled down for
from facebook correct the post is on the
screen right
uh i don't know i don't agree with your
phrase or questioning well i'm asking
you
isn't it true that when you like when
you personally miss green like someone's
post you're signifying your approval for
what the post said
no i don't agree with the how you're
praising that question no i don't agree
with that
um so
it's true though that you liked a post
that suggested that quote a bullet to
the head of
nancy pelosi would be a quicker way to
remove her as speaker ouch ouch
you're using a cnn article which has lot
cnn has lied about me multiple times and
you're using a cnn article i'm asking
you to answer my question did you like a
post that said it's quicker that a
bullet to the head would be a certain
way to remove nancy pelosi from the role
of the speaker and many people manage my
social media account over the years i
have no idea who liked that
okay
you're
are you testifying under oath it wasn't
you so the answer is yes it was like
testifying i have no idea who liked that
comment fair enough it could have been
you
right
[Music]
do not know she's answered
next question
okay
by the way you know miss green that
one of the places inside the united
states capitol building
that was invaded by people who were
doing violence was miss pelosi's office
right
i was inside the chamber
during uh on january 6 so i do not know
all the places that those people went i
only know where i was
are you telling us that in the
more than a year since these events
occurred
you have not become aware that one of
the offices that was invaded by people
who were illegally in the capital was
nancy pelosi's office i've seen that on
the news okay
but i don't know for sure i haven't i
haven't investigated all of that
now you mentioned earlier in response to
some of my questions that there was a
demonstration
uh that was being planned for
uh january 6 2021 called the march for
trump right
we talked about it on one of my twitter
posts right and and that demonstration
was being organized in part by an
organization called women for america
right
i don't remember who organized it okay
um
playing this exhibit 2d
i'm sorry
i'm sorry 2d your honor
d b is in board no no d isn't dog
i placed in front of you what's a
document that's been pre-marked as
planets exhibit 2d
um
you just begin by asking um
one of the things that you can do on
twitter
mrs green is you can retweet or send out
again
somebody else's tweet right yes okay
and
on plaintiffs 2d
which i placed in front of you
you are retweeting a tweet
sent by kylie jane cremer
on december 19 2020 right
i don't know if i retweeted it well if
you look carefully it says marjorie
taylor green has an american flag and it
says reach retweeted as you test i
retweeted it you know you don't recall
one way or the other i don't recall
and it's your testimony that if this got
retweeted from your account that would
have been done with your permission
right
i don't i don't recall retweeting it
for those out there kylie kramer is the
one who bought the burner phones for
eric trump
in the form set forth as planus 2d
in
on december 20th
2012. i'm sorry december 19th
you don't deny that do you
this is what your picture has this paper
has i don't have this twitter account
anymore
so i don't recall i don't remember
she did have
and that women for america were the
organizers right
i don't remember but that's like this
says
okay
um
and one of the other
hashtags
for
the demonstrations that were planned on
january 6th
she's looking over to where in
washington dc
um was a hashtag
um stop the steal hashtag stop this deal
right
yes yes
and
another hashtag that got used at the
time
was or i'm sorry a website that was
being used to organize people to come to
washington was something called
wildprotest.com
right
i don't know okay
px33 please
i'm sorry again this is jelly p
px33 xpx i call it ps p33 or p32
oh my god
i placed before you miss green
a document that was marked as
plaintiff's exhibit or petitioners
exhibit 33.
let me just ask a couple questions about
it
um
does this refresh your recollection that
there was a website known as
wildprotest.com
that was um
encouraging people to come to washington
for a process protest on january 6th i
don't remember the website but i'm
seeing it here on this
on your
paper okay
and
wild was the term that president trump
used to describe what he thought was
going to happen on january 6th right
wild is also a term that high schoolers
use when they talk about spring break
fair enough
[Music]
but
whatever the
title of the demonstration or the name
or the hashtag that was used you would
agree that you were aware
in
after the election and before january 6
that people were being asked to come to
dc
for a large demonstration to object to
the certification of joe biden as
president of the united states right i
was aware people were coming to support
our objection in congress that on
january 6th the only thing i was
preparing for was objecting
when did you first
become aware that there were going to be
large demonstrations in dc on the 6th
i don't recall
did you consider at any point
participating in any of those
demonstrations
it was put on my calendar but then i
never went if we were too busy we were
you know looking at all the evidence and
preparing for our debates and preparing
to object
and preparing for an
somebody insurrection your staff i take
it
i have no idea we had burner phones to
buy you know stranger riders somebody
from your congressional staff right
bombs to plant maybe i mean allegedly as
you sit here
can you tell us
why it is that
a an appearance for you at that
demonstration was placed on your
calendar
can you rephrase that question how did
it come to pass that
it was put on your calendar that you
were going to appear at a demonstration
i understand you said you were too busy
i don't know i was so busy just
preparing to object i don't know
um you were going to
go to one of these demonstrations as a
speaker right
i don't think so i was always preparing
to object we were very busy
well have a look at what we've marked as
another round 33
if you go about
three pages in at the bottom of that
page and then over to the next page
it says invited speakers and featured
guests right
i'm assuming i guess i was on there
because i was invited right but i don't
i don't know who made this website i i'm
sorry i can't answer okay well if you
say anything about it
well you can answer that that's your
name and face right
that is my name and face but i again i
don't run that website i have no idea
who does
my question to you representative green
is
did some you or someone under your
authority at your congressional office
authorize
you to be placed as a speaker or guest
of the wild protest demonstration i get
many invitations as a member of congress
to many events and and all kinds of
speaking engagements like a
on my knick-knack
but they have no relevance as to whether
i attend or not so would it be fair to
say ms greene
that through your office
you authorized your name
and your
likeness to be associated with the
wildprotest.com demonstration no you
cannot say that or assume that
that would be whoever organized this
let's talk about that
going back to 33.
you know ali alexander don't you
no i don't really know um when you say
you don't really know him you've met him
right
i've seen him before but i don't know
him
yeah how many times have you been in his
physical presence to your knowledge
i cannot even guess hardly any
10
20 no
have you shaking his hand
i've shaken to you before yes i shake
hands with
pretty much everyone i need lots of
people right um
and he's a friend of yours right now
okay
oh not a friend
um
did you discuss with
mr alexander
the idea of you coming to appear at a
demonstration on january 6th i do not
recall that now you're not denying that
happen you just don't recall one way or
the other i do not recall that now
um
well did you discuss with anybody
attending the wild protest demonstration
that was planned for january 6th i do
not recall ever talking about attending
other than people
um
on your
congressional staff or your campaign
staff
list for me all the people who you spoke
to
about the demonstrations on january 6th
that would i i'm sorry i have no idea
okay you don't remember any of them i do
not remember not any of them no okay
and you spoke to some people about those
demonstrations
prior to being sworn in as a
representative from the 14th district
right
i i don't remember and you spoke to some
of those people
after you took the oath on january 3rd
and before the 6th right i don't
remember
um did you speak to anybody in
government
about the fact that there were going to
be demonstrations in washington on
january 6th
i don't remember we were mostly reading
information about election fraud and
people signed uh affidavits about what
they'd witnessed with voter fraud and
preparing to object that was
pretty much all i remember doing right
pretty much but your testimony as you
sit here today under oath is that you
didn't talk to anybody in government
about the fact that there were going to
be large protests in washington
on january 6th i don't remember
just fyi i don't recall or i don't
remember is the
sure way not to get hard for perjury
this is what this is she's making it but
she never gets charged with perjury do
not remember
how about representative gosar
sorry i don't remember so in other words
she does remember she does know talk to
people but she doesn't want to be
charged with birth we're going to be
large demonstrations on january 6th in
washington i don't remember
either that or she has dementia i mean
come on right
it's a heart in january it's very
difficult to not remember all this
anyone ever mentioned to you it's all
that crossfit that you know gets to your
memory violence in washington on january
6 2021. i don't remember
so it's possible that folks told you
things could get violent in washington
on january 6th right can this judge
the judge knows this obviously i don't
remember those conversations and this is
what we were talking about earlier is
let her not actually answer but in her
non-answer giving the answer very
seriously
my question is just about
whether anybody
at all ever mentioned to you the
possibility of violence i don't remember
okay so you're not denying it you're
just saying you don't recall i don't
recall
and
you don't recall that
people said
you know we're having these big
demonstrations in washington
and some of the people who come to those
demonstrations
might become violent
that never happened
the only violence i'd ever seen was
antifa and blm riots and i've been to so
many trump rallies
i never
and that was before january 6. i don't
ever recall trump telling people to take
physical assault to others
those were trump people right
i knew there were many people coming to
support president trump and our
objection on january 6th right and
at least some of them were coming she's
practiced that line several times
i didn't person i don't recall
personally asking people to come but
evidently i tweeted about
january 6.
did anybody
strike that
did you have any conversations with
anybody
in government representatives
senators
white house staff the president united
states at the time
any government official or government
employee about the fact
this is now prior to january 6
about the fact that there was a risk
that people coming to washington for
january 6 demonstrations might become
violent uh object that's the fourth time
he's asked the same question
really is the same question
what you asked questions last time
i don't i don't recall
ms green did you ever hear that um
from any source prior to january 6 that
some folks were planning to come
to washington on january 6th and the
idea was that they were going to flood
the capitol with people
no i don't remember ever hearing that
you never discussed that with anybody
no i do not remember that
um
but you supported the idea of people
coming to washington on january 6th
and flooding the capital right
no i support people's first amendment
to have a peaceful protest use their
freedom of speech well previously you've
publicly said
that one way for people to express their
displeasure with their government would
be to flood the capitol building with
people right that is true there's video
versus capital belongs to the people
they that's where you come and speak to
your uh senators your representatives
you you come to express your views you
come to talk about how you want your tax
dollars spent you come to talk about how
you want senators or representatives to
vote
my question is a bit more narrow than
that in 2019 she did say publicly
expressed support for the idea
that people should come to washington to
express their displeasure with their
government
by flooding the capitol
move on
can we have um please show the video 23
please please show the video
it's the one where she appears to be in
a hotel room with a black hat on right
now
23 which is a
there's no way they can't play this
video this is the cnn article i believe
that you sent me um
in in 2019 marjorie taylor green told
protesters to flood the capital and feel
free to use violence
here we go they're objecting because
they're gonna they're they're gonna show
the proof that she just purges back high
school
uh you have to be treated with
statements that like flood the capital
flood the capital you're honored
it's not appropriate
you might if you can figure out how
you're going to lay the foundation for
this you might proceed
thank you
um
i want to direct your attention
representative green to the second page
of this exhibit
shelly could she could you please go
through the proper things so she knows
what she's looking at
uh yes what
i thought i did but i didn't hear it i'm
sorry okay
um
ms green this is an article that
appeared
um
we believe in um
on cnn
in the wake of january 6th i ask if
you've seen this document before
um no i haven't seen it
yeah i can't remember all the rants i do
um
to be fair i don't remember the one i
did yesterday i mean to be paired well
i'm gonna it was two hours
you weren't telling people to flood the
capitol that's true you can tell me
whether you made them or not okay the
second page of the document
has a quotation that reads quote
all of us together when we rise up we
can end all of this we can end it
we can do it peacefully we can i hope we
don't have to do it the other way i hope
not
but we should feel like we will if we
have to
because we are the american people do
you recall making that statement
in 2019
in connection with a protest around
fund the wall
no i don't recall
can we play the video
are you denying that you made that
saying
i think he has the video i think he has
played the video i'm saying
if someone says i can't recall then i
would follow them be like does this
refresh your memory and then play the
actual video right play the video with
your words like one thing to see print a
photo of the video and printed text but
it's another to actually see her say the
words right which i hope to god they're
going to do
i mean maybe is it a possibility they're
not allowed to enter video into evidence
i mean i don't know i don't know why
they wouldn't but well i mean it's an
article and the article has a video so i
feel like it wouldn't be right i don't
see how you couldn't but i'm i'm sorry
i'm not the lord
i'm missing a page in my copy of the
exhibit okay
i'm sorry bottom of yeah
technical difficulties
uh a little further along in the article
i'm just going to ask you whether you
made this this comment
um
if we have a sea of people we will shut
down the streets if we shut down
everything if we flood the capitol
building go inside these are public
buildings we own them we own these
buildings do you understand that we own
the buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings
did you say that in connection with the
fund the wall
demonstration in february of 2019. and
because it's about the fun the wall
demonstration i knocked the uh
after she was sworn in as a member of
congress
did you say that
i don't recall you're using cnn and
they've chopped up my words so many
times they've lied about me so many
times i mean
just kind of like a video any conspiracy
theories
oh you believe in q a right oh
here we go
i did
[Music]
this is relevant
let me guess what px84 please as well
okay so under earth she said she doesn't
believe the q a now the videos that are
relevant to this she didn't say that
don't say she doesn't believe in them
she said she didn't say that she
is that your
uh face karen being so smart over here
paying attention to the words
so this is a video question this is why
women should rule the world by the way
you know and sometimes that's dude
i mean good point he starts running this
uh i want
i object unless he assures us that this
is the complete
clip not uh selected
that is the entire we haven't touched it
your honor okay i'm not saying you
touched it right well this is on
that you're prepared to play this i
think your responsibility and i'm asking
the court to require this or object
is to make sure that this is not taken
out of it is this the video that you
sent me
i think you should be recording yeah so
i think this whole time he was just
setting the quotes
with which this proceeding had to go
forward
we have been denied the opportunity to
issue subpoenas to get records to do
precisely what mr bob would like me to
do in fact mr bob objected to all of
those things and said we don't want them
to do those things so the idea now that
he is objecting to us playing a portion
of his own client's words she can defend
herself quite ably she will tell us if
it's out of context or if it's q and on
or something else
first of all
what is this again this is a video we
believe of the congresswoman making a
statement
and where did it come from it came from
uh the the cnn article links to it
from facebook
so this is but this was pulled off of
what the internet
well it was it was oh jesus christ
what's the internet what's the internet
what the hell is the internet
today's show explaining what email is
that's what was there that's what was
there yes okay have you made any
alterations no sir are you aware of any
option no sir
okay what's this www dot thing at the
beginning what is that i think you can
now ask the witnesses about it can we
can we play the video please okay great
they can ask
in washington dc on february 23rd and
protesting march with me at 8 am really
please i'm begging you
if we have
i okay if we have a sea of people if we
shut down the streets if we shut down
everything if we flood the capitol
building flood all the government
buildings go inside these are public
buildings we own them
we own these buildings
do you understand that we own the
buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings you know what
february 23rd may be kind of cold we're
going to go inside we're going to be
warm
and then we're going to demand that our
federal government serve we the people
because we're sick and tired of their
ways
we're sick and tired of the corruption
see here's the issue
here's the issue america they think that
we're stupid and they treat us like
we're stupid and we allow it
we allow it
well no more we're not going to allow it
any more
we want solutions to the problems we
want to take care of america america is
first americans come first with
americans taxpayer dollars
we're done
we're done
and we have a massive list of grievances
okay we have a huge list of grievances
and that's why on february 23rd
in washington dc at 8 am
we are going to march and protest and i
am telling you to get your butt there
i'm begging all of you to be there
be there let's make this huge there's a
lot of really really great people
organizing this you don't even know
you were urging people to come to
washington and flood the capitol right
what year was that
you tell me i believe it was for
february 23rd 2019 right
there was no violence that day we
peacefully protested fair enough but my
point is to ask you the question
you were urging people for that
demonstration to flood the country to
peacefully protest with me and enter the
capitol and and ask our lawmakers to
[Music]
serve the american people
she does know she's under oath right now
right
so so now you remember giving that
statement right
now that we've watched the video i'll
remember that now that your memory has
been jogged a little bit do you remember
talking now my recall sentences have
been heightened being done now that i
pieced all the things yeah
that demonstration was peaceful right
and you remember that you said we can do
it peacefully right of course i only
believe in peaceful demonstrations i do
not support violence
in fact what you said is we can do it
peacefully we can i hope we don't have
to do it the other way i hope not but we
should feel like we will if we have to
because we are the american people that
was another statement that you made in
the same presentation right that was in
your cnn article and i don't trust cnn
as a source yeah why why
i don't think that that video was
i'm not i just don't recall i'm not
recalling saying specifically that
you're saying it doesn't it helps her it
helps your kids totally and the fact
that this thing about the violence
wasn't in there
i mean like one is to say like you know
flood the capitals to say like there's
like some
history of that thought in her mind but
then also as a means of saying like oh
you
we need to
get back to task
ms green did you or any member of your
government or campaign staff
communicate
with anthony aguero
about the events of january 6th prior to
january 6th i don't recall
um did you or any member of your staff
either congressional staff or campaign
staff communicate with somebody named
dustin stockton
prior to january 6th i don't think i
know who that is okay
um how about jennifer lawrence not the
actress but jennifer lawrence who's
involved in conservative politics did
you or any member of your congressional
campaign staff do you ever learn
prior to january 6 about the
demonstrations that were planned for
that day i don't recall i don't think i
know who that is
[Music]
we better start playing some actual
videos that show them
ms green
uh provide any support
for any demonstrations that occurred on
january 6 2021.
i i have no idea i don't think so i
don't know did you or any member of your
staff provide information advice
funds printed material
the promise of a public statement
to withhold a public statement
anything along those lines
in connection with the demonstrations
that were planned for january 6th
i don't remember i don't think so
and if somebody were to come in here and
say oh yeah she gave us support for our
demonstrations
you'd say i don't remember that
that didn't happen
i
i'm not sure what you're saying i think
you're speculating that's hypothetical
prior to january 6 2021 you heard that
people were planning to enter the
capitol on january 6th
uh and engage in violence right
now i object that i think that's the
fifth time
well no chance question no
never heard that from anybody no
yeah
and prior to january 6 2021 you were
aware that people were going to
make noise outside the capitol as a
means to disrupt the proceedings inside
the capitol is that fair no i have no
idea what you're talking about okay
and prior to january 6 2021 had you
heard that people were planning to enter
the capitol building illegally in order
to disrupt the electoral account process
no absolutely not i don't know anything
about that
okay
your honor it's i think 12 45 is well
let's talk about that uh how much longer
do you think he missed
you know
probably an hour all right well why
don't we take an i'm going to change
let's take an hour and let's be back
here at
12 45 so that's 145 right
could i respectfully ask for to make it
45 minutes only 40 comments you want to
make it 12 30
i mean 130 i'm sorry i'm
challenged
which will be one-third thank you sir
i believe it's secure right
it should be secure yeah
we'll see everybody back at 1 30.
um
okay so it looks like they're gonna take
a lunch here and uh karen i i know you
kind of have a heart out here uh soon um
so as we watch marjorie taylor greene
leave the courtroom you you said you
thought that the video helped or not
hurt her why why do you say that i mean
first of all it was 2019 right it was
not had nothing to do with january 6.
number one number two as she pointed out
there was no violence that day nothing
bad happened
number three
she was urging people to exercise their
first amendment right you know to come
and
tell the politicians what they think i
mean how does that help you know how
does that hurt her in any way if
anything it it supports exactly what
she's saying which is yeah she calls for
peaceful protests and
and guess what happens peaceful protests
so
if if something happened on january 6 i
mean why where is the evidence of what
she did on january 6 it wasn't in the
opening statement and so far we haven't
seen a single thing other than a cnn
article which she has successfully been
able to say well i don't trust cnn
they're twisting my words so aren't
there videos out there is there not
anything about what she did or said that
they can play about about january 6. i
i hope they have more i can't believe
they only have an hour i this to me you
have marjorie taylor green under oath
you can ask her every question you want
about january 6 and and what led up to
it i think she should be on the stand
for
a day a full day
under cross-examination
which is what this is because she's a
hostile witness so they're able to
cross-examine her typically that would
be
not allowed unless you are an adverse
witness or a hostile witness
um
can you explain the difference between
the two uh
adverse like what that means so normally
when when you have the burden and you
are calling a witness and it's your
witness you have to ask what's called uh
direct examination questions and
which means you're not allowed to lead
the witness you're not allowed to ask
leading questions it's you know so what
happened next you know this is is and
then what happened i mean that those are
basically your questions so you know
directing your attention to january 6
you know
were you there that day yes tell me what
happened you know like what happened
next and what happened next and what
happened next i mean that's what a
direct examination is and then when
you're done putting your evidence on
then you uh the opposing counsel gets to
what's known what's called
cross-examine the witness and those are
leading questions and that's you know
isn't it true that you said
this isn't it true that you did that
isn't it true
you know those are the
isn't it true questions right um and and
that's called cross-examination and it's
and it's very specific you know on
direct you're not allowed to ask
cross-examination type questions and on
you know and on on cross typically you
don't ask direct you know leading i'm
sorry open-ended questions because you
want to control the witness and get your
narrative out you don't want them to you
know say say those things so that's just
sort of sort of um
the rules of evidence in every courtroom
across america you know that's just sort
of what happens but
um there's something called an adverse
witness or a hostile witness and um and
and that's what that that's what she is
here meaning she's not going to even
though the plaintiff has the burden of
proof so they need to call her as a
witness she's not a witness for them
right she's she's
um
she's going to say things that are
adverse to the plaintiff's position so
they ask the judge to designate her an
adverse witness or a hostile witness and
if the judge does that that permits the
person who's calling her in this case
the petitioners to cross-examine her and
that's what this is this that's why this
looks more like a cross-examination than
a direct examination because that's what
it is
um and when you cross-examine someone
like this you know cross-examination i
mean my husband just had a trial where
the main witness was cross-examined by
my husband who's a criminal lawyer for
six days i mean cross-examination can
take you know it's not something that
you do quickly especially when you have
a witness like this when you have a
witness this important this big
and i i think you um i think you have
her on the stand you don't want to go
too long because then you sort of annoy
the judge and and sort of fatigue you
know the watch the people who are
watching but i think a day a full day of
marjory taylor green would be
appropriate here i would say it's much
more than one more hour
and i would start hitting that hitting
her with with things that help your case
i mean i on i have not seen one thing
yet
uh other than the fact that she looks
like she's being evasive and i don't
recall i don't recall i don't recall um
you know other than that i haven't seen
one thing yet that helps the plaintiff
you know nothing they haven't brought
out their strongest evidence if it
exists i mean i assume it exists right
you guys keep saying there's videos out
there and there's all these things out
there um i you know i haven't
i
you know i i haven't followed it as
closely as you have frankly um so i just
don't recall you know sound like her
what exactly the evidence is against her
um but whatever it is if it's out there
that he better come back from lunch and
he better hit hard with that and
whatever the the and i would play the
videos because you know those are her
words and she can't say oh well it's cnn
taking it out of context twisting my
words i don't know i don't know i don't
know play the videos of her words on
january 6 or on january 5th or on
january 3rd or whenever those those
occurred play those videos play her
words and and show your put your best
foot forward and take take back the
narrative the commissioner has lost the
narrative here so let me let me show you
let me show the video because it was
hard to hear in the in the clip i think
we have the video here i'm going to
re-show it here i i've got it downloaded
let's it's only like 20 30 seconds let's
let's re-show this one real quick if we
have a sea of people if we shut down the
streets if we shut down everything if we
flood the capitol building flood all the
government buildings go inside these are
public buildings we own them
we own these buildings
do you understand that we own the
buildings and we pay all the people
that work in the buildings
so i think i think um
the video
um in the context that he tried to use
it is irrelevant um i think if he would
have said what was your mindset on
january 6th have you ever had this
mindset before about protest have you
ever said these things before about
prior protests that even if they ended
up
peaceful did you have the mindset that
if they weren't peaceful and you would
have to use violence that you may do
that right so if he would i i think if
he would have questioned a little better
before cueing up the video um and again
he kept asking the same question but
that part but that thing but that part
that he keeps talking about the if
necessary use violence that wasn't on
the video
he didn't play that
he didn't he didn't play he didn't play
if if necessary he said that was in the
scene that's my point the video that he
played did not that that to me is the
only phrase of that whole video matters
that matters
and he didn't play it or i didn't i
missed it and i didn't hear it but he
didn't play that where that i think is
is in the cnn part where she's like well
i don't recall saying that part of it
because it's not on the video and my
words are taken out of context by them
so if that's on video play that part of
the video you're right if necessary use
violence yeah yeah do you have the video
where she is uh and it's before january
6th but it's about uh when she comes
outside the white house that's right
that's right that one can you find that
one for me
the people in the comments are saying
that was in the video maybe i missed it
you know and if that's the case then yes
i would i would focus on that
right i didn't hear her say that if
that's on that video
you know i i then then i i apologize i i
did miss that part well and and i think
but i think that's relevant though is
what you're saying is that is that your
what what
they're asking the judge to do in the
case of that video is for the judge to
say that she is not allowed to be on a
ballot in this administrative hearing
because she said that one phrase in a
video in 2019 that's not related to
january 6 and i think what you're saying
is that's not enough to get her off the
ballot right now this may damage her
politically i and i believe that this
testimony is very damaging politically
and the reason why is because people are
going to be able to cut clips of this
thing and make her into what just
appears to be an outright liar um and
that's good but don't forget they have
to show that she was part of an
insurrection right right correct and
2019 not an insurrection in fact she
pointed out it wasn't even violent so i
don't understand how that helps at all
get to january 6 get to the actual
injury actual insurrection because
that's all that's even if her mindset
was
a thousand times to use violence use
violence abuse violence even if they can
prove that if that wasn't her mindset on
january 6 it doesn't matter
they have to prove
by a very
low burden preponderance of the evidence
that her mindset
and that she did on january 6
um basically encouraged this
insurrection you know that she
participated in this insurrection in
some way and that and they need to show
that and so far what have they shown
that has anything to do with january 6.
and i i i hope the evidence is there and
if it is they got to start showing it
i'm going to i'm going to play yeah so
context here is this the video that
we're going to play is actually from
december 2020 so before she ever took
the oath
this is where she was at the white house
already planning january 6th
and and uh um
this is like you said this is before but
this is about specific events of january
6. so this is a video where she is
talking about the events of january 6.
i'm going to make sure yeah i get the
volume here let's go
just finished with our meetings here at
the white house this afternoon we had a
great planning session for our january 6
objection we aren't going to let this
election be stolen by joe biden and the
democrats president trump won by a
landslide call your house reps call your
senators from your states we've got to
make sure they're on board and we
already have a lot of people engaged
okay stay tuned
and and like and i know i think i
already know what karen's going to say
here she's going to say where does she
say well karen you're going to say where
in the hell tony does she say in this
video that there's going to be a violent
insurrection let's call your senators
right and that's look that that's
that's not that's your absolute
fundamental right that is not being an
insult like again regardless of what her
intention is here of this video because
her intent is not does not play into
what her words actually are right or
does it but where's the evidence where's
the evidence right right so this video
isn't evidence yeah yeah so i mean i
look at this and i say well the other
lawyer is saying january 3rd and on is
where things count but here is an
example of where she was already putting
the steps forward
to object no but must but she said call
your senator call your congressman
that's not a violent don't think no yeah
the definition of an insurrection is the
violent overthrow
of
of a government okay and you're
advocating the violent violent it has to
be violent it's not enough to you know
all the people who went to court to say
that um i think the election was stolen
and there was fraud that's not an
insurrection that's actually you're
right you have a right to protest and to
try and and object to um an election
frankly and to call your senators call
your congressman you're allowed to do
that in fact you're encouraged to do
that that's again one of the fundamental
bedrocks of our democracy where is there
was a there there's clearly an
insurrection that day right there was an
attempt of a violent overthrow of
of uh you know just
whether you want to call it overthrowing
the government or stopping the election
or you know the peaceful transfer of
power whatever it was it's clear there
was a violent insurrection that day you
know at the end of the day where is the
evidence that she
encouraged it participated in it was
part of it there has to be that evidence
and if there isn't that evidence this is
game over and so far as i've seen
nothing
so so let me ask you because
you're saying specifically and i want
the audience to be clear on this karen
is saying specifically the game over
it's not that there's evidence out there
that other than what we see in public on
social media
in a in a possible
expulsion of congress in a possible
criminal trial even if that is if that
is the possibility that the doj would
bring a case against her what you're
saying specifically is this evidence
here does not allow this judge in this
moment to make the administrative action
to take her off of the primary ballot um
and
regardless of criminality or what
evidence there is a criminality i i
don't know i don't know exactly what the
uh partitioners have access to as far as
you know what they can get you know what
what evidence they can gather up which
if they have something maybe that's the
huge bombshell that we're waiting for
here um but but i think what you're
saying is specifically that
in this moment for this judge to make
this decision to take her off the ballot
for this primary race
so far
kfa has not seen the meat and potatoes
to make sure that she cannot appear on
this ballot and that judge is probably
not going to make that decision um
because like you said he's not going to
be quote unquote wrong uh past an
appellate court right like no judge
wants their decision overturned by an
appellate court and i mean unless
they're just dying to be overturned but
i don't think any judge wants their
rulings to be overturned right they want
to be correct in other words if it does
get appealed they want their decision to
stand basically in a case this strong i
mean
you know this i'm sorry this this hypo
this high profile he's not going to
um yes absolutely the judge is going to
is going to be very conservative in the
sense of not politically conservative um
but conservative in his ruling he's not
going to do something
where he could be wrong
um
look i'm not happy
that this is
what you know i say these things and i
worry that people might think that i'm
somehow supporting marjorie taylor green
or you know
i i'm not i don't like that i'm saying
what the things that i'm saying what i'm
saying is play the bad videos right
right or or the bad text messages or
show the phone call the the phone you
know
the the
um the fact that there was there's phone
activity between
her and
and people who you know then came and
did violent you know things on the
capitol like
show
you know it's
at the end of the day when you're in a
court of law it's about evidence it's
not about feelings it's not about
political beliefs it's not about
anything other than evidence and it has
to be uh it has to be you know that's
why that's why they make people
go under oath because
you know you you can't lie it has to be
admissible it has to be reliable and it
has to be relevant and um
and i just
you know i'm i i feel like i'm i'm being
more of a um
you know just a a
you know an umpire or whatever calling
falls and strikes like
they're you know put your strong put
your evidence out there and they haven't
done that yet and you know if they're if
there are i don't want to put you guys
on the spot
but if you think there are sort of
smoking gun videos or
or evidence out there that is just so
clear that's been kind of widely
shared on social media or in the news
i mean maybe maybe play it you know
maybe kind of tease it out and call it
out for the people watching it who can
look out for it i mean i unfortunately
i'm gonna have to leave in a little
while and and i can't believe i have to
miss the afternoon but i have an
appointment that i i can't i can't
change um because i i really want to see
what this evidence turns out to be but
so i haven't seen it and i'll tell you
that i think we're going to stay with
this we're going to go ahead weather on
lunch we're going to do our quick
session of bonehead of the week um and
and so i appreciate you joining us karen
and i want everyone to understand this
is why i like having karen on the show
is because karen is truly pro-democracy
she believes in institution she believes
in the vote she believes that the people
and our constitution
if we use it wisely will will turn out
the best result it's not perfect
democracy is not perfect justice is not
perfect we all know that from the the
just the piles and piles of cases that
we've seen um you know in in court that
sometimes certain uh folks in our
population people of color mainly and
and poor folk as well do not receive
the the justice that maybe rich folks
and white folks receive in this country
but but but we can't abandon
pro-democracy
values in in making sure that we get the
authoritarian decision that we want
because as much as you may hate marjorie
taylor green as much as you may
vehemently disagree with her as much as
you think she's vile and she's an
insurrectionist and she caused the
violent insurrection and she was part of
it
she is afforded the same rights as
everyone else and that you would want to
be afforded and let's face it if we
afford her if we the people afford her
those rights then hopefully our rights
will be guaranteed as well so i want
everyone to understand that that is that
is the position that karen has taken
here and i think if there is any
criminal evidence that the doj has that
doesn't mean that these uh uh
these petitioners would have that
evidence that's not that's not exactly
it so if there is evidence out there
that exists in the world that we do not
have that the petitioners do not have
that gabe cannot uh search here well
he's really trying to find it here no
i'm just kidding um
then we
if it exists and the department of
justice gets their hands on it and there
is criminal activity then uh hopefully
we do not demand authoritarianism we
demand justice and we demand to be a
pro-democracy and have those
institutions bring marjorie taylor green
and anyone else to justice for the
violent insurrection on january 6. now
if you want more balls and strikes as
karen says
please go follow uh and subscribe to
midas touch legal af podcast because
karen is the co co-host with michael
popock on wednesday's edition of legal
af
and
our one of our favorite legal show here
but this is why i like to have karen on
is because she does care about those
institutions she does care about
democracy and and that is most important
to me um when we are trying to get our
message out there is that we're
pro-democracy we are not for merrick
garland being a bill barr that's not
what i want i want merrick garland to be
the attorney general of the united
states and i want him to direct his
united states attorneys to bring anyone
to justice whether rather be january 6
or any other thing
in a way that does not violate someone's
constitutional rights and does it
correctly as best as they possibly can
and that our democracy can deliver
justice i that's what i want from
merrick garland um and i hope that's
what we see i think that's what we're
going to see i think karen will agree
with you but karen before we leave tell
us where we can find legal af tell us
where we can find karen on all the
tweety tweets and trendy trends because
i know everyone wants to leave
um so
legal af you can get it pretty much
wherever you get your podcast but
youtube is a pretty easy place to to get
it you just put in legal af and you'll
you'll get that or you can go to the
midas touch
uh subscribe to their channel and it's
on there um also i'm i have a twitter
account i think i'm i think it's at kfa
legal yeah we got it right there on the
screen right there there you go yeah
okay
so go over and follow follow character
and you've got a you've got a mug i
think that has your logo on it right
yeah yeah yeah
i already put that in the dishwasher
okay oh okay well well go go check out
the legal af mugs um and and help karen
out let's get her twitter account up
let's get her some twitter followers
over there um she she's been trying to
get more on twitter i think i think
you're doing a great job trying to uh
come come to the tweety tweets in the
trenches you know i was a i was a
prosecutor for almost 30 years and
because of that i
really did not have a social media
presence because we just couldn't you
know we really couldn't be on social
media so i had a you know like a little
personal facebook kind of account that
you know you just you you watch your
your cousins and nieces and nephews sort
of you know that kind of account but
it's only until i left a year ago where
now i can sort of get on social media so
i'm i'm starting to get my sea legs and
you know
they're i'm starting to learn kind of
how to do it and i'm i'm really enjoying
it but that's why my social media is a
little bit you know delayed it was
because i just couldn't do it for many
many years but i'm i'm getting into it
now so well everyone go ahead i was i
was gonna say i'm you know tony and i
both appreciate it and i'm sure everyone
who's watching especially today but
other times if they come into the
podcast for your show
uh or when you pop into our show um
really appreciate the legal perspective
and that you know you said 30 years as
prosecutors so it's you know gonna it's
only gonna trump any armchair lawyer
that uh decided to become a legal expert
over covets hey easy on po poc easy on
vote
out loud or crying out loud easy on
guarantee no i'm kidding i'm kidding
we've had po poc on and and popock does
poppins but we we enjoy carrying for
karen's much prettier than pop let's
face it though
well hey i think and i've said this
before i think women should rule the
world i think men have done a horrible
job at it maybe that's the situation
that we're in today and why we're here
um with with some of the things that
we've done um and specifically men like
trump um so i think i think if we can
get ourselves in a position where uh
people who are level-headed who have a a
better opportunity to actually govern
and do policy um i think i think we'll
have more outcomes of justice so karen
thank you thank you for joining us thank
you for having me
yes it was fantastic i know i know i
messaged you late at night last night
when we found out this marjorie taylor
green thing uh i was super excited if
you said yes so thank you very much for
coming and yeah now i appreciate you
having me i was i really uh it gave me
an excuse to get to watch this so okay
great great great great well you you
have a good appointment and and uh yeah
well maybe we'll have you down next week
when we find out more about what happens
yeah
i have a feeling i'm going to miss the
the good stuff so
well you know
thank you karen very much you have a
good afternoon uh we're going to get to
bonehead of the week here thank you
karen bye-bye bye-bye
okay everybody um
well there we go that was you i didn't
yeah i i i take this as an opportunity
you can if you can uh
pull down the fort for like three
minutes oh do you gotta take a piss you
gotta know oh oh
you got some things you gotta i gotta i
have them i got no i don't absolutely
absolutely absolutely i just need to
switch from this room to the other room
oh okay great great great yeah let me
let me give some commentary we'll get to
bonehead of the week um and and we'll
come back with bonehead with gabe here
in a second let's do this let's take a
quick break don't go anywhere i promise
we're going to bone in the week and then
after bone at a week we are going to
stay live we're going to stay live here
um as soon as they come back in the
hearing room it looks like they're going
to come back at 1 30
which we may or may not be able to get
through bonehead here we may have to do
bonehead as a separate
as a uh as a separate thing i'm i'm not
sure we'll just have to uh figure out
time
uh
as far as it goes here's what we
normally do for all you new listeners
out there we do two hours every single
weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central on youtube
twitter and twitch so make sure you
follow and subscribe to our youtube
channel
uh that's very important that you follow
our our youtube channel that way you
don't miss a single episode because
we're not just on youtube twitter and
twitch we're also on the midas touch
facebook page for all you out there who
follow my touch on the facebook page you
probably noticed that our podcast is
showing up right there on the books of
face
so like and subscribe or like and and
you can go follow me on facebook if you
want i'm on the books of face i've got
an account over there you just type in
the tony michaels you'll find it but you
can go to thetonymichaels.com you can
find all the places
to follow
uh our podcast the tony michaels podcast
whether it be youtube twitch twitter or
mind a touch facebook page but make sure
you go over to twitter
and follow at tony michael's pod because
that's where the bonehead of the week
pole lives
uh bone of the week is a poll we do we
put we put some contestants up every
single week you
you
the viewer get to vote on who is the
bonehead of the week
and then on fridays normally when we
don't have uh marjorie taylor green
perjuring herself on the stand
live we normally go through bonehead of
the week and we do a breakdown and
that's what we're gonna do today
now rather we do it
um here before we get uh restarted here
or we do it uh after we have this um we
will have to make that decision on the
fly here so we will we will try to make
those decisions for you and get you get
you bonehead of the week breakdown but
you can go vote for bonehead of the week
and then we'll break it down every week
and and again if you don't if you want
to watch the show you can watch on
youtube but if you want to listen to the
show you can go to apple google spotify
you can download every single episode
this is a special edition episode we're
working on four hours right now on this
episode now this special edition episode
with marjorie taylor green appearing to
perjure herself on the stand that's what
appears to me it seems like there's
several lies that she's already told
under oath and that are easily prove
easily proven false now like karen said
she's trying to do the whole
oh i don't recall i don't remember
you know kind of thing uh you know i
understand that that's that's a thing
that you know she's trying to do not to
purge her herself uh mj here says in
super chat kfa legal
is awesome thank you yes we really thank
karen for coming on the show and giving
us her legal analysis um when i found
out last night that there was going to
be a hearing on marjory taylor green
appearing on the ballot and that the
cameras are going to be allowed in the
room like oh we're going to stream that
there's no way we're not going to stream
that um
for our audience i i think it's a huge a
huge thing to see inside
of this hearing
i think originally there wasn't going to
be cameras but marjorie taylor green
wanted cameras there because they wanted
to say that people were gonna spin this
into lies
well when you get on the stand in what
appears to be perjuring yourself where
you just lie lie lie lie lie of stuff
that's pretty much provable
um that's where the lights come from
marjorie taylor green hoof foot merge
it really is ridiculous but
this is what we're here to do
um that's what we're here to do is to
show you the truth do not look away
because our democracy is important
and marjorie taylor green
as much as everyone wants her to be
taken off the ballot
in georgia now rather it's the
the ballot that they're working with
today which is the primary ballot
because that's super important uh minus
ken says uh uh marger taylor green has a
monopoly on bone end of the week she
actually appears on our bone end of the
week but ken you might be disappointed
but stick around you'll find out who
wins the bonehead of the week now but
thank you ken for the super chat
um but our democracy is important and
the ballot that they want to take her
off of is the primary ballot right
it is the primary ballot not
not the ballot
that is
let's see are we coming back here no
this is uh earlier okay
uh it is not the ballot that would be
the general election
now
uh you know i think i think a good way
to take marjorie taylor green off the
ballot is to go vote for her opponent
right like
in this primary race specifically um to
go vote for her opponent that way
there's a different republican on the
general election ballot that would be a
good way to take marjorie taylor green
off the ballot
uh it really would whereas right now
we're trying to rely on a judge to make
a decision that
i i'm actually in agreeance with uh
a karen kfa i think that it's possible
that this judge is gonna take the path
of least resistance and he's gonna kick
this can down the road and he's going to
say let the people decide right just
kind of what i'm saying and really
honestly i i don't know that that's the
wrong decision i don't know if it's the
right decision it depends on what
evidence that the the
petitioners here bring up in this second
line of questioning after lunch but um
if gabe is ready we'll go ahead and go
because you're you are you're not no i
am yeah okay
the only one the only one that remains
is who are the
dishonorable mentions gonna be
oh well you know let's let's go to bone
end of the week because um yeah
lookie there no
oh the the real bonehead of the week um
here's our here's our contestants this
week marjorie taylor green obviously for
today's ron desantis and greg abbott but
let's let's start the um let's do the
the whole thing where we where we do the
music and then we'll do bone end of the
week and when when the hearing starts
we'll end bonehead of the week and we'll
go back
all right let's start let's start the
music
[Music]
[Applause]
holy moly new graphics huh
video
did the graphics department is is on top
of it this week it's like somebody's
paying me i guess so no no they're not
no no one's paying the gravity
department they work they work for free
here at the tony michaels podcast
welcome to bone end of the week
your addition you guys vote
you decide who is the bone man of the
week and we break it down for you i'm
speaking that here is bone of the week
and and to just tell all the listeners
out there who were just listening to
bone end of the week because we actually
post bone head of the week on youtube uh
of its own video that way if you guys
miss bone of the week you can watch it
separately so all of you out there
watching bone of the week right now that
didn't watch the episode the five hour
episode that it appears that this is
going to be this week
cut this out right right we will cut
bone into the week out but if you're
watching just bone of the week know that
it's probably going to be a short
version
because what we're doing today is we're
listening in on the insurrection hearing
of marjorie taylor green and we're
giving commentary as that goes so this
is a special edition episode on this
friday
april 22nd
and so we may or may not uh have a long
bone of the week but to get to it here
marjorie taylor green is on this list
because
because today's episode because of
today's episode so we'll skip over that
if you want to find out more about why
marjorie taylor green is a bonehead i
mean just google marjory taylor green
you'll figure it out um but moving to
the next bonehead of the week is uh greg
abbott greg abbott is the governor of
texas well sort of
i mean sort of don't you think
yeah i mean if anything he's um
he's a literal drain on our uh right tax
our tax money our gdp
i think of what it was nine billion his
whole stunt has cost that is the reason
why i wanted him
because he won
he won bonehead of the week last week if
you recall and the reason why he won
bone in the week last week is because he
was emptying grocery store shelves he
was destroying hundreds of millions of
dollars worth of produce because he
wanted to manufacture a crisis so that
people would blame it on joe biden
and he cost the state of texas and he
cost the united states this week we find
out almost 9 billion dollars and that my
friends is the reason why he's on bone
head of the week this week so his cause
and effect last week he won because of
the cause this week he's on because of
the fact and we'll find out if he won or
not but here's the thing
here's the thing that republicans are
gonna do
he he cost us nine billion dollars in
the united states and what the
republicans are going to do they're
going to tax you they're going to tax
you to try to get that nine billion
dollars back they already have a tax
plan and um that several are running
around the country bragging about that's
gonna that's gonna tax you forty five
hundred dollars more so the middle class
is gonna pay for that nine billion
dollars
but which brings me to which brings me
to another one of our boneheads here um
another one of our bone and speaking of
republicans wanting to tax their
citizens and the constituents ron
desantis has decided it's a good idea to
tax folks over uh this his fight with
mickey mouse well he wants to he wants
to pass the buck because disney has a
tax incentive to be where they are right
and also keep in mind that disney is a
huge money-making machine for the state
of florida jobs uh i mean basically he
says
yeah do not come do not come to the most
visited place in florida do not come
here and spend your money you stay out
of the state because disney's woke or
whatever the right whatever craziness
that they're trying to spend here
because disney's on the side of equality
because that's what's happened they
passed the do not say gil gay bill uh in
florida and the the actual story is is
that disney was not against the don't
say gay bill at first
um as a company they actually funded
some of the groups that were kind of
behind the don't say gay bill and when
the employees of disney world found out
about this they decided that they would
say well if you support this bill now
now that we know that you did support it
and now that we know that you won't be
against it we will walk out we will walk
out and we and we will not work here at
disney world and and disney being the
company that they are did not want to do
that to their cast members they call
them cast members
their employees essentially
um and the ceo decided to change his
tune
and just and he actually released a
statement and not so many words he said
disney will always be on the side of
equity inequality and i made a mistake
here and we are going to be on the side
of equity equality and we want we want
florida to to basically throw the don't
say gay bill in the trash
i just looked it up and disney was so i
looked up the most visited place in the
us because i was curious myself you know
not only is it the most visited in uh uh
florida but
in a list of places that are the most
visited in the us you've got times
square central park union station so all
things within the east coast new york
area then it's magic kingdom disney
world then disneyland resort then walt
disney world
at epcot distance animal kingdom walt
disney world disney's hollywood studios
walt disney world right so you look at
these and like in the top 10 like
there's like five of them
that are all disney world specific but
gabe it's because it is disney i really
i really don't think that ron desantis
did a lot of political calculations
before they went on this crusade of
making disney the enemy i thought they
thought it was going to be really easy
because the left and the right has tried
to um boycott disney over the years
right yeah and boycotting a company is a
little different than a state legislator
or a governor taking legal action in
their state based on laws and rules that
are already in place in their state um
it is a lot different to say go boycott
them than to take away a special tax
status now
most people think um well
most of the maga the trump supporting
desantis supporting morons out there
think that disney is getting a tax break
through this special assessment and that
is the exact opposite that is happening
what disney world did when they went to
florida they bought huge swaziland it's
the size of approximately like five
counties like it's humongous right it's
not small and what disney said was is
instead of the state spending a lot of
money on our special service
infrastructure so uh water sewer
uh power plants fire departments police
departments and security um there's just
a whole host of services that we receive
as taxpayers that we actually don't even
recognize that we get until we don't
have them right now disney did this so
that they could build their
infrastructure and they could pay for
that infrastructure as opposed to the
state of florida and their disney would
do this for a lot of reasons number one
they wanted to have control over the
upgrades of those services as they build
their parks right and then they would
expand disney world so that makes a
little bit of sense
the other thing they didn't want to do
was fight with the state over these
services so it made sense for them to
take on the cost
of these special services inside this
assessed area that is disney world that
disney owns right and and to do this
what ron desantis is wanting to do
is make sure that the state of florida
now has control over those services
which means the state of florida now has
to foot the bill so what ron desantis is
saying is because disney wants to be for
equality and equity which is something
ron desantis hates equality and equity
that we what we're going to do is we're
going to tax the citizens of florida to
make sure they're not for equality and
equity that is literally what he's
saying so if you if you are i mean if
you are a bigot and you do not like
disney because you are a bigot then the
state of florida is going to pay for
your cause but if you're someone who
really doesn't give a damn if gay people
are married or not if if lgbt
communities have their rights
and you want to go to disney and you
don't want to have to have floridians
pay for disney to have these special
services inside their their district as
it's called
then you're probably on the side of it
ron desantis is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and a
bonehead right i mean for a party that
says uh oh do your own research
ron desantis is somebody who did not
actually do his own research on this he
was like oh i'm gonna make a move that
you know what they're gonna they're
gonna balk and they're gonna they're
gonna come back and say oh we're so
sorry we apologize we really need this
meanwhile i'm not saying that disney
world could just like up and leave and
go to another state while they very well
could uh you know that realistically
that's not gonna happen so anyone who
says it is i think it's a little
unrealistic right but
they
disney does have a lot of the
you know a lot of leverage here and i
think they do have the cards in their
favor
and ron desantis is going to see this
because no one can bypass the fact that
if
this does in fact have to go to
uh the the buck is passed to the
constituents and the taxpayers
there's no way to to to to flip that any
any other way right you're like oh
this company said they support lgbtq ron
desantis doesn't and as a result now we
remove this uh
right yeah special assessment and now
you guys have to pay an extra two to
three k i don't mean to cut you off
gabriel yeah we're gonna have this
hearing coming back uh one thing i want
to do before we give the winner his due
i want to talk about our alpha kevin
mccarthy because just as we're seeing in
in this hearing with marjorie taylor
green the lying the outright lying the
reason why we made uh kevin mccarthy the
alpha cuck of the week is because kevin
mccarthy was lying about what he said
what he didn't say because the recording
came out last night uh rachel maddow
played it on msnbc and it sounds like
more came while we've been on this whole
course there's more more has come out
right so so uh kevin mccarthy he really
is probably i mean he's the alpha cuck
of the week but he's probably the
scumbag of the week as well right and
it's not surprising with these
republicans um of the lying and seeing
what marjorie's day they're green but
let's go to the winner let's give the
winner his due the winner is greg abbott
believe it or not you guys voted for my
surprise i really thought i really
thought um oh
no wait was that right
i don't think so that's why i'm
surprised i think you did it wrong oh i
did it wrong
who is it it's ron desantis right it's
ron desantis give me one second give me
one ron desantis is the winner yes um of
the bonehead of the week let's give him
his due and then we'll play your slide
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i i didn't actually have the um the
uh
the ability to look at this beforehand
and double check you did you just pull
because i think you pulled the slide
from last week didn't you oh my gosh
what is going this is what happens when
you're trying to multitask watching this
question i know i know because we are we
are we are trying to monitor
the marjorie taylor green uh
insurrection hearing uh speaking of
bonus she was on the bone end of the
week this week for this very reason she
was yes but you guys did not did it not
but you guys chose
um um
ron desantis and i am assuming you chose
ron desantis because he's a bigoted
scumbag um who hates mickey mouse this
and and since we know that he now is the
bonehead of the week
gabe would you ever get in a fight
um and especially a public relations
fight with mickey mouse
no that's so dumb i mean what the [ __ ]
was he thinking
like literally i understand like you
want to hate disney right like the
overall scope of things but literally
that the [ __ ] face of disney
walt disney himself made mickey mouse
the face the image of disney how in the
world do you think you're gonna win do
not mess with the mouse right he owns
the house all right so this is the
actual uh
okay the video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
great
oh my god
okay here's the thing here's the thing
we're gonna go back to the hearing
marjorie taylor green so bone end of the
week i blame it on marjorie taylor green
desantis please join us next week with
bonehead of the week where you can vote
follow us at tony michael's pod vote
there we're gonna go back to the hearing
thank you for joining us for bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we're gonna go back to the
hearing here uh let's see if i can
um
back on and yes she is back from january
3rd to january 6th
did you or anybody in your office
your congressional office
provide tours either formally or
informally
the people of the u.s capitol
no the only people that were with me was
my husband and my children
that would be on the third is that right
they were i don't recall the exact days
i believe they went back to georgia on
the fourth okay i'm trying to capture
the period
january 3rd when you were sworn in on
january
did anybody in your office provide tours
to anybody
no okay
and during that period
did anybody
on your campaign staff
or did you authorize a provision of
funds and money
to people who were planning a
demonstration on january 16th i don't
think so i don't recall that at all
if you wanted to know the answer to that
question who would you ask
um
i would have to talk to
people in my campaign but
i don't think we did anything how would
we have done that we didn't do anything
like that
um during that same period of january
3rd to january 6th
did you or anybody on your campaign or
congressional staff
provide any information of any sort
to anyone in connection with january 6
demonstrations
i don't think so
i have no idea i don't think so
and
did you have members of the public visit
your congressional office between
january 3rd and january
no
and during that period from january 3rd
to january 6
did anyone from your congressional
office or your campaign
provide
maps for the location of offices within
the capitol
no no we got our keys to my office on
january 3rd i i couldn't even find where
the bathroom was most of the time
you know why i'm asking these questions
don't you representative green i have no
idea why you're asking me questions
representative green
you're familiar with the
significance of the year 1776
in u.s history right
yes
1776 is the year that the declaration of
independence was signed
right and that was a statement
by representatives of the 13 colonies
that they were no longer subject to the
authority of the british crown
right
they were declared it was the
declaration of independence from the
british crown right and in fact you may
recall this from your studies the
declaration of uh independence refers to
king george tyson right
i'm sure it may say that somewhere in
the history books i don't have the
history books in front of me and i don't
know which one you're referring to but
well i'm referring to the declaration of
independence that's the one that says
that king george was a tyrant unfit to
be a ruler of africa are you quoting the
declaration okay well you'll accept that
if you're quoting it okay
and you would agree that
when a government
acts
tyrannically then it's unfit to be the
ruler of the free people
we're typically against tyrannical
governments here
and the people who
wrote the declaration of independence
they were working with other people in
the colonies
to express their independence from
britain right
i wasn't alive back then but there's the
history i'm not i'm not a history expert
but
as you've heard of the american
revolution haven't you of course i have
yes and you know that the american
revolution
was a violent rebellion
against british rule in the colonies
yes
and
they were trying to overthrow the
government
in britain
that was ruling the colonies right
uh america was trying to start our own
government
right and to do that they had to get rid
of the british colonial officials who
were here in america and throw them out
they yes
and they viewed
the british officials here and the crown
in britain as a tyrannical government
yes okay
that was an insurrection wouldn't you
agree
the american revolution was an
insurrection against the government i
don't believe it i don't know where it
said that
well i'm asking you whether or not you
agree
that the american revolution was an
insurrection against the british
government i believe it was the american
revolution was as part of our history
where we
separated from uh from the crown
and started our own government here
right and the separation was brought
about by violence right there was a
revolutionary war yes
um and the violence
the colonists were justified in using
violence
to get rid of the tyrannical government
of britain i actually think this is what
kfa was talking about earlier is he's
really i mean i don't know what he's
building here he's only got an hour
so he better get to it quick i mean
honestly this is you actually
you know if he had a whole two or three
days maybe this would be relevant
questioning but he better get to it
are you referencing something i've said
somewhere well do you recall talking
about that topic i've talked about the
declaration of independence but i don't
know what occasion you're referring to
okay
um
well one of the occasions
where you talked about the declaration
of independence
was in connection with january 6th right
i don't know okay let's go to
planus
15 please
hang on
the screen i'm going to play a short
clip and ask if that's you
speaking on the on the video okay what
what's the date on this i can't read it
here's some more video evidence i hope
we can hear it well um
gabe you want to see if you can find
this in case you're getting here
on trade or tv with steve bannon
it says
correct
that's your statement right
i don't believe it was finished but that
was me i don't i don't recall i don't
know what the rest of what i was saying
because it was cut off
it doesn't even matter what the brushes
she was saying
you were comparing
the overthrow of the british crown in
america in 1776
to january 6th i don't know what my
statement was because it was cut off
now you talked about the need for people
to have guns
in order to secure
their rights against the tyrannical
government i bet he has a video for this
one too yes we have a second amendment
for a good reason right
and the good reason is
in case they need to overthrow their
government they can use their guns to do
that
we we have us well
you're you're twisting things around
could you rephrase your question please
well i'm i'm reacting to your answer you
said we have second amendment amendment
that's a good thing and i said but the
reason from your point of view that
there is a second amendment is so that
people can overthrow their government by
violent means with guns that's not the
exact purpose we defend ourselves um
save you know if you're being attacked
um you know a gun is a tool to defend
yourself right and
but one of the things that could be used
for let's try that let's let's go to um
px6
i'm going to play a video here and ask a
couple questions about it um well first
let me just ask you do you recall um
giving an interview
as reflected on
px6
in october of 2020 just about a week
before the election
uh at something called the relic hunter
firearms shop
i vaguely remember okay and that's you
on the left and the gentleman on the
right is the owner of the shop am i
right about that
no okay who's that just right now uh
mr dore
who's mr door
he said he's a gun rights activist and
and
just someone i know got it and
it's backwards because of the video but
mr dora's t-shirts
says
um
let's say
i am 1776
sure
that no one is taking my guns
do you agree that that's what it says
yes okay
okay um so explain the video i i'm just
playing this i have
watch this
right in the middle
there is a section cut off
right in the middle well let's see oh it
has been edited
he doesn't even see the video yet and he
objects
he's like just play the video that's the
best yeah it is it's a video
what does it matter if if there's a
split in the footage it's just like when
she was like oh that was the end of the
video you said what you said adding
context unless you were quoting someone
else
who doesn't it doesn't add anything to
it
well i you know i know you'll need to
see it but don't say it
yeah the judge is like no if it's if
it's a video just play that goddamn
thing
by the way if we have a break i have the
uh clip of the last video thanks to gabe
sanchez our executive producers we're
not watching the whole thing we're
picking up in the middle of it is that
correct it's uh a minute and nine
seconds
i don't know what i'm asking is
oh i see it says sure i look like we
were halfway into the video that's why i
was i was good we started the beginning
yeah i'm putting the whole way back oh
jesus christ
grandpa judge mock balls here
geez louise
it's gone
and once it's gone freedom doesn't come
back by itself the only way you get your
freedoms back is that it's earned with
the price of blood we can't be too busy
or too complacent or too worried about
offending someone anymore it's there's
no more excuses this is this is it
november 3rd freedom is on the ballots
you have a choice of either voting for
freedom by voting for donald j trump for
president again for 4 years voting
republicans straight down your ballot or
you're going to vote for socialism and
vote to completely end america as we
know it and this is this is no joke they
do not want you to be able to defend
yourself because if you can defend
yourself guess what then you can stop a
tyrannical government however if they
take away your guns then you can't not
only can you that never stop a
tyrannical government you can never even
defend yourself if someone is breaking
in your home and and that's the reality
this is where we are today in 2020.
[Music]
everyone has access to all the evidence
that has been submitted so this [ __ ]
of like
trying to be like oh i don't i don't
approve this it was you already knew it
was coming
right
when it was cut
yeah okay yeah can you find that clip
too and and we get a minute we'll try to
replay because that one was really hard
to hear that one
yeah but in the video they were talking
about this uh the argument you know
can respond i mean she said she said a
lot of she said a lot of buzzwords
and and this
the judge the judge is uh making good
points here
representative green this is a statement
that you made in an interview with mr
dorr in october of 2020. that is a very
partial cut off and
that is me speaking but my sentences are
cut off oh message is not there okay if
you got a business you didn't build that
you remember that you remember that yep
what you say is if you can defend
yourself you can stop a tyrannical
government
however if they take away your guns
you can never stop the tyrannical
government right
correct okay you can you believe that
absolutely okay
and in fact
what was done in 1776
was to stop a tyrannical government with
guns
there
sir yeah and and that was to use
violence against a tyrannical government
to get that clear
there was a big process there was a big
build up there before the revolutionary
war
the whole purpose was not to use guns
for violence
is the narrative what do you use a gun
for i mean outside of a deterrent what
did you mean when you said that
um
once you lose your freedom it has to be
earned with the price of blood
and i've always said i never want to see
a war in this country
never i've said that over and over again
in many speeches and the reason why i
say that is because i don't want to see
war here on american soil i have three
children that are young adults and i
never want to see my children
back our freedoms
and i've said that that's why so she's
admitting that there could be a
possibility of violence in the civil war
when you're saying right blood is a
reference to violence isn't it
the price of blood is the unfortunate
and tragic cost of war
and that's what happened in the
revolutionary war and and that's right
there's violence
and you know that
um
the term 1776
is actually a term that's sometimes used
in politics today
i don't know if you've noticed our state
seal here in georgia i know you're not
from georgia but as you can see we we
enjoy our history and we're proud of our
freedoms 1776 is on our state seal right
and it's also a term that's used in
political discourse in america today i
don't use it as a term of violence
but you use it as a term right
i have used it as a term but i do not
use it as a term of violence as you're
trying to push we're not we're not up to
that yet you'll
we've seen multiple takes facebook posts
other things where she
promotes violence things have been
removed
like the phrase political discourse
price of blood is not just yes
and euphemism
or metaphors in fact one of the examples
of 1776 being used in political
discourse today is the t-shirt that mr
dora was hearing in the interview that
we just saw right
we saw 1776 backwards on his t-shirt on
that cut-up video yes
and you understood that t-shirt to me
that people need to possess firearms in
order to oppose a tyrannical government
i don't recall
even
i don't remember seeing his t-shirt that
day when i saw him
the only time i'm paying attention to it
is now because you're drawing the
reference but as you sit here today you
understand that what that t-shirt is
conveying it's a political message
that's like her saying oh i went to the
nick fuentes little meet up and i didn't
know who nick fuentes was
this whole like i don't have a memory of
this happening
i'm just asking whether you have that
understanding it's a republican thing i
know you wouldn't think you're more
trying to push a narrative and push
words in my mouth and i don't agree with
what you're saying
necessarily
as you sit here today representative
greene
you know that that term 1776
has been used in connection with events
of january 6 2001.
i guess it i guess so i don't know well
you yourself have used the term 1776
to describe
the events of january 6
2021.
i don't recall but if you say
let's go to px27 please as well
[Music]
by the way this video
your honor has been admitted into
evidence right
miss wells
uh no it wasn't actually planned but
president trump knows how much i support
him he knows how much i support our
district uh georgia's 14th district and
so i was happy to go up there and
encourage our voters to get out and vote
we can't allow our two democr our two
republican senators lose their seats to
two radical socialist democrats so i was
excited to get up there and also um
cheer on senator kelly lefler for
announcing last night that she'll be
objecting to this fraudulent stolen
election tomorrow she flipped on lafleur
the minute she approved the
certification women uh representing
georgians will be fighting for president
trump and fighting right
and she would still drag her today what
is that
tomorrow how do you plan to handle what
could possibly go down uh in this joint
session of congress tomorrow um are what
are you prepared for
well you know i'll echo the words of uh
many of my colleagues as we were just
meeting together in our gop conference
meeting this morning this is our 1776
moment
um
that's your statement on january 5th
2021 correct
i don't know the date i
again i don't recall but now that i've
seen it what what was the date of the
video
january 5th 2021 because a lot of these
moments i don't recall until evidence is
brought forward you'll see that you're
talking about that tomorrow is the sixth
yes and you use the term 1776
to describe
in response to a question from the
newsmax broadcaster right
i was speaking about objecting
well you he asked you what is your plan
what are you prepared to have go down
tomorrow on january 6th
and your response was
tomorrow is our 1776 moment
we're talking about the courage to
object
and
you said you were echoing the words of
your republican colleagues
was the term 1776 used by your
republican colleagues
i don't recall
that was the video but i don't recall
in fact representative bobert that used
a term 1776 to describe the events
january 6. today is 1776 i believe i
don't recall i have no idea let's go to
px9e please lauren bobert enters the
chat
of course she was why wouldn't you
um you recall seeing
a tweet from representative governor
from colorado
uh at 8 30 in the morning on january 6
2001. today is 1776.
i don't remember seeing this i see it
now
if that's her tweet i've got eyes i've
seen it
that representative used the term 1776
to describe the events of january 6th
she's going to i don't recall myself all
the way through the end all the way back
to px
quote treats retreats likes
video what she said what she didn't say
the whole thing
that's what it said on the screen
newsmax
well you're not denying that no i just
saying i don't even remember the
interview until we've seen it okay
and what kind of representative doesn't
remember any of this what's what's
newsmax what's the newsmax anyways i
don't know what that is
get the [ __ ] out of here with this i
don't remember
yeah line ass [ __ ] she's really
making the case that she's not a
competent representative right she's not
able to recall any of these moments she
isn't on committees i mean so now we
know why she can't even recall
this is our 17
76 moment
you knew that some of the people who
felt that donald trump was the rightful
winner of the 2020 election
used that term to refer to the
possibility of violence
on january 6th 2021
no i never heard anyone talking about
violence for january 6.
absolutely not i've never heard about
anyone using the term 1776 to refer to
the [ __ ] i would never
i don't mean to cut you off no i
apologize yes
you've never heard anybody say
use the term 1776
as a code word
for violence
to occur on january 6 2021. no
absolutely not you're telling me mo
brooks was the only one who got a four
like a a heads up on the violence and
you know that he did have it he did have
a vest on right why would you wear a
bulbar vest he was warned about the
violence he had a written plan
for i think he was told about the qrs
why he was wearing the vest
no i did not know that okay
um the proud boys are an extremist
violent group you would agree with that
i don't know much about the proud boys
you've never heard that they're a
violent extremist group
i've heard about them i don't know what
they do i i don't know much about the
brown boys
i'm sure they're loving to hear that
right now
and you haven't heard that the
written plan
attributed to the proud boys for january
6 was called 1776 returns
no i have no idea anything about that
never heard that okay let's pull up uh
px39
oh i wonder what this is
is this another clip
i don't know i don't know if this is a
tweet or clip but
i mean they're going to bring it up on
the screen i just don't know what format
this is an article that appeared
in the new york times on march 14 2020
entitled document in jan six case shows
planned to storm government buildings
do you see this document
i've never seen it now let me get you a
copy so you can have a
look you need a number
it's uh
mrs green did you see a story
in the new york times or any other
publication or media outlet
in march of 22 2022 about proud boys
having a written plan to storm
government buildings on january 6.
no
i've never i don't recall never heard
anything about it never heard of that
never heard that that was called 1776
returns that plan that the government
alleges proud boys had to storm
government buildings
no i've never heard of it
you were aware of prior to january 6
that 1776
referred to an idea or a plan
for people who were opposed to the
certification of the electoral college
vote
to infiltrate and occupy
buildings in these states no no no no
and you were aware prior to january 6
2021 that 1776 was a term that people
were using to describe a plan or an idea
to physically interfere and prevent the
electoral college though
no i don't know anything about that okay
you can put that to one side we
[Music]
talked a little bit about
a person named ali alexander this
morning you remember that testimony
and you said somebody you've met on a
number of occasions sat there i i've
seen them a couple times i don't
remember when and
it's not someone i know oh
um
i wonder if he's doing one of his online
rants right now
hello knows who i am
uh
all right um
let's just start i'm going to ask you to
have a look at
just the first 10 seconds of the video
it's just a person not even speaking and
tell me if you can identify that person
[Music]
what are we watching here
you know that person
that's ollie alexander yeah okay let's
go thank you let's go to uh
yeah the music threw me off yeah i
didn't
i didn't know if we were like starting a
soap opera or something like we're going
to watch it i don't know around 11
minutes and 20 seconds
for anything go ahead
okay members of congress are on a
committee um congressman steve king was
the only one who was yanked off of all
committees um but so that's not true
um
so avoid the disinformation avoid the
division
we are here to continue pressing forward
yeah congresswoman marjorie uh green
my favorite she's coming in a friend of
mine she's coming in she'll
uh be whatever someone's trying to tell
me why he thinks she's a friend you see
that mr alexander describes you as
his favorite
favorite
right you've heard him say that love
letters he's from ollie alexander
mcfuente said the same thing the
explanation for why do you feel that way
after he said sing hell al hitler
after he said that he said she's my
favorite that well i only met him a
couple of times
he describes himself as
you as a friend of this right
those are his words right that's what he
says
oh this is a meme already it's already a
meme
sometimes people say things on videos
for their followers or to maybe i don't
know
it's hey hey i do not i do not i do not
i do not say things on videos alexander
was very active i'm just in the
post-election i
resemble that remark
isn't that right
i don't know i don't follow his account
oh she doesn't
let's go to how could she she's banned
from all accounts from
following other banned accounts
well i think we've established that
during that post-election period from
the member when you were elected until
january 6th one of the things you were
doing was organizing people in congress
to file objections to the electoral
college council right yes working very
hard on objecting okay let's go to px3
please
people are asking a question here in the
chat um he's right there in the gray
suit is that matt gatt yeah that matt
gates is right there gray suit brown
hair right in the middle right here
uh-huh that's matt gates this is this is
matt getz
disgraced congressman
sitting child sex trafficker from
florida
matt getz an america first nazi just
like marjory taylor green right there in
the front
screen i want to focus your attention on
the box in the middle of the page
that says marjorie marjorie taylor g r e
dot dot dot 12 30 20. you see that yes
and that's a twitter
uh comment that you made on december
30th 2020 right
i don't recall making that tweet
um but that's what this piece of paper
says
do you have any doubt that a tweet from
your account
was issued on december
30th 2020
that said quote word on the hill is that
mitch mcconnell and nancy pelosi could
be working together on a rules change
deal to block our electoral college
certification objection
i don't recall this tweet
my question's a little bit different do
you have any doubt that this is a tweet
from your account i don't know
do you um recall in late december of
2020 hearing uh
rumor on capitol hill about a deal
between mitch mcconnell and nancy pelosi
thank you thank you gabby for the laugh
in the comments thank you for the
electoral college account i can't really
remember
it's been 16 months or so ago that would
be pretty important wouldn't it if they
changed the rules so that you couldn't
object
the electoral college count right
it would have been that there was no
rule change we were still able to object
or at least we tried anyways but by this
point in december of
2020
your focus was on
objecting to the electoral college count
in congress right
yes finding evidence of voter fraud and
planning to object yes
and
if there had been rumors of a
rule change that would be something that
would be important for you to tweet out
and talk about publicly
if it possibly would have been i just
don't remember this tweet
i don't remember it
um you know that ali alexander has
responded to tweets that you've sent out
over the years right
i don't know i don't i don't know what i
have no idea who retweets and who
responds
that's not something that i spend
much time at all there's an old frieze
where i come from
she doesn't know her head from her ass
who responds to yours
occasionally i have some time and i look
at who responds but i do not know
what he has responded what he has
tweeted or retweeted
and and
the reason that you look at
responses to your tweets
is you want to see how
what you said as being
taken on board by other people is that
fair actually i don't really look at
comments on twitter because they're
filled with a lot of bots and a lot of
hateful people and i don't like to
read things like that so i really i
don't read many comments hardly ever
well you read mr alexander's response to
your december 30th tweet that's shown in
the exhibit
right
and and just to read it out loud
what he writes is if they do this
everyone can guess what me and 500 000
others will do to that building
1776
is always an option
you read that didn't you
i'm
he's totally talking about a time
machine i think he's talking about a
time machine
it's got to be words i guess he can't be
talking code where he's got to be saying
that he's going to
you know understand
what that [ __ ] mr alexander was
referring to was not legal objections on
the floor of the congress right
no i don't know what he's referring to
and you knew back then that what mr
alexander was responding to your tweet
was to say
if they make a rules change
and congresswoman
taylor green can't object
we're going to go into the capitol and
do violence
i have no idea i don't know anything
about this
and that term 1776 is the way mr
alexander was conveying that to his
listeners or his readers
i have no idea
again i don't know anything about this
i've never seen it before
between january 3rd and january 6 2021
ms green you viewed the electoral
college certification of joe biden as a
blow to freedom is that fair
i i viewed it as
we needed to object because there was so
much evidence and so many people had
signed their names thousands of people
had signed their names i want to point
out that she's lying right now
right now she's lying to me because i
care about the people and i care about
their votes and i care about our
election integrity
my question is whether you view it as a
blow to freedom
if the electoral college certification
of joe ryden were completed
i don't agree with your wording okay um
i feel like he's only got like twenty
minutes left to go come back by itself
right
i hope he has a crescendo here because
he can get freedom back the only thing
he's done is prove that alexander aldi
alexander you're twisting my words and
creating a narrative that you're trying
to make though that's not my narrative
that's not what i said
well that's not 20 27 2020.
that's what you said and that's what you
meant right
i'm sorry yeah on october 27th 2020 when
you did the interview with mr dore
when you said the only way to get
freedoms back is when it's burned with
blood
that's what you meant right well you
showed a video that's chopped up that
doesn't show
my fl even my full sentences
so no i don't agree with what you're
saying
i feel like she's getting a little cocky
here i don't know if that's gonna
come back to bite her but
i i i think i think kfa i think karen
drake this judge is gonna kick this can
yeah unless he unless the effort
i don't remember this is seeing this
interview is
the first time i've seen it in a long
time i don't remember now prior to
january 6 2021 you spoke publicly on
your facebook page
about the transfer of power that would
occur on january 6th you recall that
i don't recall okay you said on the
video on your facebook page that the
peaceful transfer of power not be
allowed to occur
i don't recall
um you said that the peaceful transfer
of power cannot be allowed to occur
because joe biden didn't win the 2020
election right
i don't recall
let's um go to the video
uh can we start with
here's more tape
um i i do want to say though this
section explains there are two versions
of this
and i'm going to ask about both of them
you can tell me if you think they've
been chopped up in in any way
they are they have been chopped up
that's true
you'll tell me whether you were
misinterpreted okay
the first one is px66
yes can you play that one okay uh just a
second
what what's the date and the source
the source is
it was something this green's facebook
page is not available
this is something that was captured by
someone else and posted on another
facebook page
where it says is from her facebook page
yes it does 66. 66 have been admitted
you're on it
yeah it's been admitted to what it's
worth
i do not recall
we're going to ask your question
i do not recall what facebook is can you
explain facebook in a in a nutshell to
me that would be helpful
and this is an important time in our
history
we can't allow this just to just to be
gone you know just to let it go you
can't allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidences
so
that's you right ms green
yes that's me
and when you say we can't allow it we
can't just let it go
the
it in that phrase is
to have joe biden declare
the winner of the 2020 presidential
election
you are showing a video where it doesn't
give us any reference beforehand and it
doesn't give us any reference afterwards
maybe
maybe she could recall what the
reference is what i was saying
i i don't
we're watching a partial video and a
partial statement of clearly an
interview i was doing
i don't know what date it was on and
it's definitely off someone else's
twitter or facebook i can't see it i
don't know who filmed this video of me
in a selfie mode
ah son of a [ __ ]
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not win this election
that's you saying that right
that's the partial statement
of on that video okay can we pull up
i just want to bring up again
you got a business you didn't build that
i just want to bring that up again i
just want to make sure you said they're
different i want to be sure that she has
an opportunity to see what the
difference can i make a suggestion let's
go back to the beginning of this one i'm
not going to play it all the way through
that'd be good i agree let's do that
oh does he have a full-length video of
this
i'm not sure
let's listen they're going to play the
video again
and this is an important time in our
history
we can't allow this just to just to be
gone you know just to let it go you
can't allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he did not
win the selection it's being stolen and
the evidence is there the mainstream
media for four
years talked about russian collusion
conspiracy theories and lies and
demanded investigations
non-stop
into russian collusion
non-stop but yet they refuse to
and this is an important time in our his
is that where it ended
okay let's let's show uh the witness px
12. you know i don't see yeah that's the
thing that i keep getting is like she's
like oh it's a partial bit it's like not
a complete sentence you said leading up
to that moment like you you can't undo
what you said right right right it's
it's you saying it too
yeah for one second
this video that we just saw which we've
marked as uh
plain 66.
that's a video that you made in
anticipation of objecting to the
electoral college
count in favor of joe biden right i
don't know
it i don't see a date it's not from my
specific facebook page it appears to be
on someone else's
let's see the other it's a video of her
it's a video of her
taken by her right right
who gives a [ __ ]
i believe off of the video on the
facebook page of the client
yeah the other thing is like she's
saying that we can't offer the word
peaceful transfer
you know
it's off the face yeah margie brings up
a good point here off of the republican
accountability project okay so this is a
secondary source yeah it was copied
but
hold on one second and this one
he's gotta have a reason for going
this is a clipped one and it's a full
one
america re-elected donald j trump for
four more years you can't allow it to
just transfer power peacefully like joe
biden wants and allow him to become our
president because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there there's a large
group of us we're organizing an effort
to object to the electoral college votes
for joe biden and key states where
there's real evidence that this election
has been stolen i am very convicted in
what we're going to be doing on january
6th and it's historic and i feel it's
very very important
on january 6 if you're able there are
going to be possibly a million or more
people coming to washington to be there
for this historic event it's critical
for everyone to show up and show the
nation who we are we aren't a people
that's that are going to go quietly into
the night we are not a people that are
going to be thrust into socialism
without stopping it
ted cruz said that very same thing
now that you've seen that on stage that
day
and and
this is this is a statement after she
says peacefully
on january 6th
this video on the democrat leftist pac
republican accountability group that
looks to be chopped up and spliced that
video that's not my full video
that's not me on the video
the words that are shown
that you're speaking on the street
those are things that you were talking
about in anticipation of objecting to
the electoral college i can't tell if
the judge is buying the whole clipped up
thing or he's getting frustrated
but again that's a cut and sliced video
and when you said we're organizing an
effort to object to the college uh
electoral college votes
on video though we
were members of congress right
well members of congress are the only
ones that can object that's that's part
of our ability
that's what we're allowed to do lawfully
right
exactly and making objections
is in fact
peacefully peacefully is part of the
lawful transfer of power
right
objecting is part of the electoral uh
count process democrats did it with the
past three republican presidents that
were elected right they did it
i'm sure there was a lot of planning
that went into that yes not planning for
insurrection
a lot of work into it um and as you can
see we talked about objection so when
you were talking about
we can't allow it to happen
you can't just let it go
you can't allow it to transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president
because he didn't win
you weren't talking about
objections on the floor of the congress
for you
is we can't uh allow the electoral
account to happen without objecting that
i felt it was our dutiful responsibility
to object on behalf of the uh large
amount of voter fraud and the people who
truly felt like that there was big
problems in our elections
and
you test you're testifying under oath
that that's what you meant when you said
you can't allow it to transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants and
allow him to become our president that
was a reference to
without objecting without objecting
of course you don't say anything in that
part of the video about
objections on the floor of the congress
right
would you like to see it again i believe
the video i said uh objecting but in the
sentence where you said you can't allow
it to transfer power
like joe biden wants and allowed him to
become our president because he didn't
win the election
you don't say anything in that sentence
about
objections on the floor of the congress
sir we just saw two videos that are cut
and clipped and they don't my sentences
aren't even completed
with me saying and
meaning it was starting into
partially something i was already saying
what i was uh from the video and my
recollection from watching him just then
it was purely talking about objecting
one of the things that you say in these
videos is that you call upon people to
come to washington on january
i don't did i and i i don't remember
every single word that we just watched
let's let's look at it again i think p
p12 is the one that includes that
have you been watching is matt gatz live
tweeting this
does anyone like me as everyone knows
donald j trump for four more years you
can't allow it to just transfer power
peacefully like joe biden wants that
seems like a full sentence to me
when this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there there's a large
group of us we're organizing an effort
to that's right here the electoral
college votes for joe biden in key
states where there's real evidence that
this election has been stolen i am very
convicted in what we're going to be
doing on january 6th and it's historic
and i feel it's very very important
on january 6 if you're able there are
going to be possibly a million or more
people coming to washington to be there
for this historic event it's critical
for everyone to show up and show
[Music]
so in that segment representative green
you're asking people to come to
washington on january 6th
in this video which i saw jump three
times which means it's been cut and
spliced
yes i did talk about people coming there
to support our objection peacefully
support our objection
support president yeah you also said you
also said don't you know that there
might be can't let it be a peaceful
transfer of power
did you just make that up or let me tell
you that i believe those were the
numbers being talked about at the time
by who
uh the media
and just different
i have no idea i think i saw that on the
news
um and what you said is it's critical
for everyone to show up right that's
what we saw
supporting yeah peacefully supporting
our objection that's the only thing i
was thinking do you get the sense that
marjorie taylor green just isn't trying
to remain on the ballot she's also not
trying to self-incriminate herself
yeah
yeah i get that sense yes
now that phrase we aren't the people
that are gonna go quietly into the night
that's not something that you came up
with on your own is it
i have no idea what you mean well that's
something that you borrowed from a movie
script right
i don't know what you're talking about
you bothered that line give me a [ __ ]
break
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
what a lion tag
maybe maybe she did steal it from ted
cruz not from the movies
are they are they going to show the
independence day clip you've seen the
movie independence day you know what
they're doing you've seen it before
i i think it's probably a great movie i
haven't watched movies in a long time
but from what i remember it's a great
movie she's too busy reading her bible
and planning violent insurrections
she's like
independence day 1776
right
you are giving us quite the
entertainment today thank you okay
and there's a scene in that movie where
the president the guy who's playing the
president united states addresses the
fighter pilots who are about to go into
battle against the aliens remember that
scene literally the republican party is
so far down a q anon rabbit hole
that in a hearing where they are
questioning whether one of their
representatives is on a ballot they have
to play clips from movies that these
people think they're in
right that's how that is the
significance of this is these people
think they're in these movies so they
have to play the clips
to exist
and should we win the day
the 4th of july will no longer be known
as an american holiday
but as the day when the world declared
in one voice we will not go quietly into
the night
we will not finish we're not a fight
we're going to live for [ __ ] sake
we're going to survive
this does not give me hope
that we're sitting here listening to
independence day as a script
so she can recall words from a very
famous movie and
this is uh quite there is quite the
hearing
lord
heard it just now yes and that's the
exact phrase that you use
in the video that we saw
that was
a previous exhibit
we aren't the people that are going to
go quietly into the game
i don't view courtrooms in politics
since hollywood like you do that is not
the first person i'm sure that said that
and won't be the last and i don't
recall getting anything
though from this hollywood movie
like you're suggesting so you you were
not communicating
and referencing that film
that
january 6 was going to be a new kind of
independence day
all i was talking about is objecting
this is really [ __ ] stupid what a
dumb idea to play this clip really it's
really dumb independence day is
july 4th right
yes
it's july 4th of 1776.
that's right
i'm not saying this sounds like
conspiracy theorist connections but
like
i get what he's trying to say
it's just a bit it's a really dumb point
though it's really [ __ ] stupid it
doesn't help his case
left but [ __ ] you
i don't need a break
let's keep going right
i mean again i mean if we're talking you
know 30 minutes we're talking two hours
yeah no i don't think that's two hours
uh the screen did you advocate yeah
we're already at five hours here at our
show this special edition of the tony
michaels podcast and any new listeners
out there i don't remember we are on
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central youtube
twitter twitch january 6th normally two
hours today we're five strong so far yes
i'm very unhappy about it
now
we talked earlier about
um a fellow named anthony aguero
right
you brought up anthony aguero earlier
yes and he's somebody who you know yes
yes he's somebody who you've spent a
fair amount of time with is that fair
um not much time no he's a friend of
yours someone that i do know yes and you
consider him a friend someone i hardly
ever talk to but someone i have known
for a few years
and he is a friend of yours right
a distant friend someone i know he
refers to you as one of his closest
friends you've heard that right
and i have not okay
um
and you refer to him as amazing right
he does a lot of great work down at the
border showing the illegal invasion
constantly happening in our southern
border i think that's amazing the
footage that he shows and exposes okay
and you know that mr aguero
um entered the capitol
on the u.s capitol on january 6 2001
right i had heard that some time after
january 6th and you've seen a picture of
him
in the middle of the crowd in the
capital rotunda on january 6 2012. no i
have not seen that picture let's have a
look at px
13 v please
[Music]
make that a little bit bigger
representative green is that man in the
red circle on the left of our exhibit
13b is that mr aguero
i don't know i can't really tell
um if i told you that it was reported
that that was mr aguero and that he
acknowledged that publicly
that helped you discern the best that is
i
i don't really buy a whole lot of what
you say you've been using cnn and mother
jones and other
terrible sources as your sources and
showing hollywood movies so but that's
what you're trying to say now but i i
don't know if that's him or not i'm just
asking whether if i suggested to you
that he's acknowledged publicly that
that's him in the capital rotunda would
that help you identify him as your
friend mr aguero
i don't see your evidence of him
acknowledging that that's him
okay
i think we can probably do something
with that
uh can i see 13 please
so
i showed you something from cnn you
probably wouldn't accept it as authentic
would you
i think we've established that today
we'll move on
um
have you spoken to mr aguero
since january 6
i don't recall speaking to him now or
communicate with him in any way text
email
here you go
and um
did you communicate with mr aguero at
any point prior to january 6th
about
the plans for a demonstration in
washington on january
no i didn't now
did he have press credentials i know i
mean there was a lot of press in there
and that's the job i think this is a
perjury trap being said
media company that he he works with so i
i have no idea about what i have no clue
about it okay were you aware that he was
going to be
in his capacity i guess as a member of
the press
present on january 6th in washington for
the demonstrations that were planned no
i was not aware um did he communicate
with any member of your staff in any way
like text or email
cell phone
about the fact that he'd be coming to
washington not to my knowledge now
did you ever discuss with mr aguero
um the idea that
on january 6
as part of the demonstration the u.s
capitol was going to be flooded by
people
no
because the only thing i was working on
objecting and had no expectation of
anything that happened on january 6.
well you knew there were going to be
demonstrations right
i knew there was a peaceful march
planned
on january 6th itself were you in
contact with anyone
who was involved in what you described
as the peaceful march that occurred that
day
no
with anybody from your staff
congressional staff or your campaign
staff
in touch by cell phone text
email
with anybody who was involved in today's
demonstrations
not of my knowledge
at any time on january 6 did you
disclose to anyone
uh outside the capitol
your location in the capitol
during that day's events
i texted my family and told them i was
safe
anybody other than family
no on her non-burner phone
[Laughter]
on her non-burner phone she takes her
family
[Music]
i just want to make you forgot to add
that when january 6 did you first
learn that people were entering the
united states capital unlawfully that
day
when we were in the house chamber uh
we were starting the electoral account
and we went on lockdown and and that's
when i first learned of it i was shocked
and you know what time of day
i don't know the exact time
and
when you went on lockdown as you
described it why don't you tell us what
that meant
what you mean by that they had to lock
all the doors in the house chamber and
they told us that
that it was on lockdown is she gonna cry
that we could choose to leave is she
gonna do a ridden house like kyle
rittenhouse
and so i stayed inside
when she's describing and when you say
you stayed inside where did you stay
inside the house chamber
and during that time that you were on
the
in lockdown as you put it on the house
floor um you said you were in touch with
your family to tell them you were safe
not at that time now
when did that happen in the day sometime
later after we were evacuated
where were you evacuated
i
i can't disclose that location
somewhere in the capital
and
when you were in that other location in
the capitol i presume that would be a
secure location is that right
yes
um did you have any communication either
by phone
uh by text some other way
um with anybody who was outside the room
outside the secure location you were in
other than your family not that i recall
now
not that she recalls
that means
yes
when you
were notified
that people had entered the capitol
illegally did you also understand that
point that there had been violence at
the capitol
i only knew what i was told i'd heard
i'd heard a gunshot we all heard it
and um we were so confused we thought
antifa was breaking in or blm because
it's good those were the riots
on and on all throughout 2020 they were
so violent they were so violent
but it wasn't actually in tv and blm it
ended up being trump supporters
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
you racist [ __ ]
is that an acronym for something
black lives matter rioters
that rioters that uh were attending the
black lives matter protest
um
she recalls everything else but she
knows exactly who is right exactly
well she knows in that moment who she
felt like who was writing after the
gunshot went on charge in connection
with the january 6th but she can't
recall who she called
and i don't recall if i called anybody i
know they were arrested all over the
country much through 2020 and over 95 of
them had their charges dropped unlike
january 6 rioters
that are still in jail
some of them
pre-trial
um i have a few moments to consult and
then i think i may be done sure just
yeah we don't do we don't need a break
do we
okay it sounds like they're gonna
take a break here
um i'm gonna mute this for a second and
while we're watching um so
basically
is this
she's still on a hot mic
okay they're just bantering back and
forth the judge she's giving her a big
smile to the judge that way in case he
decides to rule the way in her favor i
really thought she was gonna do a kyle
rittenhouse there for a second when she
started to describe the event i don't
know if she's capable of that but you
know you know what i mean i i thought
she's gonna totally yeah
i can't remember
i can't recall i mean really this is
[ __ ] ridiculous like you said she can
remember the exact moment the gunshot
went off and exactly how she felt and
who she thought that this was of course
her racist bigoted mind goes to blam and
antique of course they knew it wasn't
[ __ ] antivirus they knew it wasn't
they knew it wasn't the reason why those
congress people were taken to secure
locations is because the trump
supporters had marched down from the
trump rally from the nazi rally
happening down the street to the capitol
to overthrow the constitution of the
united states they knew this that's why
mo brooks had a [ __ ]
bulletproof vest on because there was a
qrf across the potomac that the oat
keepers were controlling and they were
waiting for orders to pull that qrf
across the potomac they were hoping
antifa and black lives matter were going
to be there they were really [ __ ]
hoping and the reason they were hoping
to dance together
exactly that's right they would pull the
qrf in
donald trump would com would declare
martial law and the oath keepers could
start arresting democratic members of
congress which would allow the
republican members to con convene and to
turn down the certification of the vote
our vote for joe biden overturning the
constitution making donald trump the
dictator of our country and [ __ ]
[ __ ] on hundreds of years of our
democracy and undoing it all in a moment
in just one [ __ ] moment that was
their [ __ ] plan people that was the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup that eastman
laid out oh well we were trying to stall
you were trying to stall to create
violence so you could overthrow the
constitution this nonsense about this
objection where she keeps going on and
on and on about oh well we were protest
we weren't protesting we were objecting
it wasn't a violent insurrection we were
objecting that's all [ __ ] and that's
how you know this this nonsense about
how they were just trying to stall so
that way they could recertify the vote
that's all
[ __ ] nonsense they wanted to have
those those
the the
shadow select a slate of electors from
these states ready to go when those
democratic members were [ __ ] arrested
when the qrf was initiated by whoever
was supposed to give that order to
stewart rhodes and the oath keepers get
your head out of your [ __ ] asses all
this evidence exists and if you don't if
you think i'm some crazy kook just
saying this [ __ ] there's an oath keeper
who is pled guilty to seditious
conspiracy there is a and that oath
keeper was standing next to roger
[ __ ] stone who had a direct line to
the people who would give that order for
that qrf
that mo brooks was wearing a goddamn uh
uh bulletproof vest because he was
scared he was gonna be caught in the
crosstalk fire he was warned before
january 6 that there was a likelihood
for you know the potential that
something could you know get out of hand
you don't just wear a bulletproof vest
to wear a bulb or vest you're up there
giving your speech rallying tell them to
go kick ass and you've got a vest on
because somebody says
oh hey uh things might get a little uh
confrontational so it's best if you have
protection
i i do not i do not see how mo brooks
was the only person on january 6 or
before january 6 that was given a heads
up about this about the potential of
violence right like
everyone else either took it
and then said ah whatever or took it
seriously and then protected himself mo
brooks is just the only person that we
know wore a bulletproof vest right
because he was wearing it out in the
open well the other thing too everyone's
asking what a qrf is the qrf in basic
terms is a stockpile of weapons that
they were storing across the potomac the
reason why they were storing it across
the potomac is because across the
potomac is the state of virginia not
washington d.c washington d.c they
weren't allowed to legally have that qrf
in washington d.c and if they were found
out that they had that qrf stewart
rhodes and the oath keepers and the
people harboring that qrf those that
ammunition and those weapons would have
been given federal
firearms charges that's why they didn't
do that that's why you haven't seen
stuart rhodes with that with the charge
of that qrf because he stored that qrf
in a place where it was legal to store
it now rather that plays into the
conspiracy of sedition i i bet it is and
i bet it will guaranteed in the trial of
stewart rhodes and the other oath
keepers especially when that oath keeper
who was protecting roger stone who was
tasked with protecting roger stone on
january 6 when they when they tuck
tailed and run on the proud boys
protection and i believe it's because i
believe personally the reason why they
switched the protection of proud boys to
the oath keepers is because the oath
keepers had the order for the qrf that
is the reason why and because roger
stone was the direct line to the oath
keepers and two stuart roads to whoever
was supposed to give the order of when
martial law was in order and was enacted
so they could pull that qrf across the
river legally and and be deputized by
whoever was in charge of the martial law
i.e donald trump
and to start arresting members of
congress the democratic members of
congress who would have voted to certify
that is the whole [ __ ] point
and and and now that we have this
evidence laid out before us and guys let
me tell you the department of justice
has all this all this they have all this
and honestly the the judge carter
decision out in california lays a road
map for the doj and i don't know if
judge carter purposely relayed that road
map for
the doj or if it just is happenstance in
his decision to make sure that the
public knows in his decision that the
emails that john eastman and donald
trump were exchanging was not under
attorney client privilege they were
committing crimes they were trying to
obstruct
a official proceeding that is the
criminal charge that that judge is
saying that is clearly committed that's
why he's not affording them
attorney-client privilege and it is
insignificant in that the proud boy who
who has pled guilty has pled guilty to
the charge of a conspiracy to obstruct a
official proceeding that is super
important and i i know that it doesn't
feel like we're there yet but i'm
telling you all the signs are leading to
you can hear liz cheney say it when
she's making public statements and the
select committee when they're making
public statements that this this
investigation into members of congress
into the proud boys the oath keepers
roger stone alex jones uh
rudy giuliani donald trump himself and
his family is much further along than we
could ever dream of and if you don't
believe me
show me the evidence of how stewart
rhodes and the oath keepers knew that
they were going to be arrested and
indicted show me the evidence where
enrique tario knew that he was going to
be arrested and be charged with the
crimes that he committed on january 6
when he wasn't even at the capitol that
is what is important folks that's what's
super important here and i believe that
this hearing as much as it's not going
to produce the result that marjorie
taylor green is going to be cast off the
ballot wait wait stop stop stop stop go
unmuted i'm muted i'm muted with that
i'm going to return to the subject yes
ask her if she recalls that she posted
this to her facebook page if she does
and we're done and then
i'm going to go over that okay all right
we'll do that
so it sounds like the judge and the
lawyers are conferencing of course now
she knows exactly what they're going to
do right
okay yeah that's
that was a good call to keep that on the
hot mic
not
sorry
thank yeah for your patience
representative greene your honor um
in the previous discussion i had asked
about
um what we've marked as plants exhibit
27
which is the newsmax what people call
that we showed you remember that right
the one we've already watched
and i asked you whether you recall
that you posted that newsmax
clip on your facebook page
i don't recall what was posted on my
facebook page i don't make all of my
facebook posts fair enough
let's let's um
explain what this is yeah i'd like to
i'd like to show you this this is a
live version of your
congressional campaign facebook page
as it sits there today
and what we have is the clip that we had
separated
in the previous testimony and i'd like
to play that for you
just to
see if you will acknowledge oh oh it is
now available on your facebook oh man
[ __ ] undoctored on her own facebook page
right
it's live they're going to play it live
from the page it wasn't actually planned
but president trump knows how much i
support him he knows how much i support
our district georgia's 14th district and
so i was happy to go up there and
encourage our voters to get out and vote
we can't allow our two democ our two
republican senators lose their seats to
do radical socialist democrats so i was
excited to get up there and also um
cheer on senator kelly lefler for
announcing last night that she'll be
objecting to this fraudulent stolen
election tomorrow on january 6th and i'm
very excited that uh both of us women
are representing georgians will be
fighting for president trump kelly
laupler just for reference actually
what is your plan tomorrow how do you
plan to handle what could possibly go
down uh in this joint session here we go
bruce tomorrow
are what are you prepared for
well you know i'll echo the words of uh
many of my colleagues as we were just
meeting together in our gop conference
meeting this morning this is our
1776 moment
it's green that's up on your facebook
page today right
if it's if that's there then yes it's on
there right and that's been posted since
january 5th 2021 correct
uh i don't i didn't post it but if
that's when it was posted then that's
when it was posted and things that are
posted on your facebook page are posted
with your authorization and permission
right i do not view things that are
posted before they're posted
posted on your page that's something
that you authorized and permitted
whether you viewed it in advance or not
uh
i i think if i'm authorizing i would
view it in advance before it's posted
well no one no no one put that up on
your facebook page without
authorization from you its own sense
right
i don't recall authorizing but you have
to understand as a member of congress we
have staff and many people that post
interviews and so forth somebody's
getting fired
[Music]
what's the message january 5th 2021
that's a comment that you posted on your
own facebook page
this is our 1776
right
that is my campaign
facebook page right
and that was posted up as it says on
january 5th 2021.
that's what it says okay
um ask about a couple of other things um
prior to the inauguration
uh in 2021
did you advocate for martial law
um with the president of the united
states uh what what did i say what'd i
say before we came on i don't recall
um you know president trump right yes
he's um i groped his cardboard body
yes and
obviously a very important person
in general right yes
45th president of the united states i
consider that very important right
yes now he's the janitor at mar-a-lago
the election 2020 and
january 20th
of 2021 right
yes
and in those meetings you discussed with
him your advocacy for the idea that
there should be martial law declared in
the united states no i don't recall ever
discussing that are you saying it didn't
happen or you're saying you know oh one
more thing i don't recall ever
discussing that
did you discuss that topic
the idea that there should be martial
law
declared in the united states
prior to the inauguration of president
biden your honor i'm going to have to
which i actually represent president of
the united states and that's covered by
executive privilege she can't get into
this conversation executive crystal
she's not a member of the executive and
this council is here on her behalf not
on mr trump's behalf unless there's
something i miss
wait wait wait wait hold on i didn't
know a lawyer was there from trump that
was sorry i got flushed what was the
question again the question was
whether
um prior to the inauguration of joe
biden
ms green whether you ever advocated
for martial law to be imposed in a
conversation with the chief staff of
then president united states mr trump
you can answer the question
i don't recall
did you ever advocate for martial law
prior to the inauguration of mr biden
any member of the white house staff that
was part of the trump administration i
don't recall
are you aware of any other
congressional elected congressional
representatives advocating for martial
law
to stop the peaceful transfer of power
before the inauguration was divided
i don't remember
um
do you regard the people who were
arrested
and charged in connection with the
january sixth events as patriots
i
i don't
i don't think them being arrested and
charged on january 6
affects the fact that they're
patriots or not right so you do them as
patriots yeah some of them are veterans
yes some of them definitely are patriots
okay
and we have um px60
what do we got here
[Music]
he's starting to make some sense now
you know we're getting away from the
independence day clip and it's starting
to make more sense with like the actual
insurrection
if he somehow pulls us around like he
was doing some like pool game hustle
jedi mind trick type [ __ ] i will with
the clip yeah yeah i totally doubted him
when he pulled out the independence day
[ __ ]
he was like no really i'm gonna i'm
gonna show a movie here and this is
gonna
this is going to give the judge a reason
why to take her off a ballot because of
a clip from a movie that was [ __ ]
ridiculous
yeah that was i mean it really is it's
dumb
this green has placed in front of you
while we've marked this uh petitioner's
exhibit 60 which is historically during
the washington post
on january 5th 2012 big news fake news
that's what she's got story in the
washington post
i don't think i've read this one
um you recall hearing that
i bet sarah palin has read it
she reads everything she reads
that
but you couldn't name it there were
concerns that there were going to be
shame it's going to be violence in
washington on january 6.
i i had not heard that i heard no
threats of violence that i remember at
all for january 6. so full of [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i i heard threats of i i heard him i
heard him
i heard him they were typing them in my
comments come on
the screen i placed before you a january
5th 2021 article
entitled violent threats ripple through
far-right internet forms ahead of
protest
um
this is a article that appeared in nbc
news on the 5th
do you recall
reading
that nbc was reporting that there were
violent threats
that were expected to occur on january
6th that they reported that on the 5th
of january sir we were really busy just
preparing to object on the 6th i don't
recall that news report
have you read this news report before
not until you've placed it in my hand
okay probably didn't have much time to
read it yeah um let me consult for one
minute
one last thing
um
you told us earlier in the day that you
were suspended from your twitter account
or permanently taken off twitter is that
right permanently banned
um you're not banned from facebook
though right
yeah
we saw your stop banned from twitter
either god damn it you pulled that out
yes you did
and
on your facebook page
you have
directed that certain videos be removed
from the facebook page right i
don't recall one of the videos that you
have removed was the one from february
of 2019
where it talked about a sea of people
and
flooding the capital
and violence in the capital in
connection with from the wall matter
right
i don't know what you're referring to
you had your staff take that one down
didn't you i don't refer i don't know
what you're referring to they facebook
never order you to take any video off
your facebook page did they
i don't recall
i have nothing further on
do you want to proceed
you need a break
yeah she's like i'll do my 11 hours in
one minute right
i do not recall i do not recall i do
never agree i'm going to take you back
to january
[Music]
you've already testified that
um
that you are unlocked down in the
uh house chamber
and uh
i'm sorry i just named this dog to speak
up a little bit oh you need to speak i'm
sorry
thank you
you've already testified that you were
on lockdown in the house chambers
yes
and
[Music]
did you have an opportunity to do a
video
yes
and a tweet accompanying that video yes
and about what time did that occur on
january 6
i believe it was around 2 30
in the afternoon
and where were you when the video was
when you took the video
i was inside the house she recalls the
[ __ ] out of this and i mean recalls the
[ __ ] out of this you notice there had
been some violence
outside the capitol and someone had been
shot
and there uh was
just people only told there were people
inside the capitol
and i got very concerned because at that
time i was confused
i mean she's recalling the [ __ ] out of
stuff now
violent before it's almost as if
something happened
and i went inside the cloak room uh
inside the house chamber in the
republican cloakroom
uh into one of the phone booths where
you can go to make a phone call or
anything i went inside there and i made
a video uh
telling people uh to be peaceful not to
be violent uh she remembers the words of
the video
and i tweeted that the show remembers
the words of this video from the
republican club
did you know at that time who was
attacking the capitol no i didn't know
there were there was people were saying
different things we mostly thought that
it was antifa dressed up as trump
supporters that was the first thing we
were told
uh we had no idea i was in the club room
couldn't see the news
i just knew that we were on lockdown and
and they said by that point they said
you cannot leave you have to stay in
here i just want to know what pair of
shoes was she wearing do they look like
the shoes that the fbi are looking for i
just was just wondering tweet
and i don't know
i think we just have the video on uh
electronically
this this has already been made yeah
right
is this your tweet is this your face
yes
did you say in this tweet
a message from me
be safe
be smart
be peaceful
obey the law
this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump and support election integrity
god bless
yes
will you show the video please
r1
deputy dog needs to really lean into the
microphone
lean in son
dominic
sorry i don't
of course
everybody's here
i think that's the universal rule of
life
[Music]
i mean i have
this may be it
i have
that's it
is that it
i mean
i guess it's like it's been in my
custody
i don't know where he is
and you do not want to be touching the
computer
i can assure you
right
okay
so
[Music]
okay for anyone listening out there
um
why why we have this
technical break here
i think this is
actually on tv
we'll take five minutes i mean you know
people are not going to leave and come
back in five minutes it's going to take
a minute to set it up sorry
i
they're trying to set up i don't know
what the hell is going on they had it
all set up before so i don't know if
they didn't have their evidence set up
or not but as you as you've seen uh when
[Music]
marjorie taylor green's attorney came up
to start questioning her her [ __ ]
memory just bam there it was like she
[ __ ] that memory out like quicker so
easily she was like i was in the
cloakroom i did this i did that she was
able to recall the most the whole
goddamn thing my like minor minor in her
small details but everything else she
was like oh listen there's a guy i may
have met that guy i don't know
i shake a lot of hands i don't know
whose hands i'm shaking but i shake a
lot of hands right and then she'd be
like oh i was actually shaking this one
guy's hand in the cloakroom you know
fearing for my life
no uh this
this type of [ __ ] of the her memory
just came back so so quickly right i
mean it was fast like it and almost
seemed like it almost seemed like to me
like she was lying her [ __ ] ass off
when she said i do not recall i do not
girl it almost felt like she's lying her
hands off that hole it's almost like she
didn't want to commit perjury right the
questions that might incriminate her
right when the department of justice
gets a hold of her because that's
important here that's important and i
don't know let's go back to the sound
scene
it still seems like they're uh it still
seems like they're getting set up here
um so we've been streaming for almost
six hours straight folks and i think
we're going to keep streaming this video
um
live
me and gabe are going to take a quick
break um ourselves and then i'll
probably come back now because this
episode is so long
i'm probably it's probably gonna not
actually appear on the audio
uh directories until sometime this
weekend once we get a chance to cut out
parts um to try to narrow this down
because it is a six long hour special
episode but we will let it live on
youtube forever and ever and ever amen
as long as
you know we don't recall where it's at
yeah there's there's matt guetz is he
speaking
is he speaking can we
on a hot mic
there's there's their uh their
republicans local child sex trafficker
accused
um
child sex trafficker he's not indicted
yet yet
just accused
who's the guy who's the guy sitting next
to him
i don't know maybe indeed do you think
he's there as a political buddy or is
this another kind of buddy i don't know
a lot of people are assuming that um
matt gatz is kind of a
not just an america first
uh tour partners that's it i will say
this that's a you know that's a decent
trip
down from dc or you know or if he was
from
up in florida i don't know but i mean
like to make a trip to another state to
go sit
and we've been here for six hours right
right i mean he matt gatz could have
totally watched our feed the entire time
that's all i'm saying
he could have totally watched our feed
he didn't have to drive all the way down
there
and did you guys notice i don't know if
you noticed this um but at one point
during the questioning
from the other attorney the one that she
can't recall anything he says are any
questions that he asked um
trump's attorney spoke up at one point
about it yeah somebody said that we
missed that but we we called it out the
one question i had was
we don't know who the attorney was right
right from trump's council we're not
sure which person sitting here is the
one that's trump's counsel now the other
the other thing too that is significant
is before we got into before the hot
mike situation of the judge and the two
attorneys a meeting at the judge stand
um i was talking about uh martial law
being declared let's make sure
you talk you know
all right the magic box oh jesus christ
he's going a computer here's hunter by
hunter biden's magic box oh my god are
you [ __ ] kidding me so anyways
anyways the significance of what that
questioning was was to
probe into the idea that someone was
supposed to declare martial law and the
only person that really would declare
martial law in washington dc is the
president of the united states
um and that was
what the argument that i was trying to
make um
when when we before we came back the
last time
is that we have evidence out in the open
public we have indictments and we
also we also have plea deals that are
out in the open public in federal court
that show us the roadmap to martial law
like it's it's clear cut with the qrf
which for those of you who don't know
the qrf was weapons that were being
stored across the potomac
um in virginia
because it's legal to have weapons there
instead of washington dc and they were
waiting for orders
um
stewart rhodes specifically the founder
of the oath keepers was waiting for
orders
that day for the qrf to come back that's
why she brought up back black lives
matter in antifa because they wanted him
to be there to create chaos so that
donald trump could declare martial law
and that way the oath keepers could step
in be deputized
and to continue
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup and
overthrow our vote in our constitution
that's the purpose that's why he was
asking her about martial law and someone
asked in the comments and actually a
couple of people asked
do
did we think
that they were asking these questions to
try to set a perjury trap as you would
call it um in court
for the department of justice if there's
any investigation going on there for
marjorie taylor greene which i don't
know if it's an intentional perjury trap
or not
but i do think that it is a very very
very significant piece of evidence that
the department of justice will want to
break down each one of these questions
because not only is she just saying this
out loud she is saying this
under oath which is super important
super important
tai here is uh laughing when i say
cheeto dust kangaroo coo
uh yes the that's the insurrection the
cheeto dust kangaroo coo um so
look look judge magic box is here again
let's see what if we
they still don't have the magic box
figured out
um
this is kind of like gabe trying to
figure out how to use his microphone
you know it's because i'm in the green
room and i want to be yeah yeah yeah
polite and not right not make noise
while you're still on the air before i
come in right right right you mean when
i push the button for you to come in you
don't want to be yeah yeah inadvertently
like you know farting or something like
that right
yeah you know any weird noises okay well
it looks like they finally got their
magic box to work
i can't believe that's a sentence i said
today and uh during this hearing they
got their magic box to work
oh lord
oh
look at that resume playback we have
been watching this for a long time
because now it's wanting me to go ahead
and resume playback
um we've been at this for six hours as
soon as they start here me and gabe are
gonna uh take a quick break we're gonna
continue to play the
the hearing we just won't be here for
commentary for a bit
and then we will we will come back now
so i'm kind of glad this uh this
broadcast did this that way i can um
be assured that it did this then see you
and protected and and let's do this in a
peaceful manner this is this is not a
time for violence this is a time to
support president trump support our
election integrity and support this
important process that we're going
through in congress um where we're
allowed to object uh so this is this is
very important so i urge you to stay
calm um be the great american people
that that i know you are and just know
that we're we're in here fighting for
you so god bless everyone be careful be
safe and and be smart and and obey the
laws thank you very much
representative
yes
uh
as i look at your face
and hear your voice
i think you're scared objection this is
this is not for mr bob to testify about
his feelings
what was your feelings at the time
i i was scared
i was very scared i was like i got way
more way more violent than i thought i
still have the feeling that she's gonna
kyle rittenhouse on us here he said
we're going to fight
it was all about objecting
and to me that was the most important
process of the day
and i
i
had no idea what was going on and i just
didn't want anyone to get hurt i didn't
want to
see anything terrible happen um
and it was it was very upsetting i was
very very upset when i made that video
and you've been on the stand for several
hours here during direct examination
and they showed you multiple tweets
and multiple videos
did they show you that video
no they didn't they didn't show that one
or or all the other
social media posts that has have been
made on my account that i have made
um or videos i have made where i've
always denounced violence and all the
videos i've said and speeches i've said
of how upset i was
about the riot on january 6 and how much
i didn't like it and how much i was
against it
and even when i went and visited the
january 6th defendants pre-trial
defendants in the d.c jail and i went
there
to see their conditions because we had
heard horrible things about their
treatment i know what this is relevant
to i object
the fact that it's not relevant
so i sustained yes
cutting you off was going beyond the
question thank you
now let me show you what's been admitted
bizarre before
so this is a transcript of the video
that's been admitted into evidence
and i want you to turn to page two
and use did you say these words
so i urge you to remain calm i urge you
to have a peaceful protest
make sure everyone is safe and protected
and let's do this in a peaceful manner
this is this is not a time for violence
this is a time to support president
trump support our election integrity and
support our important process that we're
going through in congress
where we're allowed to object
so this is this is very important so i
urge you to stay calm
be the great american people that i know
you are
and just know
that we're we're in here fighting for
you
so god bless be careful be safe and be
smart and obey the law thank you
yes
i think there's a subsequent
tweet
that you did
referring to the violence that occurred
on
january 6th and it's p
1 p
and i am actually not certain whether
that has been admitted
i think
so
[Music]
so representative green did you
i don't remember but i see it's my
mt green
twitter account
so it it went up from your twitter
account that you don't know if you did
it or another member of your staff or
another person
i can't recall exactly but i think i
tweeted this one
now
this says and this is what the date is
january 12th is that correct
yes yes
history says i proudly stand with
representative
and everything in his statement which
you link to later on
the unhinged left is out of control and
they're disgusting witch hunt
is full of hypocrisy
democrats are on record for support of
violence all year
we did not plan
cause
and denounced
and that's capital letters
denounce the january 6th attack
i defend my honor
and reputation
so was that the message sent out on your
twitter account
yes it's the same message i've said over
and over again about january 6.
now
representative excuse me
fbi director christopher wray
testified before congress
that soon after the attack it was before
the senate on march 2 2021
and this is r5
which has been admitted to evidence
i don't
thank you
now when he testified before congress uh
on march 2nd of course you'll remember
congress right
yes
and he said
i was appalled like you
at the violence and destruction that we
saw that day he's referring to january 6
yes
i
i was appalled that you
is justifying before congress looking at
members of congress
our country's elected leaders
were victimized
right there
in these very halls
were you evicted by the attack
yes i was i was in the house chamber
when it happened
i had to be evacuated to safety we were
held for hours and a
secret location
protected by
capitol police military members
uh for hours until they cleared the
capitol yes i was a victim of the riot
that day
no further questions
your honor i believe the testimony has
opened the door on
the issue of
text messages that representative greene
sent
on january 6th during the insurrection
and we would call for their immediate
production and the ability to have a
moment to look at them so we can examine
her on them i thought she i thought the
testimony was she did not send any other
message no she's testified that she sent
messages to her children and her family
those were text messages
those were not tweets we did not talk
about any text messages
that was the controversy over the
admission of the text message images
which we have not referred to right at
all
except that representative green
referred to it when i asked her if she
was in touch with anybody
uh from the from uh that day from the
floor and she said she texted her pamela
you can't open the door hold on hold on
oh my god
do you have any questions other than
this
and i'm going to preserve that position
but i understand we're going to take a
break um
it's been a little chaotic for the last
few
you mentioned a number of uh
statements that you made after january 6
where you talked about being upset about
the fact that there was violence right
yes can you point to one
press release
or tweet or comment on facebook
prior to january 6th where you use the
word
peacefully and in terms of urging people
to behave peacefully at the
demonstrations that were expected to
occur
i would have to look all through my
social media but i'm sure that it's
there i've and i've always denounced
violence i denounced those
antifa blm riots all over the country
over and over just like i denounced the
january 6 riot over and over even even
to the people in jail i told them that
it was wrong i told them in the dc jail
i did not like what they did but that
i'm there because i support their due
process rights which is being violated
um can you point to one video prior to
january 6 where you urge people to
behave peacefully on january 6th
one time in public it's on video where
you said those words
i don't have a computer i don't have my
social media
i didn't i didn't remember
many of the
social media posts that you pulled up in
interviews
i was interested that you
answered some questions about
fbi director ray's testimony in congress
do you believe the fbi
uh was behind the january 6th violent
capital
i don't know i certainly think there's a
lot to be investigated we don't know who
reyettes is the scaffolding commander
we don't the governor whitmer's plot
certainly leads to questions about
things that happen on january 6th i
think there's a lot of investigations
that need to happen
you've referred to january 6 as a
federation right
i'm i'm not sure
nothing
okay
anything else just about before we take
our break no anything else
okay do they rest or do you rest no we
have
well we have an issue that we want to
insult on but
either we're going to put in a video or
we're going to move to closing
statements but the video has been
admitted so it's a timing issue that we
want to talk about all right
so you don't need with she's excused
that's right thank you
thank you thank you representative you
are excused step down all right now i
believe we discussed we will take a
break
before we go
what do you want to do mr kelly i mean
you want to take a break i don't know
what i don't know what you're talking
yeah i think
your honor we would appreciate a very
short break well let's take 15 and be
back it must be back at uh quarter two
last question
are we absolutely
dedicated to stopping at 4 30 if we went
a little longer than that i will have to
consult with
the real powers
well only because we want we're trying
to figure out our presentation the last
piece of our presentation if we want to
close or do we have stuff one more thing
and so it'd be nice to know but we will
i will consult with judge mali and we
will respond and we can meet thank you
okay we're off to 15 minutes
okay it seems like they're going to take
a break here
um let's make sure there's no more hot
mic moments before i cut away
and do some more commentary
because we've been streaming for six
long hours today thanks for joining us
here at the tony michaels podcast we do
appreciate you uh staying with us today
uh if you're just joining us or if
you've been joining us all day uh
welcome to the tony michaels podcast
where we broadcast every single weekday
monday through friday
every single one of them
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch here's the thing normally we're
only on for two hours today has been a
special event because uh we really
wanted to stream this marjory taylor
green testimony we think it's very
important um amanda says need a bathroom
break tony um no i i i um i have been
taking secret breaks i have a body
double that sits here
um he sits off and off frame and he has
a voice like no i'm just kidding um
there was a few times where we had some
breaks i was able to um use the restroom
so thank you amanda for thinking of me
but here's the thing we don't normally
we don't normally stream for six hours
not a normal thing we normally do it two
hours every single weekday noon eastern
11 center on youtube twitter twitch and
now we broadcast from the midas touch
facebook page so if you guys are out
there and you've been listening to today
you really you really should go
subscribe to the youtube channel
just go to youtube type in the tony
michaels podcast hit subscribe
that way you don't miss a thing because
here's what i think i'm going to do
because we were really trying to figure
out how this was going to work we had no
idea i didn't know how long this thing
was going to last
i didn't know what was going to happen
in this thing
but we had karen agnipolo
kfa from legal af the podcast that minus
touch produces legal af
on earlier giving live legal commentary
during during the hearing
so what i think i'm going to do for the
podcast directories is i'm going to take
this episode this this gazillion hours
that we have and we're going to cut out
some of the parts where kfa is talking
about her legal analysis
we will cut out bonehead of the week so
you guys make sure you get bonehead of
the week on the directories and then
maybe we'll cut out like some other
commentary that we've done and maybe
some significant parts of the marjorie
taylor green
some of her testimony i expected
to be honest with you i expected the
marjorie taylor's greens lawyer to spend
a lot more time
on her testimony but it doesn't seem
like they thought they needed much time
to prove it and i think karen agnipolo
kfa from legal af
is correct on this i think the feeling
is
is that this judge is not going to make
a constitutional decision
or what he views as a constitutional
decision
um
for
the when when
when we're in an administrative type
hearing right like this isn't this isn't
a civil courtroom
this is not a
this is not a
criminal courtroom
uh thank you mj and ken for the super
chats there now they're both thanking us
for our service today i guess you're
welcome you're welcome now we were going
to be sitting here anyways we're just
streaming longer now
i was going to watch this thing
regardless so i might as well watch it
with you i guess
but i believe that this judge
is going to do what uh karen mcnippolo
kfa from legal af says
is that he's going to kick this can down
the road he's going to make it really
easy on himself right so what he's going
to do is he's going to say well this is
a constitutional question this needs to
be
had in a federal court or this needs to
be worked out with congress right
that's what i believe he's gonna say and
he's gonna kick this can they made it
really easy because there's been no real
definitive proof um that the that the
petitioners have provided that would say
that yes
undeniably in this courtroom during this
hearing during your testimony she is an
insurrectionist she called for violence
like there's no
you order the co-red you order the
co-red you goddamn right i did you know
there's not that moment right
there's not that moment there hasn't
been a piece of evidence that really
spells out for this judge i believe who
is probably
leaning towards
uh probably leaning toward marjorie
favoring in marjory taylor's green's
favor anyways
i don't think there's anything that's
shown that would justify him to not kick
this can down the road and what i mean
by that it's not that i want him to i
just i that's what this [ __ ]
knucklehead's gonna do
right that's what he's gonna do here uh
ty rots thank you for the super sticker
thank you ty
ty's one of our favorite over on um
twitter you guys should go follow ty she
writes for occupy democrats by the way
so go check out her articles at occupy
denver we've actually featured a couple
of her articles here
on the tony michaels podcast because i
think she's wrote about those oath
keepers that i keep talking about i keep
talking about the oath keepers they keep
talking about the proud boys they keep
talking about roger stone and i keep
talking about that goddamn decision made
out in california by car judge carter
about john eastman's emails and how they
were not protected by attorney-client
privilege because john eastman and
donald trump committed a
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding
that is why judge carter decided that
those are criminal and that is why
they're not protected
by attorney-client privilege a federal
judge has ruled
that donald trump and john eastman
committed crimes
conspiracy to obstruct
congress official proceeding is the
actual charge or the actual crime that
he accuses them of in his in his
judgment
on
the fact that these emails that they
were they were planning the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup are not protected by
attorney client privilege
but that is significant and the reason
why that's significant is again and and
when questioning
marjorie taylor green the petitioner's
lawyer even brought up martial law which
i thought oh man maybe he's gonna come
in
here with some real evidence
some real evidence
because there is actual evidence out in
the open in the public that we have
that shows that the oath keepers were
waiting
they were waiting
on an order from someone
to
order the qrf which is the stockpile
weapons across the potomac in virginia
to bring them across the river
so that way they were armed
that way they could commit or commit a
coup
by donald trump declaring martial law
and deputizing the oath keepers
stewart rhodes was in charge of that qrf
or that stockpile weapons he was waiting
for the order
and it just so happens that one of his
lieutenants who has pled guilty to
conspiracy of sedition
which is important when you talk about
the qrf and the stash of weapons
he was protecting roger stone he was
standing right next to roger stone the
entire
the entire time the insurrection was
happening on january 6.
now it's known that roger stone has a
personal connection with the president
and probably has a personal line
with the president where he could
either call or text him i don't know i
would imagine that roger stone maybe
even had burners on him that day who
knows i guess maybe we'll find out in a
court of law one of these days
but also that is what is significant
is that
stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers
who whose lieutenant was protecting
standing next to roger stone the entire
time the insurrection was happening
met with enrique tario
the day before and the context there is
that they met in a parking garage in
washington dc where enrique tario was
ordered not to be it was unlawful for
him to be in the city of washington dc
at that moment
and there was a protest where he had
burned a sign off of a church they tore
a sign down off a church and they'd
ordered him out of the city but he came
in anyways to meet with stewart rhodes
the founder of the oak keepers where his
lieutenant
would be standing next to roger stone
waiting for orders apparently
from someone to give to stewart rhodes
that martial law had been that had been
declared
and that the stack stockpile weapons
could be brought across the potomac
to stop those antifa and black lives
matter and even marjorie taylor green
in her testimony here in open court
brings up antifa and black lives matter
that racist [ __ ]
of course they could they they do this
[ __ ] where they conflate these two
issues
and the reason why is because they
wanted black lives matter and antifa
there that day but they weren't but they
wanted them there they wanted so bad for
antiva and black lives matter to commit
violence
so that way it was very easy for the
president united states at the time the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
himself donald trump
to declare martial law and to deputize
the oath keepers so they could arrest
members of congress
and it is very important to know
that stewart road and stuart rhodes and
enrique tario met the night before
and the reason why it's super super
super duper
significant is because the proud boys
were supposed to be
the security force that was going to be
next to roger stone that day
but they switched it for some reason for
some reason the proud boys decided they
wouldn't protect roger stone that the
oath keepers were i wonder if it's
because the proud boys didn't have the
stockpile weapons it was the oath
keepers who had the possibility of
bringing the qrf across the potomac
but the reason why also that the proud
boys are significant in that they
were in cahoots with roger stone is one
of the people that have charged an
indictment with enrique tario
is another lieutenant but of the proud
boys and he has pled guilty
to the conspiracy listen to this
the conspiracy
to an obstruct
an official
proceeding that is very very very
important
very important in this case when we
watch
that that a judge a federal judge in
california judge carter
says that john eastman
and donald trump were committing a crime
that's why they're not protected
by attorney-client privilege and the
crime that he thinks they've committed
that would not protect their
attorney-client privilege is the
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding
and we have the proud boys
pleading guilty to that exact charge
this is not this is not
this is not
um
hard to understand
it's not hard to follow the bouncing
ball here we know this out in public now
and marjorie taylor green has done
nothing more today
than to maybe maybe keep herself on the
ballot but only to reveal to us
the real plans
of january 6th she lays it out when
she's asked about martial law
and of course they tried to cover their
tracks of course they did of course she
made videos the president united states
made a video
in the rose garden trying to cover his
tracks when they knew it wasn't gonna
work and when they knew it wasn't gonna
work is when mike pence
did refuse to leave the capitol
when he refused to leave and he refused
to go along with the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup and his
his role in it
mike pence refused
to not do the thing that he was that he
was constitutional constitutionally set
out to do was his duty
was to preside over the proceeding
where the states would certify the vote
that they had already certified
folks
all's mike pence was doing was opening
up the oscar envelope and reading the
results
this objection [ __ ] that she's talking
about oh democrats have objected before
it is the right of a member of congress
to vote to object to a certification she
is correct
that is your right you do have that
right as a congressperson
but that doesn't mean that it's going to
happen
and just because you have the right
doesn't mean you have an alternative
which is what she was talking about in
one of those videos that was shown when
she didn't recall i don't recall if
that's me i don't know i [ __ ]
my memory just went blank
now the question is to me
is
when will we see
results from the department of justice i
think that's the real question after
today the question after today isn't
rather marjorie taylor green's going to
be on the ballot or not because honestly
if the constituents inside her district
don't want her on the ballot they can go
vote for her primary challenger a
primary challenger
they will be able to anyways these
ballots are already printed they said
that at the beginning of the hearing
it's not like they're actually trying to
take her off the ballot in the general
election because she's not even on that
ballot yet
she has to win the primary she has
challengers she's likely to win
that's why they're protesting
um her being on the ballot in the first
place the why they uh petitioned to take
her off when using this
this insurrection
law
to take her off the ballot i think it's
very significant though that she is laid
forth in her testimony
uh more lies more perjury it seems
and the other the other thing that i
think is probably discounted is how much
this politically
not only damages her but it damages the
republican party i'm sure the republican
party is not [ __ ] excited that
marjorie taylor greene is sitting for a
couple hours testifying about how no no
i'm not an insurrectionist don't look
over here
don't believe your lying eyes don't
believe your lying eyes then i'm an
insurrectionist all the while matt gatz
the the accused child sex trafficker
sits in the front
giving links to my i mean i'm assuming
there i'm making assumptions there that
he's winking at her he might be taking
notes someone
said while ago taking notes on how not
to answer questions during testimony
but i don't think this is good for the
republican party this is not good for
their politics for her to be sitting
here
folks we now have hours and hours and
hours
of marjory taylor greene
being the leader of their party
uh looks like the proscenius are gonna
come back let's see if we can listen in
i think they're gonna make their closing
arguments here and hopefully the judge
will make a decision if the judge
indicates that he's not going to make a
decision today we will probably cut out
um
since we've been here for almost six and
a half hours but if he looks like he's
going to make a decision i will stay on
so mr shelley before we start i trust
the message guys
thank you we can we can go as long as we
learn together we very much appreciate
your honor
so you heard that they're going to go as
long as they need to go or can go
which are the tweets reflected in the
propublica report and the lothrin report
to be admitted with the leader that
representative greene's testimony about
how her twitter account was operated
that she authorized tweets to be issued
is sufficient foundation
for them to be admitted and so we would
ask that those two sets of planets
exhibits be admitted mr bob
yeah if they were well
it had been a lot
oh my goodness sorry
it made a lot more sense if we uh that
happened uh at the time at each time
because
just because it's authenticated doesn't
mean it's missable
well
that's why i'm asking what what's your
position on this there were a number of
them that were we went over and then
there were some that i don't run over
and then i think it was one you
requested
so
and it was
so make sure i've got it right
we're looking at
basically everything in one
is that correct mr chelsea yes okay
they're in right there
and p2 as well p2
now wait a minute
that's different kettle of fish
what are we talking about are you
talking about
the whole thing yes these are her social
media posts
i i do not object to a social media
that's all they are
well but there's also
to the entire report
actually all right well all right
all right it looks like this is
again let's you might want to take a
second look at it well and i i have what
uh yeah it looks to me like these
everything that's in p2
looks like it is there's a cover page
but we're happy to exclude that okay
that was my question what about the
cover page we'll exclude that all right
so you basically pick up from page 22 of
128
to
128 so 22
that's right which is just the text and
the tweets and the
enclosures exactly right
and of course we have made our
individual objections right yesterday
all right and uh
and they're preserved and they're
preserved yeah if you want you're
preserving those notices all right we're
going to preserve the objections
okay before we rest your honor we have
one piece of last piece of evidence
which is plainness i'm sorry p
73 which is a video it's 14 minutes long
your honor
which one is this this is the washington
post
um
it shows the events of january 6.
did i not already admit this yes i did
okay why does the audience need to watch
that i can watch it that's that's fine
i've already watched it a couple of
times okay i mean again i mean one of
these things about it's only 17 minutes
there's a lot of material in the record
which obviously was not the subject of
today's hearing which i'm perfectly
happy to refer refer to in review in
connection with the briefs so
about i don't know that we need to play
the video and it's watching post video
it's available on public sources right
as you wish your honor all right great
okay any anything else mr chelsea um no
no
the petitioner's arrested yes anything
else
will you arrest very well all right well
i'll hear closing um
petitioners get the last word
about you you get to go further
okay
so we're going to start closing
statements here uh
deputy dog
margie taylor green's attorney is going
to start and then the petitioners get
the their final closing statement
um
i again want to talk about the law and
then i'll talk about the evidence that
has been submitted and whether or not
that evidence means to correct legal
standards
that we believe are
lean into the microphone of course
you're under north carolina
22-1-5
which permits secretary of state to
remove
someone as a candidate for office if one
they do not qualify as a candidate for
office
or number two
if they are not eligible
to take office and in this case on
january
3rd 2023
now
they assert a disqualification under
section 3.
is that uh
representative greene engaged in
insurrectional rebellion after taking
the if of office on january
and uh
and i assume
even though they're not clear
on january 6th
section 3
also provides
that kant that quote congress made by a
vote of two-thirds of each house
remove such disability in other words
remove the political disability
of not being able to take office by
taking the oath which is the truth
and um
and
they can do that at any time
you can see the wording of the last
sentence
is not time limited in other words it
could could have been done last week
it could be due
next month
it could be done on january 3rd 2023
when representative green presents
herself
and before she's sworn in
congress could pass
a stat he set a statute under section 3
the last sentence
and she would then
to take off
how in the world do we know right now
that she will not be qualified on
january 3rd 2023
when congress at any time
either for her in particular
or for a class of people as congress
congress has done in fact there were
thousands of individual amnesties
and then two general amnesties granted
by the congress
they could do that at any time
it is impossible for this court to know
at this time that she is not eligible to
take office because of that contingency
they can be exercised by congress at any
time in the future
up until january 3rd
that means this is nothing
she cannot be viewed as disqualified
today
because it cannot be determined that she
is ineligible for office
on january
third twenty twenty three
that should end it
now
second
[Music]
this has already happened
the amnesty has already been granted
the simple argument about this is the
1872 amnesty act
relieved
the disability under section
3
to
quote all persons whomsoever
representative green is
a
all persons whosoever
and it relieved the political disability
that
section 3 imposed and by the way the
word imposed here
is a past participle
meaning
that phrase imposed by section 3 is an
adjective
on regarding
what political disabilities are we
talking about because absent that
modifier of that of political disability
uh it could be you're a felon you lost
your civil rights and we're giving you
amnesty
from
that political disability that you
cannot
take office as a convicted film
so
the only way to know what political
disabilities we're talking to is the
past participle
i didn't know this at the beginning you
know
the past participle imposed by the by
section three
now we also know that section 3 is both
retrospective because it affected anyone
in the past
that had engaged in
insurrection or rebellion
after taking the oath
and disqualified them from office but it
also had a prospective effect because
why would we be here if it didn't have a
prospective effect
what would be what would be the basis to
apply this to representative green
so
we know it has both perspective and
retrospective
and in the amnesty act of
1872
it was removed that that
retrospective or prospective
political disability under section
three was removed
for all persons whosoever
and the court and the district court in
north carolina agreed with that analysis
that case was now on appeal
the uh the district court here in
atlanta did not
and that case is on appeal
so you get to be the tiebreaker
right now
uh
we also know
that when they use when that
set uh the 1872 amnesty act was adopted
that they did intend to be to it to be
both retrospective and prospective
because of the wording of the 1898
amnesty
the 1898 amnesty act
after the phrase
disabilities imposed by the third
section of the 14th
uh amendment of
article of amendments to the
constitution of the united states
inserted the words
heretofore encouraged
that is not in the 72
version
so congress knew very well how to do a
retrospective amnesty
if they
chose to do it
because in 1889 that's exactly so i
think i think what um
attorney deputy dog here is making in
his boring statements
is basically he's trying to convince the
judge that hey
you don't have to make this decision now
you can kick this can and if congress
wants to expel her
or disqualify her they can do that later
on you don't have to do it now
he's trying to make it as easy as he can
on the judge
that
the political disabilities were both
retroactive and prospective
in 1872 the wording of that amendment of
that act
encompassed both
the 1898
wording only referred to retrospective
now
you know we heard some you know
interesting things you know about uh
the history
of uh our country
uh
from uh
my fellow hoosier
uh law professor
he um
but
he admitted
that when congress considered
the uh
the fourteenth amendment in section
three
there was not a word about any other
insurrection rebellion other than
the civil war
and uh
that means that that history about
shades and about about the whiskey
rebellions as interesting as they are
would simply play no role
in other words that was a historical
occurrence there is no evidence even if
we need to look at legislative history
no evidence that congress considered
that at all
so
i i will soon be talking to you about
what we do know about what they thought
in 1867
but uh
now
so let's get to uh
the meaning of the words in section
three
engage in insurrection or rebellion is
one
and
giving aid or comfort to the enemies
thereof is number two
well that number two
is about foreign wars
as i will soon be explained
number one is about domestic wars
as has been described and was which were
described at the time
by authorities
when they talked about those phrases
so
what is engagement
what is engage
it connotes
condeph
and you will soon see hear the authority
for the proposition that that is quote
direct
a a direct
over
act
such as voluntarily joining the armed
forces of the confederacy
giving them
food
giving the army food you know cash
whatever a shelter
the people in the war department
prosecuting the war etc
now
there is
not a single
piece of evidence
that any of those things occurred
here
with respect to representative green
there were certainly some 700 people
involved at least they have been charged
who have been involved in the attack on
the capitol
primo's wonderful
they agree with that
and there is no other act
of
direct over act of an insurrection
nature
that she is engaged in
is anyone else having a real difficult
time staying awake
during this guy's closing arguments
they're not satisfied i'm definitely
cutting this [ __ ]
out of the audio version of the podcast
oh my god
and and when they use their political
speech they want to use
the nuances or the vagueness or wait a
second we didn't use the word peaceful
in this one sentence
even though you said it over here you
didn't use it in this one sentence right
here
and code words for goodness sakes
right there
this state is an insurrection it is our
insurrection
right says right there 1876.
now
if you're going to use speech which you
can't use here because they didn't use
the word insight violence they said
engage or incite an insurrectional and
they said engage in an insurrection
but it is instructive
and it's different because you can see
for instance in the act of 1862
where there was a felony to quote incite
set on foot whatever that means assist
or engage
in any rebellion or insurrection and a
quote that's codified at 18 usc section
2383
those two two
words are used in the same
list
rules of construction tell you that they
have to be different
or there's surprises you need we never
assume that congress
is just throwing words out there as
surplus
so
they
they necessarily mean a different thing
brandenburg decide that uh
defined incitement as requiring speech
that quote
directed or inciting or producing
imminent
lawless
action
that is likely to incite or produce
such or that is likely to produce such
action
producing imminent lawless action
now that's very restrictive that's very
limiting and of course the reason is the
protection of the first amendment
which we have now seen on full display
here
full display
the danger of
consuming words way beyond their meaning
to allow political opponents
to smear
their their opposition
in a court of law
i know you're you've got
you know
it's an administrative court but yeah
whatever you play
and they have exploited that to the max
well uh what are the words
that do not amount to insurrection
well we we know there are words like
that or statements like that ku klux
klan leader quote
advocating the duty necessity or
propriety of crime
sabotage violence or unlawful methods of
terrorism as a means to accomplish
industrial or political reform
the court said that's advocacy that's
not incitement of violence
the uh
i represented did you just hear that
he just used
the kkk
i don't know if you guys got that he
just used a quote from the kkk as an
example of what advocacy is just like
what marjorie taylor green is doing not
incitement i don't know if you caught
that
as an example he used the kkk
as an example of what marjorie taylor
greene was doing and the quote not
incitement
for violence
but advocacy protected by the first
amendment
so we know the kind of words that will
be considered that
so what do we have from them
we have
a rally
there is no evidence that there was
anything but that that was anything but
a peaceful rally
and
and
accusation that she organized it which
she didn't
and uh and while she
on a few occasions urged people to go to
it she didn't even go to it herself and
speak and there was zero evidence that
anything unlawful happened there
the these kind of rallies happened in
the capital
of the united states
numerous times every single year on the
ellipse
i attend one of them every every year
and uh
and you know
guess what was one of the things they
always say and of course these are
left-wing right-wing democrats
republicans whatever what do they always
say
well once we're done here go to the
capitol
tell your representative
uh you know
to vote for our issue okay
that in their world
is what is calling for violence
when it is
absolutely appropriate for people to go
to the capitol of the united states
to enter into it
it's absolutely lawful to do that it was
not lawful that day the building was
closed
it was not lawful that day that's
[ __ ]
he's [ __ ] lying this is a code word i
guess
then uh uh
well what about this representative
green
did your staff take anyone on gabe
sanchez rejoining us everybody between
january 3rd and january
did any of you give any maps of the
capital to anybody
what are they talking about congressman
do that every single day for their
constituents
not during covet when it was closed down
you should have just stayed off i mean
this is really this is putting everybody
to sleep
i've almost passed out four times
lawless riot
oh but
1776
or what about independence day
or how about
talking about the declaration of
independence
or what about
talking about the
revolutionary war for our independence
these are now code words
for advocating for a violent overthrow
of the government of the united states
what an outrage
they want to hijack and cancel
oh my god
part of this script
i'm wondering if ron desantis got his uh
word in
on this uh these closing arguments
defense of the second amendment
if you advocate for defense of the
second amendment you are in favor and in
get back are engaging in
the
uh the violent overthrow of the
government of the united states
when you say that you're going to use
the second amendment
to get rid of politicians that that's
what you're saying
right
in the militia you know necessary for
you know a free republic or why i don't
know exactly
then the citizens have the right to keep
and bear arm so yes
there's a
military application if you will the
military the militia
i mean the militia won this you know was
a major factor in winning our
revolutionary war oh god is he
justifying the insurrection right now
well i mean earlier he used uh an
example of the kkk
of of advocacy and basically compared
what marjorie taylor green and the
insurrectionists did to the kkk
as advocacy not not incitement so so
there's that advocating for the there's
i'm sure it's a clip of it's already on
twitter somewhere it has to be there's
no way this guy didn't use
the example of kkk
as advocacy the same advocacy as
marjorie taylor green was using holy
[ __ ] oh my word
i mean
yes people on the conservative side are
concerned that the bible administration
is eroding our freedoms
i mean we just got one back as a result
of a federal judge just like what two or
three days ago so that means they're not
that that means they're not
[ __ ] boneheaded
about what will happen with the election
divide and has proven to be the case we
have lost our friends
some of them he he just said he just he
just said he literally just said
we got one back which is not a [ __ ]
freedom but whatever they keep saying
this
events of january 6th
so
what we're going to do is just mush them
all together right they're all one thing
just mesh them all together
well the first amendment then
allow you to do that
you know what the first amendment
provides with respect to freedom of
association which is what a rally is or
under the first amendment as an assembly
protected by the system is
is that if you have
a peaceful
rally which they had there's no evidence
otherwise
some people leave
as some people did
he's calling january 6 a peaceful rally
committed and nearly black
this
rally does not lose its first amendment
protection
because the actions of the few that show
up in that situation
are not
cannot be attributed
to the organization
or
who'd ever have who could ever have a
rally right
you know like somebody like you know
anyone could protest anywhere
what the rally's about or
he knows that in most cities you can't
just show up and protest as a big group
of people you actually have to get uh
what's those pesky little things on
permits permits
just because they regulate your right
doesn't mean you don't have it right
and and so
what why
there's a two-step analysis first was
there like the kkk is going to be
calling on this guy for a representation
later questionably so
under
under uh
what we know and what the evidence is
well can the rally be held
into account
for what the few did that left the the
few
you mean the few that stood up on stage
and incited the
the [ __ ] people in the at the rally
to go
commit an insurrection you mean those
few people
jesus [ __ ] christ
there was a dude with a bulletproof vest
on stage
he said go fight like hell
may have participated in conduct or
advocated doctrines that itself is not
protected
the naacp is particularly instructed
here in that and that was end quote the
naacp is particularly instructed here as
their or constitutionally protected
speech association and petition designed
to influence government action i.e
support
the constitutional right of members of
congress to object in the
two votes on the uh regarding the
electoral college
along with the illegal actions by a few
but the acts of the latter don't strip
the others other first amendment rights
where the government failed to prove
that quote the naacp authorized either
actually or apparently
the unlawful comment either authorized
it or ratified it
actually or apparently there's no
evidence of that
that's how to say who heard about them
so we have different events
some that are subject to first amendment
protection
others the attack on the capital that
are not
and to drag
her into
amanda always with her points amanda
always with your points amanda says i
always park my weapons across the river
you know
because it's peaceful across the river
it's peaceful
you know
always with her
thank you amanda
all of these are first amendment
protected activities every single one of
them
and none of them constitute even yeah
yeah yeah sorry sorry i i may have
misquoted mo brooks said today's the day
we start taking taking down names and
kicking ass kicking ass
while having a bulletproof vest
thank you for pointing that out thank
you
from facebook
the insurrection
is
narrowly defined
uh i quoted cases some from 1898 for
some from
1842
some from
uh
the
1795 militia act
do you think that do you think the judge
is like yeah yeah yeah i love you going
through and armed uprising [ __ ] the
so far reciting laws first to define the
authority of the united states yeah you
know i'm not sure exactly what this
judge is thinking
he really seems like he wants to get to
the end before the closing statements
um i actually think
it seems like he might make a decision
today i'm not sure if he will or not i
guess we'll find out
as soon as these closing arguments are
unless it is so serious done being
making us drowsy um we'll hear the uh
closing arguments from the petition
petitioners the lawyer
i mean
and then maybe the judge will
decide to make a decision today
well uh in 18
we've only been streaming for seven
hours by the way
we're going for a record p 48 actually i
think my record is nine
uh
was it during the mccarthy um i had that
i did
i streamed for like
an hour i'd have to go back and look
what the event was
it might have been mccarthy he's trying
to filibuster
i think that might have been what it was
like a all [ __ ] day and all night
that was a dude that was a dude i went
to go see a movie and i came back
oh really is that what yeah
thanks for watching i appreciate it
however
therefore what i have done
is at three o'clock
in the morning thursday morning
uh i
figured out how to not only
you know zoom it okay to make it larger
is this guy explaining this
trial
[Laughter]
i take a screenshot of my text and i
email it to myself and it's super super
long and super pixelated
and this takes you
step by step through the analysis of the
attorney general oh i thought he was
going to say step by step how to zoom in
it's a how-to article right and shown to
you
uh
what the words engage in insurrectional
rebellion
and
giving aid or comfort to
the enemies
mean
and men
in 1867 because those words were not
just used
in 1868 and the 14th of may
but they were used and this is what
the attorney general was addressing
uh it was used in a reconstruction act
uh because they were going to open up
voting to the
uh people who lived in the confederacy
old confederacy and they were required
to take a note
and that oath in order to register to
vote one of its sections was
that they have to swear that they did
not
quote engage in insurrection or
rebellion or
they had to swear on their mama's grave
i don't know which is it i swear on my
mama's grave that i didn't commit
insurrection
the first a 1a starts about you know
in the middle column we're going to go
down the middle column for a while all
right
and uh
it starts with
uh considering i now come to consider
the meaning of the disqualification
arising from this point of view
it requires a person to state that he is
quote
not
engaged in an insurrect or rebellion
against the united states or given aid
and comfort
[Music]
each of these are separately considered
according to
the the attorney general the next page
now it's on the left a little bit
uh my duty here is one of simple
construction
and i thought this was important
he was not
applying constitutional
concepts to his construction
which of course is he just talking
waiting for all of us just to forget who
marjorie taylor green is
yeah is that what he's doing
i'm not sure exactly what his point is
he's tried to make these points
but it just even at that he viewed the
oath because you couldn't vote as
depriving you of a right the bailiff is
really mad look at him
he's super pissed
he goes to
uh
that the
requirement of the oath and the
disqualification
must be viewed as a punishment for that
conduct
and as a result
it made the oath
uh even more objectionable than than the
fact that it was also a violation of a
right and a right to those
now
then on page three
uh he said any doubts must be resolved
in the favor of the voter
and uh
and then said
what acts then or within the meaning of
this provision
well
at the bottom he says well the first
sentence engaged
in insurrectional rebellion covers the
case of domestic war
and the second phrase
uh
aid or comfort to the enemy
applies to foreign war
so
in this context
we need to be looking at engaging in
insurrection and rebellion
he continues on on page four on that
analysis
page five is not i'm sure interesting
but not relevant
um
and then we go to page six
we are now to inquire what is meant by
how many pages are there oh [ __ ]
it's like uh skip that page just skip
all of them dude just skip them all he
said first
this judge this judge is likely to rule
in marjorie taylor green's favor here
don't you think
uh
yeah i just
you know i was hoping that the uh
the plaintiff would be able to
make a case in the end
because with the whole fact of like
somebody who voluntarily i don't recall
i don't recall you know on page seven
and then obviously she blossoms open to
say oh yeah i know exactly what i was
doing once her attorney goes
it's you know
i don't know
well it's very hard
it's very obvious
yeah yeah it's very oh yeah it's very
yeah very clear but i have a hard time
as it goes on
i've become less and less like ooh we
have a case here and more like
any fines than that
again again
and i think um
kfa kind of alluded to it the best case
to be made probably is that the people
have the option to take her off the
ballot and by that i mean vote for
another republican candidate in the
primary just allow democracy to happen
right or allow it to happen
um
now she wouldn't allow democracy to
happen and that's kind of this provision
that they're trying to use is because
she was committing insurrection
she doesn't believe in democracy she
shouldn't be allowed on the ballot
because her goal is to use democracy
against itself that's kind of the uh
that's kind of the idea i think the
other thing to remember here too is um
if there's smoke there is fire right
like you see this behavior and this type
of uh
narrative or or message that they're
pushing
it's it's not just a one-time occurrence
right they're using the same type of
language they're they're using the same
type of uh
you know provocative uh
messaging and and uh ways to rally
people and incite them to get them
excited or or angry or what have you
um
they do it again and again and again i
mean trump is one especially where he's
like oh go go you know kick that son of
a bitch's ass right like oh yeah parties
violence
stand by stand back stand by i mean
exactly so when you see this stuff it's
not like marjory taylor green was like
oh well you know
it was just this one moment
there's literally video evidence of her
supporting people now she might not
explicitly say i'm promoting violence
to
uh to to january 6
but i am telling you that you should
stand up in the 1776 and you should you
should fight or you should uh defend
your right or what have you
um
it's just
the whole party is guilty of it um and
it's like if they get away with it this
one time or these people get away with
it without any sort of repercussions
just know that
they're going to feel more confident
and
they're going to feel like they can do
it again or to some extent right well
and i think that's important
but also i want people to not forget
that this is not a criminal court right
like this isn't a decision to
to criminalize what marjorie taylor
green may or may not have done
uh in the lead up to january 6 and on
january 6. and you noticed that we
talked a lot about january 3rd and they
really focused on the day january 3rd
because that's the day congress was
actually sworn in so that's the day she
took the oath right so they were saying
anything before that really couldn't be
taken into account but in a criminal
court the criminal court does not give a
[ __ ] does not give a [ __ ] if she was
trying to plan and become a
congressperson sworn an oath it does not
give a [ __ ]
it does not give a [ __ ] what day or any
of that [ __ ] they're not going to give a
[ __ ] so
if she did perjure herself today which
it seems that she may have
um
the doj
likely has the evidence that the i mean
it's on the record now under the oath
right
and they have the evidence that the
petitioners here would not have right
right exactly that's another detail that
i think you know we might briefly touch
on but you bring up a good point is that
there is
okay there's like known evidence that
which is out there on the internet
and out in the public forum
there is probably also other evidence
let's say phone records or call logs or
ip addresses or geo tags or other things
that pinpoint certain people in certain
locations at certain times
as well as other kind of
connected evidence we'll say ancillary
that is not privy to parties like this
they just know the public knowledge they
were only all they were only able to
display things that were on twitter and
facebook and newsmax and fox news and
wherever else right
they don't have the apps right the same
well the same evidence that we have seen
right exactly right right right are any
of the evidence coming out of january 6
yeah so january 6 is another example
where it's like we didn't like every
time they dropped something everyone's
like oh [ __ ] there's more right measures
right and we assumed all this stuff we
assumed it but we never actually had the
evidence of it right i think the one
thing that is very significant today to
the case that could be made against
someone in a criminal court and marjorie
taylor greener otherwise
is the fact when she was talking about
how she was making her video
and the the petitioner's lawyer asked
her did you make any phone calls did you
have any communication outside of that
room i think that and she said i don't
recall
i don't recall
i think that is very significant um
and that she did have communication i
saw photos being shared from january 6
where she was with other
congress people
and she was you know totally relaxed
just hanging out laughing talking
and it definitely gives me uh
the opposite impression of her being
scared in a cloak room you mean you mean
you mean she knew what was going on
maybe i don't know
kind of weird you know
maybe maybe it got like one i don't know
exactly what the timeline is between
when she made that video and when ashley
baba got shot right because also she
knew that a gunshot gunshot went out or
off and she knew who it was or had an
idea
the other thing it was
to with that i say like
she may have very well been
uh totally chilled until she found out
that somebody got shot or there was
gunfire and it was like oh [ __ ] uh and
then made a video being like hey this is
not actually what we wanted right our
expectation was that we would be able to
come in overtake
hold people uh you know pull people
accountable
the democratic members to actually vote
to not certify the election but as soon
as
gunshot a gunshot shot went off or
somebody died or someone was injured
then people started to retreat back and
they're like oh [ __ ]
well representative clyde right that guy
said it was just a normal tourist visit
and you look at photos and he's like
barricade he's like yeah he's terrified
he's terrified well
but here's here's the thing is at some
point at some point they knew that mike
pence
the plan for mike pence did not go the
way that they wanted the plan to go for
mike pence right like there is there is
uh
major pictures
and and um i think
jonathan alter is the one who had him he
spoke about him on stephen colbert's uh
late show
um
talked about mark short and and
the vice president at the time mike
pence in the in the parking garage
trying to decide if mike pence was gonna
go with the secret service and they
decided to not have the vice president
go with the secret service and stay at
the capitol complex right and that is
significant because that sorted the
whole eastman memo in the whole eastman
plan and the cheeto dust kangaroo coup
had had a
a kink in it talked a lot about the law
yeah the fact that pence wouldn't get
into the car i'm not getting in there
that says a lot right i'm going to try
to confine my remarks with facts
and we're going to submit a brief as
your honor knows next week with
responses to all the interesting legal
issues that's involved
so that means that the response will
probably come for another couple weeks
maybe difficult yeah it i don't think
they're gonna make a decision today
they handed them binders full of tweets
so i don't know if
i'm dead serious like it literally was a
binder
full of tweets wow i mean social media
posts right simple requirements
that the candidate for federal office
had taken the oath to the constitution
that an insurrection occurred
and that the candidate
having taken that oath
engaged in insurrection
promoted it
supported it
assisted it
helped bring it into fruition
those are the three elements
we
came here today prepared to prove
and those are the three elements
that we have proved
let's talk about each of the three
marjorie taylor green took the oath of
office on january 3rd
2021.
she became a member of the united states
house of representatives the body that
represents not the states
but the people of the country in general
we the people
now mr bob said this morning words
matter
and we agree with that
our proof today started with the oath
because in taking the oath
this green understood a very undertook a
very solemn
and very specific obligation
to uphold the constitution
to defend the constitution
against all enemies
foreign and domestic
now taking that oath was an honor
but it was also an obligation
this green was no longer a simple
citizen of the great state of georgia
she wasn't just another person with
opinions and a twitter account
she became part of our government
and she took on an affirmative
obligation as part of our government
to protect the constitution
to protect its processes
from anyone who would seek to block
or impede them
that is what the disqualification clause
is all about
that special status
that is conferred upon a person
when she takes the oath of office
now we'll argue in our brief to this
court that that status means
that ms green can't just say anything
she wants that she could have said as a
private citizen
and our brief will also point out that
there are lots of things that people say
that are words
that matter
and that also have common evil
consequences
but that all of that is for another day
today the evidence has proven factually
that not only did marjorie greene um
engage in the ceremony of taking the
oath to the constitution
we've proven that the oath has meaning
that it has teeth
that has consequences
insurrection
happened at the u.s capitol building on
january 6 2021
was an insurrection
it's as clear as day
and even mr buck doesn't really deny it
and how do we know that
because he keeps talking about the rally
it's the rally it's the ellipse it's the
rally
we're not talking about the rally
we're talking about what happened at the
capitol
now there are lots of words and phrases
that can be used to describe
what's on that washington post video
that your honor was viewed a couple of
times
lawlessness disturbance a riot
and ms green and her counsel
confused some of those words today and
in their briefs
but the word they really avoid using
is insurrection
a riot can be an insurrection
we learn that today from professor
magliaka
insurrections can be disturbances they
are lawless
they are unrest
but when it's used in the
disqualification clause an insurrection
is more than these things
it is something where the purpose of it
is to block
impede
disrupt a constitutional process
or to overthrow the very existence of
the government itself
professor magliocca explained all of
this and how american history has faced
many insurrections in the past
and how all of them share the same
features
violence
aimed at the processes or the legitimacy
of government
sometimes they're aimed at courts
in this case they were aimed at the
legislature
and and the violence that cannot be
quelled by ordinary law enforcement
needs
judgment you saw and heard with your own
eyes
not just violence
horrific and sickening as it is
but its goal
which was to stop the certification of
the electoral college vote
in favor of joebide
its goal was to stop the constitutional
process of the 12th amendment
the peaceful process of transferring
power
between presidents
its goal was to physically prevent
congress from meeting
to do the essential work of our
democracy
here's the worst of it
it worked
for time the insurrection
worked
it succeeded
only briefly
but it worked
the joint session of congress adjourned
for several hours into the next morning
and ceased carrying out its 12th
amendment function
all because of the insurrection
because people violently flooded the
capital
with the goal of striking fear in the
hearts of the people who work there
and to use violence
fear
violence
flooding the capital
these are words
that came out of
marjory taylor green's mouth
now many people are responsible for this
attack on our democracy
most of most of all of course the
individuals that you saw on the
washington post video and many other
places
they defiled the people's house
but they're not the only ones
there were others as well
the leaders
the people who justified who promoted
who supported who assisted who
encouraged this in the days and weeks
leading up to january 6th
march retailer green
is one of those people
how do we know this
we know this from the evidence
let's start by talking about what we're
talking about
as a legal matter in order to be
disqualified from federal office this
green had to have engaged
in insurrection sometime after january
3rd 2021 when she took the oath
your honor you said it yourself it's a
narrow window january third to january 6
2001.
and the evidence
is very clear that in fact
marjorie taylor green
justified
assisted
supported and promoted the insurrection
in that window
that's what the term
engaging in insurrection means under the
law
and we will lay that out in great detail
in our brief next
it's a legal point
but it's a common sense point as well
jefferson davis didn't take up the
musket
and fire on union troops at least as far
as i remember my history
but he was just as much an
insurrectionist as the tens of thousands
of soldiers for the confederacy who did
now the january 3 to january 6th window
can really only be understood by looking
at the facts
of what happened
before that window and before the oath
there's really no dispute about this
either
we have proven that marjorie taylor
green
was an advocate for violence against
government officials
in fact she advocated
violence against the speaker of the
house
the highest ranking member of the house
mrs pelosi
the very house that was attacked on
january 6
2021.
she admitted it
she kind of wiggled there for a second
and then she admitted it and you saw
that with your eyes
treason
the death penalty a bullet in the head
that's what she said
about nancy pelosi
and we have proven that she saw the
invasion of the capitol building
and creating fear
fear is the word that she used
in the hearts of public officials
that she saw that as a legitimate
political tactic
and when she told people
when she was discussing this tactic that
she told them they should feel like they
can act in a violent way
she denied it
not really
she said i don't remember
that's not that's cnn that's fake news
don't buy that
you don't have to accept that
you saw the videos
and you saw the testimony
we have proven
that marjorie taylor green
was very clear on certain occasions
with her supporters
about her support for political violence
she set it
on tape
the price of blood
would need to be paced
if the government took away her freedoms
she wouldn't even admit that that was a
call for violence she
said something about the first amendment
the second amendment a bunch of other
amendments
the price of blood
could not be more clear
now this didn't happen in high school as
mr bob suggested in one of his
objections
this happened in late october of 2020
when she was interviewed by mr dorr
and she was talking about
how her freedoms and the freedoms of
americans could be taken away
by a tyrannical government
it doesn't just come back on its own
these freedoms she said
it has to be taken back
with the price of blood
these are things that marjorie taylor
green said as a private citizen
candidate for federal office but a
private citizen nonetheless
before the 2020 election
and maybe she has the right to say those
things or had the right before she took
the oath
but let's keep going
let's keep moving down the timeline to
the period after the election
and in that period you saw and heard
ms taylor green speaking out
consistently
in claiming that the 2020 election was
stolen by the democrats
i disagree with that point of view
but i respect that people can have that
point of view and it's a perfectly
it's an acceptable part of our political
discourse for better or for worse
but then she said this
not just that the election was stolen
not just that there were ballots that
were fraudulent
not just that
it's time to make objections
perfectly legitimate thing to do
we have no problem with their objections
on the floor of the house
then she said something else
that mask that mr fine spoke about this
morning
came down for just a minute
we can't allow power to transfer
peacefully
like joe biden wants
because he didn't win the election
we can't allow power to transfer
peacefully
you saw and heard it with your own eyes
judge
she said the quiet part out loud
she spoke her truth
in a video
that she made
that she posted on her own facebook page
and that she wanted her hundreds of
thousands of facebook followers and the
untold millions of other people to whom
it would be available
to know
that her point of view
was that you can't allow
we can't allow
poverty power to transfer peacefully
marjorie taylor green said this
when she was a federal official
a right about to be it's not clear
but what we can tell from the context of
that tape
is that she stated her opposition to the
peaceful transfer of power
and it was a stunning
statement
this is not internet
drivel
this is not the dark corners of parlor
this is a person who's a federal
official a member of government
and this wasn't even a rhetorical
flourish on the back of a campaign truck
after a long day
this is somebody who sat down in front
of a camera
and calmly
and carefully told her viewers
we will not accept a peaceful transfer
of power we can't
allow it
and then she said we will not go quietly
into the night
she framed this as an existential battle
a new fourth of july
a new fourth of july
1776.
[Music]
this brings us right up to and into that
critical window
that critical phase of time january 3rd
to january 6th
marjorie taylor green's rallying cry
for violence at the capitol on january 6
were the words 1776.
now i think we all know that those words
have a lot of meanings they mean a lot
to me
they are on the on the seal of the great
state of georgia and i venerate that
but that's not what marjorie taylor
green was talking about
and here's how we know this
because here's what we've proved
marjorie taylor green organized
objections on the floor of the house
and this was not an insurrection
this actually was part of the
constitutional process
and we have no prop no issue with it
but then
marjorie taylor green promoted
encouraged and supported the idea of
large demonstrations in washington
on january 6.
now there's nothing wrong with large
demonstrations either and this is mr
bob's point about the rally on the
ellipse not the insurrection at the
capitol
he says well you know who cares it's a
good thing i agree
people do these things all the time
i've done them as well
and demonstrations are an important and
venerated part of our democratic
tradition
she worked with organizers and made
calls for people to come
and that's not a problem
out of context
out of context it's not a problem
in context
this support was part of the scheme
a scheme where lawful demonstrations
were plan a
the first step
and there was also plan b
what was going to happen
when all the lawful demonstrations
happen
and all the objections on the floor of
the house
were heard
and as everyone knew
they were futile
the votes were there to certify the
election
of joe biden
there was a plan b
and plan b was violence at the capitol
plan b was to physically enter the
capital illegally
not on a tour tourist tour
busting in the windows and doors as you
saw on that video
injuring and ultimately causing the
deaths of law enforcement
to block the certification of joe biden
as the winner of the 2020 election
that's what plan b was
and plan b had a name
that had a code name
1776.
now how do we know
that well the clues are everywhere
on december 30th marjorie taylor greene
tweets out a rumor that
their lawful objections on the floor of
a house may be blocked by a rule change
an allie alexander who she acknowledges
knowing who says she's a friend
he's an organizer of a major
demonstration
he tweets in response to that
1776
is always an option and he refers to
what 500 000 people will do to that
building
if the objections are suppressed by a
rule change
that's what that tweet exchange is about
i don't believe that marjorie taylor
green doesn't read every response to her
tweets and care about them i think she
acknowledged it in truth
and she knew exactly what 1776 meant in
that
context she denied it
sort of not really i can't remember
don't buy it
she knows exactly
what mr alexander was referring to
by the way when when that tweet came out
and that reference came after 1776 we
don't see a response of what what what
is this i don't know what this is about
uh or gee if you're talking about doing
violence in the capital 500 000 people
doing something to that building
i want no part of that
and we heard a lot about
ms green's
saying that she's always peaceful and
she put out comments about peacefulness
never won
before january 6th
only after
that video
after
those press releases after
you got to ask yourself
why is that well obviously the
insurrection
succeeded for only a few hours
and then the tide turned and people saw
it for what it was
and she needed a cover story
marjorie taylor green knew perfectly
well
what 1776 meant
that it meant violence
against the government
overthrowing a tyrannical government and
that that was
plan b of january 6 2021.
she embraced it and she promoted it
and probably the most important
piece of evidence from our point of view
in this case
this plaintiff's exhibitor petitioners
exhibit 27.
this is the short clip
of marjorie taylor green on newsbacks
it's the night before january 6th
she's asked a number of questions about
the objections that she and others are
going to lawfully file on the floor
and
then the broadcaster asks her
so what's your plan
how do you think this is going to play
out
and roll out tomorrow
and our answer is one sentence
this is our 1776
moment
it's a stunning statement
it has no meaning
unless you know the code
it has no meaning unless you're in the
club
it's 1776
it's plan b
it's blocked the certification
it's flood the capital it's used
violence if you have to
this is a message posted
stated on january 5th
in the middle of that window
posted on facebook to where hundreds of
thousands of followers and anybody else
who wanted to see it on january 5th
from a sitting member of the united
states congress
it was her clarion call
people knew what she meant
they knew exactly what she meant
tomorrow is our 1776
moment
now it's interesting that the
examination that mr bob did of his
client
never asked her about that
never asked her about
providing support
to people who were planning the
demonstrations
or providing support for people who
ultimately broke into
and trashed
the people's temple
never asked for any of those questions
she never addressed it
when i asked her she said i don't
remember i'm not sure i don't think so
so what do you have before you your
honor at this point
you have her own words
in context
against nothing
not even a real denial
judge pedro
marjorie taylor green comes to this
court in this nation and she asks to be
a candidate for federal office
she comes with unknown hands
with her hands
her words her actions
she was one of several leaders
who gathered
the kindling
who created the conditions
made it possible for there to be an
explosion of violence
at the capitol on january 6th
and then
she dropped the match
now she comes into this courtroom
and she says she's surprised
and appalled
that a fire occurred
sticks of wood and dry leaves are
harmless in and of themselves
in fact they're natural they're healthy
for these vitamins
rallies
protestations objections on the floor
these are all things that are good for
the republic
they're part of our tradition
but when the conditions are dangerous
some people capitalize on those
conditions
and they add a spark
a flame
that causes all of those things to to
explode into a fire
violence and then
that flame can be in the form of actual
assistance given to people who perform
the acts of violence
like the quartermaster in the
confederate army who passes out the
muskets and the balls
and the rations
but that flame can also be a spark
by words
by signals
by signs by code by promotion by
justification by support by assistance
and that is what marjorie taylor green
did
that's why we're here
your honor we urge you to find that
marjorie taylor green is disqualified
from the ballot under section 3 of the
14th amendment of one of the greatest
political documents in the history of
the world the united states constitution
thank you mr chilly
um
it's quite late but i'd like to take a
couple of minutes just to talk about the
briefing
uh and a couple of things first of all i
would greatly appreciate it if someone
would
get us a copy of this this you know a
blown up version or something just
easier to read i mean i appreciate what
you did mr bob but somebody could do a
better job someone needs to figure out
how to do the uh the old zoom feature
again briefing's due
about you know midnight on thursday
um
a couple of things i want to be sure
that
mr bob one of your objections the first
one i think and the motion to dismiss
was about
the
the fact that this procedure and i know
i can't determine some constitution but
i'm talking about findings
um
about related to the belief
and and the the concerns from which you
voiced your closing argument
i would like to hear what you would like
for me to think about finding i mean i i
mean we haven't really talked about that
very much because it's not
it's not something i can decide but it's
something i need to consider in
particular i think the question of the
word belief and i think i mentioned the
footnote reasonable i mean there's
there's issues there i would appreciate
both sides to comment on that you don't
need to write for the pages but i'd like
to understand your views on that i'm
sure you in court will
um
we mentioned this uh some we're dealing
with some very
ancient historical ancient you know age
i mean you know they're 200 years old
you know europeans laugh at us they live
in houses older than our country uh but
in all seriousness some of these some of
these authorities are pretty obscure as
long as we can find them and pull them
up that's great particularly like if
there's a link and it's public you know
somewhere that's great if it's something
that's really obscure that's not readily
available on the internet you can't
point to it first of all our first
purpose just show it you know tell us
where it is on the internet where we can
find it or you know if it's readily but
it was not a problem uh if that's not
available please supplement your briefs
with copies anything arcane i like that
so that we don't have to spend time
chasing stuff down because we don't have
time a lot of time either
um
obviously i gotta leave it to y'all how
you wanna organize your respective
briefs
uh
we at this point the record has gotten a
little bit
chaotic because we've had so much back
and forth we've had a number of quarters
and so
and i know mr about that in your you've
got your original motion to dismiss a
lot of those arguments which you made if
you're closing
it might help if you don't mind doing it
to maybe put them together again in
light of this hearing and maybe focus on
the streamline so i just don't have to
wallow around trying to look at multiple
documents i'm sure mr joey will do the
same thing
make it really easy on me to kick the
can down the road for me
they get extremely easy on me that's
what i'm hearing is that what you're
hearing
yeah he's like hey yeah i let you guys
talk and uh
right not really my place to say
i can't i can't rule constitutionally
wink
um this is extraordinary
important stuff
thank you thank you and thank you for
the direction
yeah and uh fortunately my associate
molina siebert who's done a really fine
job uh is listening yeah and i'm sure
taking notes so we'll do the best we can
right and again i know again i know and
everybody's running and gunning and i
know you've got there's been an appeal
file to the 11th circuit so i don't know
what your briefing schedule is on that i
know there's there's a briefing schedule
in the in the fourth circuit case
i'm sure you have a lot of fires to put
out and i'm full of confidence in that
but so just
do
i'm sure you'll do the work by the way
y'all do great work i mean everything
everybody's working under excellent
circumstances very quickly and
uh
and everybody's taking it seriously what
needs to be taken so i'm sure it will be
very helpful and we look forward to uh
getting it and
finishing the stage of the
no other than your honor you've really
done a fine job in a very extraordinary
way thank you thank you flattery
i'll come in after hours if you need me
to appreciate everybody scrambling to be
here so with that i think that concludes
the hearing
obviously we're not going to zoom in the
back of our head right there
not here right
there's there's the culprit there's the
slide
so so um i didn't expect it to end quite
quite like that i didn't know if the
judge was gonna make a decision it
didn't seem like it when they started
the closing arguments because he said
you know the briefing and then with the
right weeks it's uh due by next thursday
so yeah the next six days right they'll
they'll get the they'll get the brief
and and um the just i so so we're gonna
make news on this again this is how this
always happens
um it always comes back around i'm sure
i'm almost positive almost positive
that uh marjorie taylor green this isn't
the last time she ends up on the
bonehead of the week poll oh for sure um
just for this one particular instance
this particular thing i mean there's
there'll be plenty other things that
you'll show up like i look at the
situation and i say yeah okay
we were you know we were obviously
hoping for something to come out that
was definitely revealing
um
that that would have been like hey
there's a smoke gun obviously there is
evidence or there are there are moments
right that reveal intent you know uh
whether or not explicitly saying go you
know violence she definitely has a
well i guess
political ads uh or you see your
facebook posts or whatever there is
actual violence being promoted right
right i mean yeah i think the
the most significant evidence
of marjorie taylor's words
and her argument against those words was
was probably the best case to be made in
this hearing
with the public information right
which the where she says we cannot allow
a peaceful transfer of power when she
says those words we cannot allow
a peaceful the only the only right the
only and she actually did it in quotes
the only other alternative to a peaceful
transfer of power quote unquote is a
violent
transfer of power which would be a an
insurrection violence and she says i
don't promote violence i don't promote
violence well
promoting that you can't have
a peaceful transfer of power right is
there if you can't yeah if it can't be
this right look you got to look at it
like binary right if it's not a one it's
a zero and there's nothing in between so
if it's not peaceful then it's the
opposite of peaceful which would be
right
violent right right or or some something
that is uh you know definitely more
intense than peaceful and i think that's
the most significant piece of evidence
that was shown here today and if the
judge if the judge does surprise me uh
and and say marjorie taylor green is not
allowed to be on the belt which i will
be very surprised if he makes that
decision right i will be very surprised
i did not sit here for almost eight
hours listen to all this and not come to
the conclusion uh lightly that i
actually think this judge is going to
make the decision he's going to kick it
and he's going to blame it on the
constitution and he doesn't get to make
constitutional decisions is the thing
that he's going to say right he's going
to blame it on congress and that a
federal judge should make this decision
and really honestly he's going to say
the people should make this decision in
an election he's going to say there's
always an opportunity if the if the
evidence arises that she is an
insurrectionist to remove her from the
ballot uh before the general i mean
there's so many different things he
could say there's so many different uh
scapegoats that he could use right to
not take her
i didn't sit here with you and and all
of the like our viewers which by the way
thank you yes for those who stuck with
us and chatted with us and had your own
little side conversations uh we always
enjoy it so please every day we have
every weekday we have a show right every
monday through friday and i do want to
point out because chris and give smiles
here kristen is a uh is a local hate
watcher and we love we love having
kristin and i think we gathered up a few
new hate watchers today yeah so everyone
let's tell them every single weekday you
can come hate watch monday through
friday right two hours every single day
on youtube twitter twitch don't forget
to go the minus touch facebook page and
promote over their trolls get in the
algorithm there and really help there so
if you got like four devices in russia
and you're watching on all four that
would be get them up different yeah yeah
you're great yeah right make sure that i
will say like i didn't know
i i i'm on the west coast i was up at 6
30 i woke up at 6 20 a.m
for a 6 30 a.m a.k.a 9 30 a.m east coast
time
i've
i've been i have not
taken a break outside of like going to
walk my dogs or something but i've been
pretty much been i've been talking to
you or talking to you and karen or just
watching and listening
and um i will say if anything
uh
this does obviously she's under oath
right she was under oath she said things
she
um
she said
uh things that can be used now
um as precedent for what you know to
purchase herself in in a later suit or
or what have you but also keep in mind
this is the first
sitting
uh member of congress senate you know
just politician that has had to testify
under oath
to
uh to to discuss january 6th and their
role in january 6 right and that's what
this really boiled down to it's like
what did they do around january 6 that
would either make her
uh ineligible for for the ballot and
like we said you know probably won't
happen they'll probably kick it down
they can because obviously this is like
someone else's decision to be made right
but um
what is said here is on the record under
oath will be used if need be for
further cases um or follow-up
um
and i think i think you make a good
point i think you make a good point
because like i said
anything she said here under oath um is
it can and will be used against her in a
criminal court because i think that's
the significance here that a lot of
people might miss in this decision if
they're disappointed which i think
you're gonna be if you're hoping she'll
be removed from the ballot is that this
is not a criminal court that's not what
this is so the bar
the bar to remove her from the ballot in
this instance is a hell of a lot lower
than even convicting her in a criminal
court it's like a criminal case they're
gonna have to have even way more
evidence right than what they would even
collected uh today and presented to the
judge and again we appreciate all you
guys uh sticking with us here's what
we're gonna do
tomorrow i'm going to edit um this down
to put on the audio directories so
normally what we do is after the show is
done we post our audio version on all
the directories spotify google
you can go download
all the podcasts over there and get
caught up if you're not
but we're going to edit this down for
the audio version
um to about a couple hours probably like
we normally do we'll put a lot of the
kfa back and forth we had we'll put this
in the end we'll put bonehead of the
week in there but we're also going to
cut out bone of the week and post it on
youtube like we normally do so you guys
can find that because it will be
difficult to find it in this eight hours
of video so we'll do that for you as
well um
make sure to subscribe to the youtube
channel and so you don't miss any other
episodes rather you're whether you're
hate watching or you're love watching
right because we love having you here
and we're glad that you guys stuck
around all day we really wanted to air
this we thought it was significant i had
no idea it would go eight hours but it
did and we stuck with it all day because
you guys stuck with us so we really
appreciate that make sure
make sure you go to our podcast page um
on twitter as well at toni michaels pod
follow us there you'll get the bow net
of the week poll every single week
today was friday and it was a little
unconventional because of this marjorie
taylor green hearing right but we did do
bone end of the week as we promised in
the technical second hour of the podcast
it did happen
so we try promises made promises kept we
it was very very short yes but
it's only because we had a very short
recess to make it right right i think we
had about the we had about 20 minutes to
do the weekend which normally we do it
we it usually ends up being about 40
minutes right yeah it's usually about 40
45 minutes we actually actually give
you know in in-depth or
well we want to do a little surfing we
didn't do a lot of surfing today
and it's been pretty much locked in on
the right and at the end of the podcast
you know we always say surf's up
[ __ ] but we almost can't say
surf's up today
what i want to say is
go take a [ __ ] nap like like uh get
some rest this was uh this was brutal
today in some parts with deputy dog as
uh marjorie taylor green's attorney
was super boring he couldn't lean into
the mic he couldn't figure out how to
zoom he didn't know technology um they
made really stupid arguments what do
they think the arguments that needs to
be pulled from this and people need to
go check out is the argument that he
tried to make when he tried to um make
it seem as if the kkk
didn't incite an insurrection they were
they were just um
and he tried to he tried to make it like
compare what marjorie taylor
green has done with the kkk it was kind
of gross i mean not kind of it is
[ __ ] gross yeah but that's what he
did in a in a court
in atlanta georgia of all places uh this
this attorney for margie taylor green
made that comparison uh from marja
taylor green to the kkk
uh and it's um not surprising really i i
think that's par for the course but i do
want to thank everybody again for and
gabe
man gabe was on almost all day long
i'm sure
i'm sure that there's someone there is a
a nap in my face oh yeah yeah cause gabe
was up early because gabe yeah i woke up
i woke up fed the dogs sat down in the
other because i usually do it in this
room but i had to do in the other room
uh that early in the morning
and
uh yeah did you even get the stream soda
today at all you know what i did get
some sodas during your break yeah you
know again if sodastream wants to oh
yeah advertising on the show no no no no
please i'm not saying we're not going to
but
this guy yes i did i did get some i had
some earlier i drank it you know oh okay
so you still have the soda see i just i
just drink like water the water right
well i mean it's the same thing i just
put co2 in it you know it's fancy water
yeah fancy yeah
you and your fancy water well uh some
significant things that happened today i
thought the the most boneheaded moment
of almost all of it
on on the petitioner's side uh not
martin there's a lot of boneheaded
moments on marjorie taylor greensight
but the petitioner side is when they
played the clip of independence day i
was like oh my god are we really going
to do this where he's going to play the
clip just so to prove that she knows
that those words
are from independence day and then he
tried to do it again in the closing
remarks and it wasn't i don't know why
he thought that was going to be
effective yeah
if it was
if there was any video that could have
been shown it would have been if like oh
there was ted cruz and there was right i
don't know who else said it if let's say
hypothetically it was like cruz and
gosar and brooks and holly right to show
that it was a consistent message in
order it was like hey look we need to do
this but i 100 agree like i looked at
him like uh it's getting a little
conspiracy like connecting the like you
got red dots or like lines and dots
around here to be like well it's a quote
from a movie which is actually quote
kind of a quote from a poem which is
actually quote from here like you're
trying to make this connection and i
look at and i say
it was a bit of a stretch i get what he
was trying to do but at the same time
it's like it makes it feel like you're
grasping at straws right right and it
didn't really help the argument no it
did well it didn't help any argument
really other than she didn't know what
movie it was or she pretended like she
didn't know what movie it was from right
it was really [ __ ] stupid um i i
think i think um
if they lost the judge like in arguments
that might have been a point where they
actually lost him because they were like
really you're gonna play a [ __ ] clip
from a movie because she used one quote
um not that that quote is insignificant
in what she was trying to say but i
don't think playing the clip or proving
that she's watched that movie before it
had anyone been quoting you know right
right right i mean i think i think the
language around the 1776 was a little
flimsy from the petitioner's side but
that was a stronger argument than the
stupid [ __ ] movie quote
yeah i mean again again it definitely
goes again or goes to the like if you're
gonna really go
hammer down the the the code the code
language the code words whatever to show
there was intent or you know malicious
intent
um to incite then
i think there needs to be more examples
especially again from other people from
the party who were you know speaking at
the rally or who are pushing that
narrative or messaging and uh were
actually the ones who are like
proponents or right right
well i mean and that and that is goes to
the actual case the heart of it and i
think that's the decision that this
judge has to make
was she was she planning and inciting an
insurrection or was she advocating for
the first amendment right right like
what and and for her vote
um to to object what what was her intent
and that is where it's at was she an
advocate or was she an insurrectionist
that's kind of the decision and really
the judge doesn't have to make that
decision he can say i'm going to let
someone else make that decision exactly
yeah which i think is it's a big it's a
big thing and
um
is like you know
what at what point are you protected or
not protected under the first amendment
right like the example that karen
discussed with us that we've heard
before is you go into a crowded theater
and you yell fire and if somebody dies
or you know some accident happens you're
not protected by the first amendment you
know in that type of scenario so you
look at this and say
right because you're inciting something
you're not advocating like you're not an
advocate for the advocate for the safety
of the of the theater you're actually
inciting um something at the theater uh
i actually you posted let's before we go
i want to play
um that video real quick that they
played in open court um and i think you
reposted it here let me um
let me share this screen here because i
think it's significant and and the
reason why is it's because it actually
says the thing
that um
you posted margery taylor green the
quote is
you can't allow
to just transfer power peacefully like
joe biden wants and allow him to become
our president and i think because the
alternative is to violently
not let joe biden become president but
here is that video one more time for the
audience
and this is an important time in our
history we can't allow this just to just
to be gone you know just to let it go
you can't allow it to just transfer
power peacefully like joe biden wants
and allow him to become our president
because he did not
win this election it's being stolen and
the evidence is there the mainstream
media for four years talked about
russian collusion conspiracy theories
and lies and demanded investigations
non-stop into russian collusion
non-stop but yet they refused okay i
just want to let everyone know i didn't
cut that video and then that's that's
her taking the video as well and that's
her on the video yeah as much as she
doesn't recall [ __ ]
this is what now what she said you know
there is truth behind what she said
there is there was voter fraud now it
you know unfortunately for the
republicans that voter fraud was within
their own party right four people from
the villages in florida alone we had the
one guy uh
both who two of them uh last week were
actually actually pled guilty and they
were received white guy sentences
exactly there's the one trumper who
killed his wife and you know
voted for her on the ballot there yeah
voted for him her her mother and his
mother right yeah yeah there's you know
so when when the party looks and says
and looks out and proclaims voter fraud
it's a little bit of projection because
all the cases that we've actually seen
from voter fraud is within the
republican party and those people who
voted for trump or killed people to vote
for trump
um which is insane to think about right
well i mean it is it is they are
trumpers so right right and and it's
like oh you've got uh the aeg of texas
who's like hey
um if anyone can prove that there was
voter fraud meanwhile people like okay
yeah cool there found one here found in
here where's my bounty where's my reward
that you promised
um
but yeah if you look at that you're like
oh where's the actual voter fraud
happening it's within the republican
party so yeah it is projection it is the
party the same party who says protect
the kids we got to keep them safe are
the same people
in those uh republican
seats who are the ones uh getting caught
right right like actual actually sex
trafficking or child pornography or
child molestation like there's all these
cases that have come up recently and
continue to come up well i mean i mean
think about it just in tennessee we see
where they're trying to pass a bill
where they can make it legal for to
marry children and we have two tennessee
reps one who's been convicted and one
who married a child bride i mean this
this is not this is not a situation
where um
this projection that that marjorie
taylor green and republicans have been
doing since 2016
under the tutelage of the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy's pants donald
trump himself because that's where they
learned this projection it allowed
people to use racism it allowed them to
use hatred and it allowed them to to use
this projection that we're talking about
as a political weapon when before
it wasn't as effective because people
would catch on to your hypocrisy right
and they would catch on to your
projection quickly they just completely
ignore it because they don't need to
take sides right like they can donald
trump can hate the coveted vaccine and
love it all at the same time right he
can he can love both of them he can be a
sexual assaulter where he grabs [ __ ]
and he loves women and respects women
he's the most respected women and he can
he can not like black people in white
neighborhoods in suburbia but he can be
the least first racist person in the
room all at the same time i mean this is
this is the thing that they do best and
they're going to continue to do it under
trumpism and the only way to stop them
is not to rely on a judge in georgia to
take them off ballots it's not folks
that is the lesson we need to learn
today is this hearing we we are not
going to stop these fascists from
creating a fascist state like ron
desantis is trying to do in florida
by taking them off ballots the way we
take them off ballots is to [ __ ]
engage and engage in our democracy and
be pro-democracy and go [ __ ] vote and
i don't just mean marking a ballot i
mean getting involved doing what you can
do inside your democracy even talking to
people
i've been saying this for the last week
since ron desantis wanted to ban math in
in florida just ask people around you
who you know
say ask them the question did you hear
that republicans in florida are trying
to ban math
that is the question you ask they're
going to say
what what are you talking about because
they have not heard that story right
they will not hear that story yeah they
won't they'll hear they'll heal woke
disney's bad disney's bad disney's bad
but they will not hear the story that
ron desantis is trying to actively
remove 54
math books from curriculum in florida
they will not hear that because they're
trying to destroy public education
they're trying to destroy our democracy
little by little uh inch by inch with
inside and that is the whole point of
today and that's why i wanted to make
sure that we aired this it is so
significant is because marjorie taylor
green ultimately she was she wasn't just
an insurrectionist on january 6. she is
still an insurrection she still wants to
tear down our democracy she does not
want our democracy to live she does not
want she does not want equality she does
not want equity for all she definitely
for 100 does not want liberty for all
she does not believe in that she does
not want that she has projected that
into the universe over and over and over
again she did it today
in various ways but i'm telling you i'm
telling you if you don't participate if
you don't participate we cannot rely on
judges in an administrative hearing down
in
georgia and atlanta to save our asses
and save our democracy we must do it
ourselves that is how it's always been
done we the people can
can advocate for pro-democracy and
participate in it and that is how we do
it so
um gabe thanks for sticking with us all
day and the kfa if you're out there
listening everyone go follow uh midas
minus touch's legal af podcast now go
listen to karen uh on her wednesday
episode and listen to the saturday
episode i'm sure ben myself and michael
popock will have a lot to say about this
hearing today um tomorrow on their
episode they'll air it on youtube and
then i think on sunday is when they air
it on the um
the podcast directories but go check
that out uh make sure to follow karen on
twitter at kfa legal thank you karen for
your commentary today thank you
everybody for joining us i think i'm
gonna go have a beer and a nap i think
that's what i'm going to do gabe what's
your what's your plans here that sounds
pretty good if you're in a nap are you
are you going to do that are you do you
show the stream beer i don't know i
don't know no why would you soda stream
beer oh it's already it's already
carbonated yeah but i've got a i've got
a little ksa uh
little kosh in the in the fridge waiting
for me you know okay good good take a
little nap maybe have a little snack
okay good good good well go snack go
have a beer everyone have a great
weekend and until monday again noon
eastern 11 central every single weekday
monday through friday youtube twitter
twitch and now from the mind and such
facebook page remember
have a great weekend and surf's up
[ __ ] surf's up
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking